step into a world where Paradise is both
Elusive and infernal with the boundaries
between life and death blur and with the
most profound secrets of existence like
hidden hey everyone Dio here and welcome
to my full length explanation of Hell's
Paradise or jigo kaku's Manga
Masterpiece today we embark on a journey
through each Arc of this extraordinary
story from the captivating island arc
all the way through to the riverine
departure Arc delving into the
Brilliance that is Yuki kaku's creation
H's Paradise is not your typical Runner
M manga it's a testament to the Artistry
of a mangaka who dares to push the
boundaries of Storytelling weaving a
narrative that resonates deep within our
very core the meaning behind house
Paradise goes beyond mere entertainment
it speaks to The Human Condition proving
it the essence of existence itself one
of the most remarkable aspects of house
Paradise is the world that Yuki Haku
meticulously constructed it is a realm
very much like our own world that fuses
together an amalgamation of different
religions creating a rich tapestry of
beliefs and mythologies as readers we
are immerse in a universe where a
variety of e and faiths intertwin where
humans and gods coexist and with the
line between good and evil becomes
blured throughout the exploration of
these four arcs and makeup house
Paradise we will come to appreciate the
sheer Brilliance of Yuki kaku's
storytelling prowess jigokuraku is a
tale that engages both the mind and the
Heart It challenges our preconceptions
delves into the depths of our souls and
leaves us yearning for more just before
we do move forward though and spend the
rest of our day discussing this be of a
series if you want to watch more of
these massive story explain videos just
like this but for a variety of different
series then be sure to hit that
subscribe button and push this video to
5K likes so that I know you want more
either way sit back grab some snacks and
get ready as we delve into Yuki kaku's
Masterpiece as we kick things off we
find a young restrained man who's just
been betrayed by his comrades on a
recent Mission before bringing the sword
down he asks him for any passing words
but the infamous Gabby Maru the hollow
simply replies nah so you see
decapitation demands exemplary sword
Technique One in which only a few have
ever been able to master typically the
spectacle turns into a brute fist that
transforms the grounds into an arena of
Hell however as this sword comes down at
top Gabby Maru it leaves everyone
absolutely blown away once it snaps and
cl us to the ground upon touching his
skin having managed to survive the
initial execution gabimaru wonders why
he won't die he knows that he doesn't
have any kind of attachment to life as
to his core he's a ninja not someone who
sees the value of of Life later on
during a sentencing he's visited by an
inspector Who records his life story in
excruciating detail they go over
everything from his parents dreams all
of the attempts made on his life how he
actually wants to die and finally how he
was betrayed by his village Chief later
on and after witnessing another failed
execution attempt the same female
questions Gabby Maru stating that he
told her he wished to die and yet it
appears is though we just resisted his
execution she asks him why a man with no
reason to live would do such a thing
sitting there Gabby Maru explains that
he was the best of the best inur and
because of this he was able to marry the
daughter of his villager's Chief however
after getting together he couldn't
tolerate her and requested a me him with
a chief to end it being restrained upon
entry into the house though the chief
states that he would allow Gabby Maru to
leave her but only on the condition that
he would complete one last mission then
out on that said Mission the moment he
learned that he had actually been set up
he also realized that if he tried to
evade capture then the I gurri Clan
would track him down for the entirety of
his life so because of this he decided
to throw in the tow and give up then
skipping forward to another series of
failed executions like oh my Lord the
actual insanity and pure beauty of the
art in the story is freaking phenomenal
like like look at this man after
surviving the Boiling Pot anyways
anyways so finally the inspector who had
been recording gab maru's past tells the
other men around her that the
preparations are complete having
collected gab Maru from his cell he
slowly walked to yet another room and
watch he assumes that they'll fail
executing him again yet after opening
the door it's revealed that the female
who had been questioning him is actually
a Slayer named yamad asimon sigiri so
this Yamada asimon is the name handed
down over generations to the Ronin from
the Yamada Clan who were known to be
extremely skilled with a sword and they
trained their Blades by cutting down a
multitude of different people as sigari
prepares to bring her blade down on
Gabby Maru she tells him that his wish
is granted since in death approaching he
realizes that this woman is indeed
genuine and instinctively flexes
destroying the shkel holding and
restrained quickly dating in behind
ninja sigari attempts to slice down on
him with a katana but gabim Maru swiftly
Dodges at the last second again dodging
a quick flurry of strikes from sigi
Gabby Maru starts to wonder why he's
refused to accept his fate and die as
more thought fall start to surround the
duo sigari tells him that the blade
reflects one's true nature some may
Bluff and keep a brave fa at a Bitter
End some turn desperate and cling to
life While others deceive themselves
into accepting death to her it's
extremely obvious that there is a great
emptiness within him and it's fairly
evident given the life he's LED she
tells him that he does indeed have an
attachment to life staying that he loves
his so-called dimwitted wife to Gabby
Maro her very existence gives him a
reason to live in the first place
lunging at her Gabby Maro attempts to
slice the Gary but she easily blocks and
confirms her Theory she wonders if he's
refused to be executed because he still
has feelings for her but he's also tried
to convince himself that he actually has
no reason to live screaming at her to
shut up Gabby Maru jumps back and yells
asking what the hell she would know
about this messed up world that they
live in he is the infamous Gabby Maru
yet as our broken man goes to scream the
name that brings Terror to the hearts of
even the strongest men his cut off by a
memory of his beloved wife telling him
that he really isn't Hollow after all no
he's not the cold-hearted demon he's
made out to be he's full of kindness and
the only one who can stand a gaze upon
her deformed face after a small but
super cute moment together she says that
this confirms it there is no way that he
could actually be hollow inside yet in
reality now he continues to scream that
he is Gabby Maru the hollow a completely
heartless monster he tried his hardest
to live a freak conormal life but it's
just not possible living somewhere
peaceful a normal life like Ordinary
People he hasn't allowed any of that all
of a sudden though sigari disagrees with
the statement and presents to him a
document saying that he would be
pardoned for his Crimes by the Shogun if
he could complete a certain task he
would have to travel to the other side
confused about what she meant by this
gabimaru asks if she meant death but
aary elabor at that the other side is
actually the pure land or Heaven A
revered holy realm since ancient times a
place of joy and plenty where none will
suffer which has just been recently
found in They Se Southwest far beyond
the ryuku kingdom by the way this ryuku
Kingdom or like the islands that the
ryuku kingdom was in are the SE of
islands that hold Okinawa and stretch
down towards like Taiwan and stuff I
wonder if Taiwan could be the like
supposed land that they're referring to
here or I wonder if it's just a random
Island made up for the story but it's
quite cool to wonder if if it could be
part of her own world in general anyway
anyway questioning the fairy tale like
Story scary explains to him that in
pursuit of the elexa the Shogun had
already dispatched a research team to
the island however the single boat that
had returned was filled to the broom
with flowers and a foot with some
organic material instantly they sent out
five more boats but not a single person
among them ever returned as for the
things that did they could barely be
called human the next team to head to
the island shall consist of those
already Marked for Death so because of
this sigari is here to actually recruit
someone she sees fit she seeks a man of
talent but someone still with a strong
will to live saryi explains to gabimaru
that his wife is still alive but has
turned inwards from the moment he was
captured and now speaks to no one and
refuses almost every meal zi thinks that
only one can guess what's on her mind
but tells Gabby she suspects that she's
waiting on his return and so because of
all of this that have rambled on about
she asks him if he is still attached to
his life will he traveled to this crazy
ass island with a bunch of goons to
complete his pardon and return to his
wife as that is the only hope of ever
having a reunion with her standing there
with tears in his eyes as he remembers
his wife's words of encouragement he
asks sigari if she wanted to see some
ninjja too then as she responds
affirmatively he tells her to watch
closely before Sparks of fire start
lighting turning Gabby Maru into a ball
of flames as he States NPO atic Blaze
and an absolute blaze of power Gabby
Maru effortlessly takes out every single
one of the surrounding guards before
taking the demon L tuna place above a
pile of scorched men and confidently
stating that she can count on him he'll
find the so-called elixe of life going
into a flashback now sigara remembers
the first time she saw her father
skillfully executed criminal so
skillfully in fact that they dude didn't
even realize what happened from that day
onwards she wanted to pursue a career as
an executioner later in her life and
after completing her first clean cut
she's congratulated by the clueless men
nearby sigara herself knows though and
is also reminded of her true weakness by
her superiors each time she executes a
criminal it's explained that when there
is still fear inside one's blade that
doubt and fear will deliver an agonizing
death to The Condemned the blade
reflects the truth in all things a blade
drenched with fear causes the condemned
to suffer which in turn weighs down
one's blade even further being drowned
in her fear scary wonders how it's even
possible to overcome this how is she
ever able to R herself of this fear and
doubt like her father once had back in
the present day now we find all of the
law Breakers along with the people who
brought them to the capital seated in
front of the 11th Shogun Lord Tokugawa
Nar Yoshi one of his goons explains the
confidential Mission being offered to
them if completed it will give them a
full pardon by decree of the Shogun
himself even still after telling the
criminals to remove their blindfolds he
shows them the amalgamation of flowers
that had returned back from the land one
absolutely ried dude he like nah n no
I'm out of here bro I don't want to
chill with these weirdos gets up and
goes to leave suddenly though his head
is cut clean off as at that moment the
same guy screams to more information
informing every criminal that they the
Yamada asimon will accompany them to the
island this is mainly due to the fact
that their death sentences are already
determined and they don't need anyone
trying to flee once making it to the
island the criminals are told that if
they make one wrong move or try to turn
once landing on the island then they'll
instantly be taken out then finally just
before ending his explanation of what
awaits them he states that they' like to
cut down a few of the numbers telling
the multitude of Ruthless criminals to
go on and reduce the amount of
participants as the massacre begins
filling the fat Shogun with Glee we see
one young man who's obviously on another
level when it comes to straight hands
man takes out a few small fries before
it skips over to auna Wei who by herself
had apparently taken down a bunch of
retainers in the sigwa castle the
previous year back with sigiri she's
approached by Yamada asimon eizen who
was that guy who shanked the foto
criminal just before anyways as the two
begin to talk he tries discouraging her
from partaking in the mission literally
saying that she should be in the kitchen
not in the bed or which is just kind of
crazy Zari explains to him though that
she would have chosen that life if it
was a possibility but their Clan test
their blades on bodies and turn the
remains of those fallen into medicine so
due to these circumstances her life
inherently revolves around the dead and
as much as she tried to ignore it she
just couldn't as she knew from the time
of her father that blade reflects the
truth in all things a few criminals then
try to attack sigari but fail as she
manages to decapitate them but just like
previously she's instantly dragged down
by the grotesque fear cing through a
blade notice seen this gab Maru points
out that she was still shaken when she
takes her alive but States he'd rather
avoid unnecessary killing as to him that
seems perfectly normal having overheard
this one of the guards points out to a
large group of criminals and commands
them to take down Gabby Maru stating
that doing so will guarantee their
participation seeing as he had no other
choice in the matter now Gabby Maru
proceeds to brutally murk all of the
criminals trying to attack him after
seeing the hollow himself literally go
demon mode sari comes to the realization
that instead of trying to kill without
fear she needed a try bear the weight of
her fear and the lives she takes just
like Gabby Maru does she sheds a single
tear and declares that she will be the
one to execute Gabby Maru so after the
complete Beatdown that we just got to
witness is finished the participants are
finally revealed we have the scar up G
Bandit King aacho blade Dragon Tamaya
gantet suai Hunter of the hundred warped
Kon everyone's favorite nugi of the
Sanka The Killing Buddhist prayer hubo
stray ninja gabim Maru the hollow
cannibal corisan akanu kunoichi Yara of
kesu moru Makaya the opposite and
finally the giant of be in Roku Rota
remember all of these names along with
like each disciples from the yada clan
that will be paired up with them they
all kind of get revealed at different
moments throughout the early moments of
this island obviously anyways anyways
moments after the massacre was completed
all 10 survivors were loaded onto a
large ship and sent towards their
freedom supposed Freedom they would like
to think after arriving on the island
Gabby Maru tells sigiri about the iures
chief's Immortal body and how the elixir
of life may actually exist though he
doubted it would be on the island
because of the unnatural environment he
then easily frees himself of his
restraints stating that they don't know
what they could possibly encounter but
Zira refuses to allow him to do whatever
he pleases and demands that he put back
on the restraints not listening to her
Gabby Maru instead goes on about the
ridiculously small amount of supplies
along with little to no direction on
where to go once arriving stepping back
cigari holds her blade to get throat and
commands him to rebind his hands she
reiterates that they are not Partners
she is his executioner and should he
fail to find the elixe well she simply
couldn't kill less clearing her voice
she once again tells him to bind his
hands in which after sign he replies
that he gets it and rebinds his hand
stating that he'll go along with these
little rules but only up to a certain
point then out of freaking nowhere Gabby
Maru suddenly bends his neck back like a
snake dodging a thundering strike from
warped Kon having bounced back out of
the way Gabby Maru instantly points out
to sigiri that the Gabby Maru instantly
points out to sigiri that the criminals
arms were not restrained which I
absolutely love like instant rebuttle
anyway overreacting herself sirur
questions the ranked to sester Yamada
asimon K show as to why he wasn't
following the rules thinking that he's
been ignored by the hollow Kon charges
at Gabby Maru and pulls out a full case
of weapons to attack him with he states
that the weapons can only shine after
they bathed in Blood and soon his entire
body will learn the beauty of his art
Gabby Maru who's just like Blown Away
with the weirdness of his new opponent
explains to him that if he keeps up with
how he's going then eventually the other
criminals will overtake him in his race
to the elixe yet Kon rebuttal him as he
actually thinks it'll be a best case
scenario to take out all of the other
competition first being left with no
other choice gab Maru decides to take
him out yet warped Kon instantly charges
in and attacks with a huge two-handed
spear that shatters upon connecting with
the top part of his head quickly he
changes a stance and since the hollow
shooting back what they jab to his body
with the spear however it had absolutely
no effect on on Gabby Maru who like the
legend he is was just double-checking to
make sure his hands were still tied
together he then somehow manages to P
the spear under his arm and fling the
giant upwards directly above him with a
bunch of the weapons falling down he
returns the falling weapon are that had
just fallen out of the Armory was imp
perfectly balanced kicks jumping back
sary wonders if Gabby Maru somehow
defeated him with one blow yet Kon
actually managed to survive after
revealing that he was wearing a thick
armor coating underneath his clothing
getting back up he states that the
legendary Hollow skills sure are amazing
but they weren't legendary enough to
pierce through his living armor he
prepars to fight Gabby Maru once more
telling the small demon that he doesn't
understand the use of weapons and
couldn't display the beauty of his Blade
with his previous attack but now he will
teach him its true beauty yet apparently
this man is completely fodder and
doesn't even deserve three panels
explaining what happens as instead he's
instantly finished by the scattered
weapons that had fallen to the ground
just previously as Gabby Maru walks away
from the mess he sigh and shows the
surprise retainers he never even removed
his bindings during the fight over with
the other group and while rokoto was
being transported which is like the
massive giant looking dude it takes
three vessels tied together to even pull
this giant along looking at the size of
them the random staff members become
worried overthinking the possibilities
that the giant could awake and go on a
rampage but Eisen the schools rank one
assures them that this is literally the
reason they're here no one is immune to
their Cuts back with our main group Kio
had actually moved into attack and it's
revealed that warped con was taken by
surprise being merked in the process due
to his prisoner dying kishu advises the
others that he's going to hit home as he
really doesn't have a reason to stay
anymore scary tries warning him about
the 60 men that we must seen on the
island and helping with finding them but
the swordsman though just find it a
complete waste of time to be worrying
about others and in fact considers
themselves lucky to be able to make an
escape he warns her that the criminals
with them have already made their move
the individuals who have never cared for
society's laws and the rules that the
Shogun gave them should not be taken
seriously since it might risk their
chances of acquiring the elixe of law
life in his eyes rather than taking the
rules literally surely the Shogun it
would be more pleased with success at
any cost he points out Gabby Maru as a
prime example asking if she preferred he
was cut down now and she ran off having
heard enough though Gabby Maru silences
KES show getting all up in his face and
telling him nothing else mattered all he
wanted was to get back to his wife kesho
tells him to hurry up then and snidle
warns the hollow ninja that within a few
hours everything will have changed back
with Eisen and probably had at somewhat
of a similar time seeing that the giant
had risen he asks him if he's hungry but
immediately notices the blood lust
emanating from his criminal any Flash
the two don't even trade word but
immediately go to attack sadly Isen Ain
living up to the aura that that name
hold and was literally slapped like a
bug by Roku Rota honestly a complete
change from all of the other series with
an eizen plus with him being rank one I
was also expecting him to be insanely
skilled yet we never even get to see his
true potential obviously as kho then
continues his ominous statement it darts
around the outskirts of the island
revealing the dismay that is erupted in
the other groups kishu explains that
apparently an emissary was already hied
to IA kakur to help them with this
Mission he knows the limits of his
strengths and tells thei that this
Mission will likely determine the next
head of the yada Clan then with him
having warned him about the coming
possibilities he finally makes his leave
taking this all in she tries to pass off
the idea that Gabby Maru would even make
a move to attack her however just as she
asks where they should go next Gabby
looking shell shock darts at sigari
trying to strike down baffled and
angered with the change in his attitude
she just asks him why what could
possibly be the meaning of this standing
there Gabby Maru thinks back on the
moments after his birth and how his
parents tried to escape the village with
him but were sadly slain the aar's chief
cruy used this moment to shape the child
telling him to look upon their weakness
he states that because of his parents
sentimental love it made them weak and
if he doesn't grow into a strong man
he'll end up like his parents incapable
of protecting even his loved ones later
in life Back In the Heat of battle and
after learning what kesu had to say
about EA gak getting involved Gabby
muray knew that it would all be over for
him he won't have the luxury of taking
time and protecting random people on his
path to find the electure and because of
that he was left with no other choice
than to take out sigiri dashing in the
two let loose a flurry of strikes
causing constant Sparks to fly off the
clashing pieces of metal thinking
herself saryi wonders why she's
hesitating why hasn't she been able to
write him off as just another villain
opposing her Gabby m also confused
wonders why why is he wavering before
then remembering his wife's words on how
it's only natural that he doesn't want
to follow through with taking her out
instead it's best to follow your
sentimentality he's different now he
isn't the hollow man he once was it's
not a form of weakness but a formal
strength and it will guide him into a
pure Warrior unable to throw away the
beliefs he grew up with though gab Maru
can't help but fall back into darkness
knowing that he's learned of weakness
using his hand like a spear Gabby bursts
through his bandages putting Gary easily
within range but once again hesitates
allowing her to notice in time and
deflect the strike the two once again
slash at each other but they both know
that their own damn emotions are slowing
them down remember in the old fight as
though the dude has some kind of hold
over his thoughts Gabby Maru takes
things up a notch proceeding to straight
up cut her sword in half and as she
stands there in utter shock seemingly
finishes the job yet somehow it's
revealed that sigiri had used her sheath
to deflect the killing blow momentarily
baffled Gabby just tells her that
resisting is useless as he knows she
can't bring him down with a sheath alone
he apologizes for what he has to do
however sigiri again hits a nerve within
him by stating that she didn't realize
he was capable of feeling such sentiment
given his reputation agreeing that he
doesn't Gabby Maru blitzes sigari
appearing on top of her any massive
smoke and fire before he could kill her
though he is once again reminded of his
wife's influence and stops himself from
taking her out appearing on his shoulder
the chief's thoughts taunt Gabby trying
to get him to take out his retainer
leaning over her he tries to will him
himself to push forth and do something
he's done thousands of times before but
he can't as his wife's separation is
able to destroy the emotions controlling
him laying below the broken man saryi
realizes that throughout the entire time
she's knowing him he's worn an
expression of utter pain like he was
uring something for her she was able to
see this and it actually allowed her to
comfort the emotions she had kept hid in
with Gabby not being able to bring
himself to do what he needed to do he
begins crying believing that with the
way he is he won't be able to survive on
the island or ever see his wife again zi
though realizes that this isn't weakness
what he has is love for his wife which
shows for a fact that he can feel
emotions still lying there she promises
him that if he faces his emotions while
reclaiming his life then she will
support him throughout the journey
finally sigari tells Gabby Maru to show
her what he's capable of as even though
their inherent relationship hasn't
changed he is no longer the same man he
once was ah so I absolutely love these
next two characters they get introduced
throughout this part of the story here
completely Polar Opposites but uh damn
they're both so cool in their own kind
of way so in the pass the hulking giant
G tiu side when by the name blade Dragon
eight provinces unparalleled after
arriving in a certain Province a Dio who
shared the similar title offered him
work and food so he decided to take him
up on the offer after a couple of drinks
though the dimeo insisted that even with
his nickname he doubts he could ever
take down an actual Dragon utterly
insulted with the idea that he couldn't
take down a dragon gitu side destroyed
the dragon statue at to the entrance way
to the Doo's residence along with the
whole gate obviously as you like may
have suspected this resulted in him
being kicked out of his own Clan and
sentenced to death hence how the man
ended up on the mission here to the
island having revealed his past to his
retainer who's the rank nine Yamada
assign on fui gusai tells him that once
he gets his pardon and walks free he
will return to cut down that silly old
Doo's Mansion fui who's just standing
there usly fails to comprehend how even
came to that being a good conclusion gen
suicide jokingly mocks the tiny retainer
and makes a few negative comments about
the yada Clan peeved fuku draws out his
sword and tells him to not make fun of
the clan causing gitu side to back away
from the blade feeling a deadly blood
lust coming from the midet not
escalating the argument the big man just
tells him to not get in his way before
freeing himself from his bindings he
then explained his part of eliminating
the other competition around criminals
wise so he can take the extra time with
finding the electure and safety fui
takes note that only a few criminals
will survive the trials on the Island
and if the Shogun becomes impatient
because of that he will call upon a
stronger and more venomous batch of
Warriors to be dispatched in their stead
by the way this is like a big thing in
the story here and I hope some people
pick up on it like throughout just let
me know down in the comments if you do
and what not but the symbolism here is
actually taken from real life back in
early Japan they used to put venomous
and sex in a pot and then let them
battle to the death which is absolutely
crazy then they would take the Venom
that remain and use that to curse
someone another big mangaka to like go
out of his way and actually do this in
their series if you've noticed is gami
with some of the recent stuff in the
manga like chapter 215 that uh this is
referenced to but yeah anyway continuing
continuing either way having moved
forward together the two then stumbl
upon some ancient man-made statues not
paying attention to a surroundings G
tipu site is stung on the hand by a
random looking butterfly that had a
human face on it stunned he quickly
remembered what happened to the guard
that had returned from the island and
without a second thought cut off his
hand confusing the retainer with him
looking at his hand though at Shan that
in a matter of moment after having
landed on the ground it started morphing
into a bunch of flowers suddenly from
within the trees around them butterfly
start bursting out causing Gant suicide
to get excited as he prepares to defend
himself against the random creatures
however appearing from behind them once
more a comically large titan-like
creature then starts walking in their
Direction meanwhile Gabby Maru and
sigari are also approached by the same
weird looking creatures with him
confused over what they're seeing
gabimaru steps forth telling sigiri to
stay back looking at it he wonders what
in the world it could possibly be why a
fish it doesn't even look like it's
supposed to be real plus it's got these
random prayer beads as if it's subject
to some sort of religion with his
Instinct screaming danger Gabby Maru
watches as the Beast tries to attack him
easily he's able to dodge the
amalgamation of hands before jumping up
and kicking the monster however the
monster was actually able to block the
blow then having grabbed the Ninja's leg
proceeds to toss him into the ground
causing Gabby to jump back and rethink
his attacking strategy remembering his
Ironclad ninja La number five to avoid
an unfamiliar enemy he thinks about
fleeing the area with theary yet our boy
is taken by surprise as a rope like
extension from the monster grabs and
tosses him through the nearby foliage
wounded from the blow he tells the Gir
that they just need to run for now but
as they go to leave it's showing that a
pathora of these random monsters with
prayer beads and vestments have
surrounded them seeing No Way Out Gabby
Maru clears his head of all other
distractions and goes out of Demon mode
jumping into the sky he easily takes out
the monsters with they punch before
igniting them with with NPO aesthetic
Blaze sigari who's watching in horror
behind him remembers how Gabby Maru
explained that in his clan they go
through all kinds of bizar training and
through that they learn abilities areen
to breathing fire or becoming one with
the sea Gabby Maru having sparked a
light from the use of his technique
knows that in order to survive this
hellish Island and get a pardon he has
to kill anything that gets in his way
watching Gabby Maru fight off the random
creatures sigui thought that she was
prepared to take on the unknown but now
with everything going on around her she
starts to wonder if perhaps this isn't
the pure land but instead then before
she's even able to think any longer a
large bike monster confronts her from
behind Gabby Mara who's fading in and
out of some kind of like visual
experience notices that saryi is in
danger but instead of turning to help
her focuses on taking out the large
creature in front of him himself however
without even realizing it Gabby had
managed to actually attack her creature
saving saryi in the process as Gabby
sits there confused holding her she
thanks him for saving her life but then
again out of nowhere he has his head
wrapped up by one of those creatures
tentacles randomly and the split seen
before the Monster Squeeze down someone
had managed to CER its hold on Gabby
Maru turning around he notices that
three newcomers had arrived and saved
them from the surrounding creatures
usara who's another ninja like Gabby
walks up and makes her introduction wasi
thinks it's odd that a pair of retainers
are escorting her gabimaru thanks them
for intervening but asks why why would
they go out of their way to help someone
when they're under no obligation to do
so USA just try straight up seducing
them to get around the question anded to
teaming up however Gabby Maru pens her
down explaining that that method won't
work on him be like Gabby guys don't be
like Snak don't be a cck boy like sneo
anyway anyway Yara was really trying to
team up with him but before they could
continue as a group sigari asks why
would two people were scor her rank
eight Yamada asimon gji explains that he
was originally in charge of marrow yet
marrow was quickly deceived by usera and
taken out after realizing what she' done
Genji proudly determined that she could
not be left alone which just a single
executioner and decided to watch over
her with the other dude usara explains
that before running into Gabby Maru they
were also surrounded by bugs she knows
that this island isn't exactly the
safest place and because of that knows
finding the elixa and escaping is key
yet if she Wass to run in without a plan
or by herself she'd probably be killed
and it would all be for nothing so due
to the predicament she found herself in
the strategy of playing it safe by
teaming up to find the electure is by
far the smartest after thinking Gabby
Maru accepted her into the group user
tried giving him a hug but Gabby
instantly pinned her down again telling
her that he wasn't in agreement since he
didn't trust them in the slightest
looking at him usera breaks the Ninja's
hold pulling him in close and telling
him that they didn't have to trust each
other and can betray each other whenever
they'd like as after all the elixa is
just with a single pardon if they team
up though she'll provide them with
information regarding the human face
butterflies explaining that they swam
around the monsters and have scales and
AIT poison that cause hallucinations but
are still a mystery overall curious on
how she she figured out all this to
start with Gabby asks how she came to
this conclusion funly enough like
remember marrow from just before well
yera had got hella friendly with him
like she tried to with Gabby then tied
him up to a tree then you know left him
prey to certain bugs to check their
effects from this she was able to learn
that the centipedes by far have the
worst effects but the majority of the
bugs won't really attack you unless you
provoke them Yamada asimon Center who's
like originally USA's executioner
finally speaks up and lets them know
that all of the monsters he seen have
qualities associated with Buddhism and
da those two religions alone have
fundamentally different core structures
so he finds it weirdly and S that
they're Blended together in some sort of
dark nature from just this fact alone he
believes that this Island's true nature
is definitely not pure Zaki agrees like
even though these monsters appear as
Godly beings the feeling her blade gives
her solidifies the idea that they are
simply living creatures to use ARA this
just to me that this is a priority they
communicate and gather more info but
Gabby Maru wondering what's motivating
her to this extent asks why according to
her this is all for her little sister
she suffers from an incurable disease
and due to her situation in life they
couldn't even afford basic medicine in
an attempt to earn money she turned
ninja and took part in hellish training
inside of the kai Clan randomly one day
the boss turned on her and that's how
she ended up here still Gabby Maru
doesn't honestly doesn't believe her
finally revealing what seems to be the
truth though she says that she doesn't
even have a story getting to live and
return home is more than enough for her
wanting to know one more thing Gabby
inquires as to what exactly she did to
her executioner like last time she
insists that he was just used as a
vessel to perform research experiments
on before snidle asking if he really
cares that much about the lives of
others knowing that she contains
information about the island Gabby Maru
agrees to help her with fighting but
other than that did not cooperate as the
others then Becker about what
information to share saryi looks back on
how far she's come since arrived on the
island which in her eyes is pretty much
nowhere she knows that she was
overwhelmed by the monsters and the
entire situation itself has just caused
her to feel flustered disappointed in
herself for how powerless she currently
is saryi drops to the floor fainting
from the effects of the previous battle
going back in time again slightly I
guess we're introduced to TOA who had
managed to earn his license as a part of
the asimon executioners after only a
month of training the only thing
remaining for him to do was the
execution itself funnily enough it's
shown that the had chosen was his own
brother in a turn of events that the
clan isn't even pry to yet Toma had
purposefully infiltrated them so that
the two would later be able to escape
together obviously the way they ended up
escaping or trying to was taking part as
a retainer and Criminal on the trip to
Paradise Island now on the island it's
shown that the two are able to make
landfall But like everyone else have
been surrounded by a pathora of random
wildlife and religious figures watching
chobi Rush forward to protect him Tomy
thinks back on how even when they were
little and had lost their mother to
illness even after their father betrayed
the clan and was sentenced even when the
bandits attacked them without a second
thought troe always figured things out
and adapted to every situation he learns
early on that the law of this land isn't
the strong always win but rather a
survival of those who manage to adapt
best to their situations and
surroundings affecting them by the way
you'll learn all about how the story
teaches us that being strong and weak
are both valuable to someone's
personality it's a much deeper story
than like I really thought when I got
into it I came in under the like the
precedent that it was a darker Shonen
and part of like the dark Trio with CSM
and JJ K and it went crazy with some of
its battles but I had no idea that some
of the things that it tries to teach us
as its readers are truly like good
morals to live by like straight up even
with just Gabby being faithful to his
wife even though he is only 16 and not
that pvy weirdness that other series
tend to have like it's that faithful
love it's it's it's normal anyway let's
get past me being like that weird soy
normal diolo in a different timeline I
don't know where this diolo came from
but anyway moving forth having taken out
a bunch of the monsters the jeo notice
even more approaching and decide to flee
the area rather than take them on as
they try to escape Thomas here is caught
by one of the monsters and while
freaking out screams for his brother's
help however toe continues to run off
left with no other option than to defeat
for himself thas strikes at the large
monster trying to take it down blowing
through the monster though it's shown
that chob had actually just gapped it to
grab a large x from one of the
previously defeated creatures chob is
then struck by another monster taking
him completely by surprise and while
looking at the group beginning to
surround them it hears them all tell
them that killing is a sin standing
there listening to all of the voices
Echo around them Tomy begins to freak
out in a similar way to saryi earlier
chobi on the other hand though like
man's on that demon mode spe becomes
enraged by the speaking of sin and tells
them to shut up he screams as he
destroys the surrounding monsters that
all of them are just slaves silly
puppets stuck to a regimented code of
law and likee them he is his own Master
his own God standing there looking at
her brother Toma admires ch's ability to
adapt his constant unyielding sense of
self is what defines him so when it
comes to like the overall plan with the
brothers right here has changed from
just getting this pardon and escaping
together now chobe states that he will
kill all of these monsters and criminals
on the island before Downing the elixir
of Life themselves back with uh the main
Squad now sigari awakens terrified after
having a nightmare that involved her
father looking down on her gji who's
nearby looking after her while the
others were working brings her up today
on how they've actually taken shelter in
a tree Hollow and she had fainted
because of the toxic powder coming off
the butterflies as saryi then leaves the
hollow she finds Gabby chilling outside
with CA making a meal for the group
outside he brings her up to date
explaining that while looking for
ingredients for the meal he took the
opportunity to check the island out a
bit more pretty much he was able to
deduce that there isn't anything
resembling The Elixir around the area
they find themselves in instead most of
the fora around are like a jumble of
different plants that you could find on
the Mainland with the exception of a few
random flowers Genji suggests that the
plants might be from the ryuku islands
but Gabby explains what really stood out
was how all of the Samurai were in bloom
remember like the initial Squad that
rolled up to the island with only one
returning well yes sadly they' all
Fallen prey to this island as you could
probably Imagine by the way for like
anyone confused with the ryuku islands
again and jig go kaku's Story the
islands are probably like the closest
piece of Japanese land to the so-called
Paradise Island since like the old
school weeb legend himself then gives
his input and tells them how these
statues all scattered about the place
seem to be either Buddhist or DST in
design yet there isn't actually what
intrigues him more he questions if the
technology to create such things even
exist on this island or perhaps their
creator lives elsewhere before he
brought them here zi believes that it's
just unfeasible for anyone to live on
the island to start with since the
creatures make it too dangerous for any
human to exist she then explains how she
detected human traits from the monsters
when she was cutting them but detected
no signs of organs or reproductive
capabilities the monsters forms are
utterly bizarre within possessing some
form of humanoid structure but with bugs
and other creatures riding the top them
Center interrupts and explains it all a
little bit better we know that they're
religious in nature but the details
aren't exactly right as if they're
poorly thought out deities this island
and the Monsters as a whole it's all too
artificial to be the creations of divine
creatures it's as if the group had been
tossed into an ill-conceived mandala an
unfamiliar space with nothing H in Back
to Reality going a crazy expression
Gabby Maru becomes manic after hearing
that creatures without organs exist to
him that sounds like some form of
immortality so if he can find that
Source then he can return home taking
Gabby maru's advice CA says that they
should do more research on the monsters
before they travel any deeper and put
their lives in more danger as the sun
begins to start setting Genji confronts
aari and demands that she return home on
the ship he knows that this isn't a
place for her and due to her criminal
passing away can take her steer in his
eyes anyone who decides to stay on the
island will only face death but Zari
denies his attempts to send her home
instead watching to complete her Duty
Genji questions her skill though and
points out that the blade she now has is
just a random one she picked up along
the way to anyone in the Yamada Clan
they know that the katana is a warrior
spirit and with theary having lost hers
it's as if she's already lost what made
her a Yamada to begin with he doesn't
deny that she is truly skilled with a
blade but this island is different some
weird skill is needed to win battles
here and she's clearly being held back
by one majorly defining Factor her
gender feel some weirdo masculinity Vibe
coming off Yi right now he seemed really
cool up until a moment ago it kind kind
of sucked I like his uh bushy ass
eyebrows either way meanwhile the goats
themselves ranked 10 yada asimon tinza
and his criminal nugi are found on a
small rowing boat attempting to escape
the island nugi brings up that even if
they do manage to leave they'll both die
as they've returned without the electure
thinking that he can get his way through
any scenario T reassures him that he'll
try and convince the hup somehow once
they AB bore the Shogun ship apparently
there is a large vessel that is meant to
be anchored nearby for 3 Days allowing
them to complete their mission and then
return home on that vessel after
pointing out something he thought was
the boat they both disarten to only find
the remains of their ship strewn in
between long ago destroyed ships half
submerged in front of them naruga who
spotted something out of the corner of
his eye tells tza to stop drawing his
sword but it's too late as a massive
tentacle appears behind and swipes set
the two having noticed in time nugo was
able to grab his boy and Dodge the
attack telling him that most creatures
are sensitive to shiny things so they
should just look for an Escape Route
unable to find a boat to escape on the
two become surrounded causing Nuka to
think back on the time he accidentally
leads soldiers to his village back then
he was one of the mountain folk someone
who didn't plach loyalty to the Shogun
it but instead lived traditionally with
Japan having certain rules in this time
period that meant people couldn't live
this way they were instead considered
Rebels against the regime sadly they
used nugi to lure out the locations of
his other family and clan members who
subsequently died from this once impr
present himself naruga had met tenza who
out of the generosity of his heart
offered him a mission to search for The
Elixir as a way to escape imprisonment
confused on what he should do nugo
wonders if he should die for the cic
committed or live on and continue his
Village's bloodline as the last of its
name obviously as we find them stumbling
into K's body which had become blooming
with flowers he chosen the L and decided
take his chances with tenso on the
island as a massive tentacle destroys
even more of the surroundings naruga
looks upon K's body and sees a vision of
his grandfather's last moments causing
him to become frightened and drop to his
knees tinza asks what was worrying him
but nugo asly broken after the decisions
he made in his life note that it really
makes sense now all of this is just a
Divine punishment his true sentence for
causing the deaths of everyone he holds
close as a tentacle beers down upon the
duo tenza was luckily able to slice it
before it took out the R guy and after
listening to his explanation about the
shanas people's Customs tells him that
he doesn't care about the Customs he
believes in he just needs to survive
with morex pushing tza to his limit he
screams that he doesn't want to hear
about his grandpa or the village the
real question is if you want to live or
not thinking back to a peaceful time in
the mountains with his grandfather nuga
says that he doesn't want to die and
instead just wants to return home
throwing him a sword then tensa points
out K's boat telling him to survive as
they fight their way off the wreckage up
now the je are just barely able to
battle their way through the monsters
and make it safely to the shore of
Paradise Island aboard kish's boat from
the efforts to escape the island tenzel
was able to deduce that even if they
find the Elixir it's pointless without a
way off the island he points out that
one boat did manage to make it back to
the mainland so there is some sort of
Escape current but as he turns to look
at Naro GUI he notices something yes
that's right I I fooled you all or at
least I hope I didn't give it away cuz
it's actually revealed that while
they're washing up ttin are noted that
nuga looks extremely feminine T nuga
says that he is indeed a girl shocking
the assignment with the messy reveal out
of the way and the two finnally joking
around TS to says that moving forward
they have to scout around to find a
proper Escape Route but the monsters
also pose an issue so he proposes the
idea of searching for more allies that
also wish to return home which in my
eyes makes perfect sense plus I think
naruga is another really dope character
it's funny how we've got a Yamada who
looks like a chick and TOA and a
criminal that look like a dude and a rug
guy kind of just opposing factors on
each side and in my eyes goes into the
entire theme of Yin and Yang that later
gets spoken about in much more depth
back over with Genji who's really Keen
to make a point on how this ain't no
place for a woman and skiri needs to
take a boat back when Dawn arrives half
wanting to leave herself and half not CA
believes that it would be the best
choice for sigiri to leave but also
thinks that she should stay to watch
Gabby Maru from what he's seen so far he
can say without a doubt that Gabby Maru
was not the same man as he was back at
EO a man only be because he knows that
he needs to return with her but wonders
if there is also some other reason
keeping her here with him with night
falling around them now sigari decides
that she'll watch over the group as they
sleep but Gabby Maru tells her that he
literally doesn't sleep so there wasn't
any need to stay up even still he asked
if she was feeling b as he suspected
that after he wounded her in the
previous battle the poison from the
butterfly probably sped through a
quicker due to how she helped him see
the light he realized that rushing in is
only going to result in disaster for the
group from now on they won't run from
anyone that threatens their chances of
survival or the possibility to reunite
with his wife to meet everyone head on
turning to Ziri he also compliments her
believing she could be even stronger
than himself as obviously he does have
an eye for strength reflecting back on
the time with her in the prison he
states that even then he had felt her
strength they had a say back in our
boy's Village one cannot know one's
strength without first traveling far and
wide most people don't even realize
their full strength until they're forced
to act it's that way for everyone one as
Dawn then finally begins to rise sari
becomes encouraged by Gabby maru's words
and faces Genji telling him that she
appreciates his concern but will not
leave the island the flipping knob gji
finds this ridiculous as This Woman's
only role should be to Bear a child for
the yamar clan having heard that same
thing a million times before sigari
explains her grief growing up telling
him on how everyone including her father
looked down on her for following the
path of a warrior and that now a fellow
Clansman was doing the same she urges
Genji to look at her as a samurai to
acknowledge that this is the path she
took man or woman regardless of
someone's situation they should always
be free to choose their path that's
absolute douche though like Genji what
happened to you dude who hurt you
obviously man is angered by her
statement saying that this isn't the Way
of the Samurai he draws his blade and
goes to strike down on her however as he
stands there talking smack it's revealed
that sigir had managed to disarm and
steal his blade completely perplexing
the bushy eyed freak literally taking a
dump on this man's head sigur reveals
that Genji was originally the person who
taught her had a steal a blade in the
heat of battle Genji getting even mad
screams again that a katana is the
warrior Soul yet unlike sary he's unable
to notice rokua approaching them from
behind during his time as an infant
rokua had I think like accidentally
killed his entire Village and family by
pushing over a tower of stones he built
sending him shooting off like bullets
around the area at least like I I think
that's what happened it looks like
that's what happened back on the island
now gji had managed to turn in time but
just like during his childhood Roa Rota
used the infamous Palm strike to connect
with the samurai sing him spinning back
severely wounded zi runs towards Genji
but is about to be attacked by the giant
luckily for her Gabby Maru arrives on
time Landing a fat head kick to Roku
Rota sending him crashing back through
their surroundings noticing that Eisen
Roku R's retainer wasn't with him sigari
comes to the correct conclusion that
he'd been taken out as soon as they
landed on the island Gabby Maru quickly
goes over the two options Escape or
fight but ultimately decid decides to
take on rokua and tells thei to leave so
that she isn't in danger dodging a
massive tree that takes out a few more
behind it he then looks towards usara
who's Big chilling up in a tree nearby
with center and asks for her assistance
usara though as like nah and reminds him
of the deal providing Intel while Gabby
Maru deals with the fighting Roku rotus
strikes at Gabby Maru once more but he
easily manages to jump back out of the
way and begins to strategize on how to
handle him his insects tell him it's
utterly impossible to guard against his
hand if he hits him it's game over
trying something different he Stomps the
ground causing a few rocks to fly up
before using nimpo Stone storm seing a
plethora of stones into the body of the
massive brute in front of him with the
projectiles not working he uses Nino
unformed blade and goes to strike rokua
yet his attack is quickly deflected Once
More by the hand not knowing what to use
he decides to throw a couple more range
attacks but as you can see by the like
what even is that 1 2 3 seven abilities
used on the hulking giant not a single
one worked leing Gab completely confused
on what his next course of action is
meanwhile in the forest behind them
sigui tries to save Genji which is like
like he girl even Genji who's still on
that weird gender spill finds it strange
that earlier saryi had the attitude of a
man but now has the compassion of a
woman screaming at him seiri says that
it doesn't matter what she is she
doesn't want to see a comrade die with
that said Genji finally accepts some
sort of Enlightenment and realizes that
zakir's conviction was to accept both
sides understanding who she is now he
brings up his sword and gives it to her
to fight Roku Rota and his dead he
screams at her now that if she's a
so-called Samurai then she won't
hesitate to cut down Roku rot taking
Vengeance for him and Eisen over with
Gabby it's obvious that he's still
struggling with coming up with a
strategy to fight Roku Roa but notices
that a appears and swiftly cuts off one
of the Giant's fingers it said that
anybody no matter how sturdy or
unconventional it is can be cleaved the
principles of execution will never
change you just need to know the body's
framework and work it to find your own
openings standing there together now
both Gabby Maru and Zari get ready to
take down Roku Rota together still big
chilling up in the tree nearby USA
watches the two face off against rokua
centa who's currently pinned up in the
tree branches asks to help Genji but
yera tells him that it's too late and
it's much safer to stay up in the tree
watching the fight down below Gabby Maru
tells a that it will be up to her to
finish him off with a singular cut saryi
informs him that in order to do so she
needs him on his knee since the Nick is
up too high literally is Gabby says that
he can pull it off rokua throws a
thundering punch towards Gabby but he
deflects it with a kick leaving her with
a perfect opportunity to drop the giant
sigir Gets behind Rota and while
remembering her past mentors prepars to
cut his right leg however stops just
before connecting and jumps back as a
thundering bat can comes through it's
shown that she wants to avenge her
Fallen comrade so bad that her sore play
is wavering and becoming unsteady trying
to compose herself she barely Dodges a
punch directed at the Joo Gabby Maru
himself realizes that he can't deflect
too many more of these strikes as his
leag is already beginning to suffer zi
tries to cut Roku R's arm but fails once
again noting how his massive size and
his fighting sty is causing his bones to
interfere with her blade Roku R his
stomach then loudly rumbles causing him
to start crying and screaming almost
deafening everyone around garu goes to
block the noise with his hands but as
soon as he does the giant takes the
opening and slams The Hollow into the
ground dting back up almost immediately
Gabby tries to withstand the unreal
level of strength and almost does but
sadly succumbs to the hurt and drops to
the ground panicking now he screams at
himself to get up as it wasn't a fatal
attack though if he doesn't move soon
he'll be annihilated by the next one
coming to his Aid Zari gets in front of
his next attack but quickly realizes
that if she doesn't move as well she'll
die telling herself to calm down
suppress her emotions and be rational as
she has chosen that way to live sari is
able to figure out that there is no
distinction between the two and
accepting both emotion and reason will
allow her to move forward unlike other
members of the yada Clan zigar hasn't
seen enough battle to make her a true
Soldier but when she's on a mission and
her goals and spirit Aline when all of
her doubts leave her blade her Sword
Play is unparalleled once the insane
belt finally comes to an end it's
showing that sigari was able to drop the
giant onto his ass she quickly darts him
behind him and attempts to deal the
finishing blow but just as quickly as
she got in behind rokua sprung back
realizing that the next attack would be
fatal seen as how normal moves weren't
working Gabby Maru comes up with their
normal plan but tells his partner that
it may be slightly extreme after
analyzing the situation Gabby Mar pulls
up his clothing over his face and bursts
into flames taking out some balls Gabby
uses NPO aesthetic Blaze mode to send
them shooting towards Roku rotor who
just knocks him away following up he
combines NPO Cipher weave and Blaze mode
to send in Flames towards the giant then
using another multitude of techniques
Gabby Maro attacks the giant of bees in
over and over but his opponent somehow
manages to repel every single attack
over with usera who decided to Gap it
earlier knowing what Gabby Maru was
actually planning tells CA that Gabby
wasn't actually targeting Roku Rota no
he was going to burn down the forest and
use the smoke to suffocate their
opponents once these smaller branches
and leaves all light up the whole area
will be covered with smoke that creates
a canopy concentrated over head bit of a
science listen here for you guys so uh
smoke is made up of carbon monoxide
carbon dioxide and particulate matter
what actually affects us is the carbon
monoxide as it binds with the
hemoglobins in our blood even more
readily than oxygen this causes the body
to instantly be deprived of ear hence
when most people in fires died to carbon
monoxide poisoning not the actual fire
itself back in the battle and due to the
effects ruota falls to his knees giving
sigiri an opportunity to finally strike
him down rokua notices her and tries to
retaliate but Gabby Maru rushes in and
holds down his hand he screams at his
teammate to hurry up as his muscles
can't hold on for much longer hearing
this and becoming tranquil yet intense
sigari becomes one with her blade and
swings The Sword Down in his final
moments rokor Roto remembers his past
wanding aimlessly searching for someone
to play with obviously from what we've
seen with rokor Rota like I'm not going
to let his action slide or anything but
it's fairly evident that the dude has
the mind of a child and never actually
grew up either way saryi apologizes to
him and lays his soul to rest telling
him that nobody resents him
anymore as the fire begins to get closer
Gabby says that it's probably best they
leave in case the fire tracks unwanted
visitors while running away Sara
remembers Genji who's actually still
wounded ring up against the tree nearby
though after realizing that she'll also
perish if she returns makes a wise
decision to leave telling herself that
she must accept both her strengths and
weaknesses which I'm like yo I think
sigari is on to something here with a
strong weak thing if you are all don't
know I'm actually on my second readr of
the story now which is why I have a
little bit more information than I
usually do say with like the jutu kaen
videos and stuff but um if you didn't
know from 2016 2018 yukii actually
worked as an assistant with tatsuki
Fujimoto on Fire Punch before beginning
this series later in 2018 so it's top to
see that greatness breeds greatness and
to be honest I don't necessarily see
similarities between their Works
obviously like they're a part of the
dark Trio but I just love knowing that
these goats had worked together in the
past and now that they're blowing up in
their own kind of way it's really really
cool as expected all of the nearby
monsters are lowered towards the Flames
which is already starting to die down
due to the thick level of mist and
humidity around the island gabimaru
suggests heading the direction that the
creatures actually came from as despite
his injuries they've really got no the
choice if they want to find leads about
the elixe of life as they start to leave
sigari asks if they should just take a
moment to recover but Gabby Mar starts
freaking out and claiming that it
doesn't matter how dangerous it is they
just need to find the electure and make
it back to his wife he asks if Ziri is
worried about all of your other comrades
but she states that everyone who took
this Mission took it knowing the insane
danger that it held having consumed for
them would only in sigar's eyes dishonor
their resolve as she has the time to
worry about them then she also has the
time to be searching for the electure as
a way to free them from the hellish
Mission hearing this Gabby notes that it
seems as if they're finally on the same
page and while running soon catches up
to Yara in centa who is stood there in
shock looking down upon something coming
up behind them both Gabby and sigari
noticed that the others had found an
abandoned Village cind comes to the
conclusion that if they're truly in
Shino The Village must be where the
Hermits live which if I haven't
mentioned the island as shinso it is the
Japanese name for the ancient Chinese
version of paradise populated by
Immortal gods and Mountain Hermits hence
how has gathered the information for
whom it's living in these so-called
Villages and like the the reason that
Center just has so much knowledge with
everything that's going on right now is
because this era of Japan or like the
the time that it's situated in with the
story is time where like art and
knowledge kind of flourish throughout
Japan more than it had done in the past
few hundred years because there was so
much fighting and stuff going on between
different parts and with the Shogun and
Emperor kind of thing going on it just
led to a lot more research and a lot
more growth uh inside of their own
culture anyway enough of me nering out
about like random history stuff back
with the uh brutal Brothers like I
absolutely love these two guys I almost
forgot that this happens here but chob
goes full beast mode and begins eating
the various Monsters of the island as a
form of fluid to stay hydrated which
kind of makes sense when you think about
it while this is going on toor explains
to him that there is a possibility
fictional beings called Hermits reside
on the island they based on the old
Chinese Mountain Hermits but as spite
their old age they're actually Immortal
beings that wield Strange Magic Shino is
really meant to be home to the these
Hermits and not monsters so Tomo
wouldn't be surprised if they ran into
them here try jokes that he'll just turn
those old fools into another meal though
as they move deeper into the foliage of
the Jungle Toma notices something or
someone nearby getting closer at Sea
that in an opening I to a fallen statue
two beautiful women are basking in the
sunlight with all four of them noticing
each other simultaneously one of the
random girls at top the statue wonders
why are humans here becoming enraged
that they thought that the soan guardian
deities were slacking off so as Center
suspected all of those creatures seem to
be some form of poorly thought out
deities created by someone either way
back in this standoff here chobby rides
himself were pointing out that the girls
are probably another form of monster one
of those apparent monsters Snidely asks
that they would like to lay with him
causing the brothers to get Hella
confused by what exactly they mean the
other one stands up and literally
changes into a male while cursing them
out over having lost his solidity he
slams his hand clothed causing the fruit
to explode and letting the brothers know
that they must die
back with Gabby Maru as they look over
the village the ninja states that it did
not matter what was living on the island
what matters is if the inhabitants are
allies or enemies directly behind the
main group a girl and a hood is seeing
watching them from behind a tree gabaro
turns and notices someone causing the
Spy to run off beabi manages to quickly
catch the spy and after removing the
hood discovers that it's just a young
girl W he wonders if it's someone who's
native to the island a branch comes
through and almost takes his head off
it's shown that a random looking tree
dude if 's favorite Bonsai man kind of
like Groot from Guardians of the Galaxy
had managed to push Gabby back thinking
that the girl might know something about
the island Gabby Maru decides to run
after her he manages to dodge another
thundering Blow from the tree before
spinning in the air and using the back
of the monster to boast himself towards
the girl since Zary is like still caught
up on the original mission's hierarchy
she quickly runs after him and leaves
the r to usera and Center usera being
the sneaky kuna Wii she is flicks off
Cent's glasses so he can't see her
abilities and decides to take on the
tree wants to with a Ninjutsu nearby
Gabby Maru manages to catch up to the
girl but as he asks to just have a chat
is shocked by her strength after she
picks him up before throwing them into a
tree saryi yells to her that they did
not intend to harm her however the girl
stops in the forest turns and throws a
punch towards her Gabby Maru blocks a
punch but as he tries to push back
notices that she is using a mysterious
power behind her attacks being pushed
back by this random power Gabby sus to
ponder what it could possibly be ever
since he came to this island there have
been so many Mysteries he thought it
would be a simple mission to just find
the elixe and return home but now he's
becoming desperate Gabby Maru then
starts to act serious and as he Dives at
her uses the vines behind him on the
tree to capture her before she even
realizes what had happened hanging there
restrained in the tree intimidated by
Gabby's now serious demeanor the girl
starts crying prompting sigiri to tell
Gabby Maru to bring her down and L her
calm down seeing her in a helpless State
Gabby Maru figures that she was just an
ordinary girl usad then arrives after
finishing her business with the tree
monster and asked how were going on
their end gabar wanted to push further
with the girl about the electure but
saryi says that it wouldn't be possible
with her crime suddenly the tree monster
started talking pleading with them to
let go of the girl and an exchange it
would tell them about the electure and
guide them to the Village speaking up
user rear believes it is a trap as up
until now the Bonsai dude hadn't said
anything after persuading her by
mentioning that there is a bath though
the group follow him to the village with
usaria overly excited about that s bath
hanging back behind them sigari asks Gab
whether they should trust him or not Le
with rarely no other options he says
it's probably best because he may know
about the Elixir but also tells her that
if the tree man is lying he will take it
down hearing the others chat behind them
the tree man promises them that it will
not trick them and Cals Center by
letting them know that the monsters and
butterflies won't even come near the
village he also reveals that those
so-called monsters are like I've said
just before called the oan Guardians of
this island according to the master tree
they provide wisdom and punish those who
turn from the teaching
he himself isn't one of them but instead
used to be human and was raised on the
island so these soan things are actually
called kamami in Japanese they are known
as tary deities of the kitchen and
household and Chinese mythology and DSM
Finly enough the most famous of all of
the soan deities was Z Jun who also went
by the Monica kitchen God in this
universe they mainly take on the role as
a fod Monster who punished people that
break the Island's rules anyway they
arrive at the Village which at this
point is really just a town and ruins
and enter the tree man's house while
Yara and sigiri take a bath which I
can't really show you guys on here let's
just uh say Yuki loves join his girls
for now outside of the bath the others
apart from Gabby cuz he thinks it's
poisoned eat some delicious looking
fruit moments later both of the girls
return and the tree man goes more in dep
explaining the ins and outs of the
island humans may call the island by
another name but to him it's known as
Kotaku a paradise for the gods there is
indeed an apparent electure of life on
the island that is found in these
ancient texts here it goes by the name
can and pretty much means the source for
everlasting life the tree man gives a
layout of the island which is broken
into three distinctive regions ISU which
is where they arrived on the island Hojo
which is where the village is located
and the elixa is located at the center
of the island called harri in our own
world this is the name for the Chinese
pingl a place said to be a mountain on a
random island in the Eastern Seas of
mythological China which was home to
eight Immortal Hermits of Dow's THS
crazily enough in a weirdly similar
parallel to this story during the the 3r
century BC a shin Dynasty sorcerer named
Shu Fu set out on a mission to find this
penly and the elixe of Life instead
though some historical text suggest that
he actually found Japan and the mountain
that would later be named Mount Fuji
continuing with h like real world
parallels both ISU and Hojo the other
areas of the island in H's Paradise are
the Japanese names for two Chinese
fantasy Islands both yinga and Fang xang
respectively I really just love how much
mythology and history is waved into the
story it's truly fantastic and just goes
to show that Yuki really has a great
understanding of his own country's past
anyways anyways continuing forwards
Gabby who still doesn't really trust
this dude asks him if he's ever seen the
elixe but Mr tree hasn't although he
knows he benefits from its effects centa
asks if he's one of these Immortals then
as he's implied that he's been around
for a thousand years sitting there the
tree man just say that they will
encounter them sooner or later and once
they do their doubts will be erased for
this man Lord tenson is Forever Young
undying Beauty incarnate the perfect
being at a similar time remember how
like the brothers bumped into a couple
gender Benders well it turns out that
they are absolutely stuffed as Lord
tenson was one or both of these beings
and took great pleasure in absolutely
obliterating the pathetic humans who
stood in its way yeah so uh so let the
Tre man was implying they are kind of
stuffed if they bump into this Immortal
being like Toma and chob were absolutely
insane especially chob the man didn't
even care what he went up against yet he
was defeated in a matter of moments back
with the main group and after hearing
about Lord tenson get marrow and usea
point their weapons towards the monster
believing that it wants them to Die the
tree man corrects them though and says
that it holds no hostility only speaking
the truth about those who step onto the
island meanwhile the mysterious being
carries Tom and chobe before throwing
them down into a pit of blooming humans
these beings are the commanders of the
ocean they pass judgment on mainly the
sinful humans who come to the island
once dropped into this pit it said
people are reborn as beautiful blossoms
freed from their sin and Earthly desires
granting them Everlasting Bliss those
who eventually become one with the
island are the source of tan for these
Immortals the trian proves that the
elixir does indeed Exist by breaking a
part of his hand off and showing gab's
crew that it can regenerate Gabby Mara
then points his sword towards the girl
wondering if she also benefits from the
electure but Ziri and Yara criticize him
for his rude Behavior scolding him for
pointing a weapon towards a child the
tree man proceeds to explain that they
can choose to believe it or not but this
is Shino a land of gods that fell down
to this poor State C ago escape from
this island is impossible and the gods
will be the ones to cast judgment on
them meanwhile tenza and naruga who have
been out searching for an ocean current
fail to find one since they need to come
up with another Escape strategy they
start to plan one when all of a sudden
they're approached by an unknown woman
after noticing that the forest is indeed
full of activity she becomes enraged by
the amount of soan corpses she discovers
on the island the woman's face begins
morphing as it then turns into a man
feeling threatened T and nuga attempt to
run but the man instantly appears he in
front of tinza and Strikes him with some
form of Sonic Boom attack as tinza
begins falling to the ground The Godly
being flashes him behind the rugy and
tries to take her out but luckily she
manages to jump back dodging the attack
tinza who's still somehow alive then
appears in front of the creature and
slashes his eyes however it's shown that
it's utterly useless as they managed to
heal the damage needing to make an
opening to escape tensa rapidly slashes
away at the man thinking that'll allow
him enough time to escape with the r guy
instantly though the bean heals and once
again appears right in front of tinza
then coming in and seemingly saving the
day the creature is caught off guard by
The Blind King rank four Yamada asimon
Shion sword throw giving his fellow
humans a moment to escape after getting
far away from the random creature Tina
introduces nugi to his Savior and a
genuine blade Master Yamada as on Shion
slapping him on the head though Shon
scolds tza for only using his speed and
his sword play against his opponent
wanting to know why he's here now tend
to ask Shon what happened with this
criminal originally Shon was in charge
of aagu but after she tried to seduce
him she paid with her life which which
is absolutely crazy she just wanted a
friend dude either way after leaving her
he managed to find a current that could
lead them away from the island however
he pointed out that he sens an
unfamiliar presence and heard weird
noises tenza says that the three of them
should go to the spot where he found the
current but Shion raises his sword and
asked why he was helping his criminal
Tina explains that she was innocent
however Shon literally isn't having it
before arriving on the island he
memorized every criminal with them and
knows what they've done even though
she's not a criminal in both of their
eyes it isn't up to them to decide what
is wrong and what is right it is the era
that they live in which decides the
crimes people commit ttin rebuttal him
though and brings up how he himself used
to be just a Wanderer without any
purpose in life there was no reason for
Shon to save him back then yet he still
decided to take him off the street now
in a similar situation of his own t
wanted to do the same for her as he sees
potential for her to live a real life in
the world remembering the past and
realizing just how far T had Truly Come
From The Day He metet him Shion is
convinced and allows his student to do
as he pleases nuga greets her future
husband's Master by calling him Sensei
to what Shon like the goatey is says
that she needn't call him that since he
hadn't taught her anything wanting to
quickly head back to the beach Shon
tells tza to chill out as they need to
be cautious of the mysterious being that
they just faced before it's best that
instead of making themselves a Target
they need to take their time and come up
with a strategy however as tza begins to
ponder on what they should do The Godly
thing drops down into the middle of the
forest now appearing as a female and
saying that they've underestimated it D
Shion quickly moves the two out of the
way but as his throat cut in the process
tensa fights back yet is unable to hit
the creature at all as it Dives in and
out of all of his swings needing to make
a stand tza uses his ultimate technique
Ito Ryu pounding torrent swinging his
sword over and over and over again
creating an unescapable wave of slashes
the female though is on a different
level of skill and easily manages to
weave through all of his strikes before
confronting him directly and saying that
she's accustomed to his speed speed
tapping him in three different places on
the chest tinsa is sadly downed by
another use of that mysterious technique
leaving the others screaming out for
their falling Ally falling into a memory
from his past tend recalls the time he
asked Shion why he even picked him up
off the street Shion says that Jud to
how his proficient as the end lives he
likes to help out others and saw
potential in him back in the present
tinzo drops to his knees and while
looking at his palms realizes that he's
currently dying from the previous
attacks as the god stands over him it's
obvious that if he doesn't do something
everyone else is going to end up just
like him screaming he rises to his feet
and attempts to fight back throwing a
fat right hook into the face of the
immortal creature he knows that this is
probably it for him but he'll do
whatever he can to make enough time for
the others to escape however tinzo
receives another fatal blow to his
stomach catching him completely by
surprise with nothing left to do better
than bruise tzer tries telling nuga to
run but he can't probably must the
strength to even say a word luckily Shon
was able to reach out and stop nug guy
from trying to help not wanting to leave
his former student alone himself though
and unable to understand what tza is
trying to say Shon takes a stand ready
to save his wounded friend knowing that
his Sensei won't stand a chance though
tenza tries to must just one word to
tell him to leave or run away but just
like with nugi he's unable to must
anything but a shot gurgle sensing
something shaon jumps back and stops his
assault before running away with theug
GUI back behind them the legend himself
tinza takes his final stand and hinders
The Immortal foes attemps to chase the
others now deeper into the forest his
sense screams in pain while fleeing with
T's chosen disciple and his final
moments ttin imagines what life could
have been like in the future possibly
teaching a bunch of younger students or
drinking with all of his buddies on a
beautiful day over with the others as
they flee Nuka screams and hits Shon
wanting to know why why is he leaving
tensa behind with his throat starting to
recover he explains that he was honoring
tena's Last Wishes tenza knew that they
wouldn't be able to defeat these
creatures the way that they are now and
if they stayed they would all have
shared the same fate retreat was the
only way however he states that this
debt will be paid before they flee the
island they will destroy that creature
meanwhile over in a much more chill
atmosphere as Gabby Maru prepares to
take a bath him and sigari think back on
the moments earlier they know that both
may and the tree who goes by hoko were
born and raised on the island they've
lived here for centuries and only wish
to live in peace CA the big Brae also
knows that in China sine beliefs tenson
refers to an elite type of mystical
hermit these soan and haray are also
words originating for the D so it's only
feir to say that they're probably
telling them the truth about the island
in Mainland China's actual history like
in our own world tenson was a turn made
up by the Jin Dynasty scholar G Hong
it's simply a classification for the
highest class of immortal hermit there
are two other classifications as well
which we'll get into later into the
video now in the bath house sigari takes
note of just how many wounds Gabby Maru
has sustained since getting on the
island looking at may she also sees this
massive SCAR or some kind of strange
marking that travels up the majority of
her back while washing himself Gabby Mar
remembers a time his wife washed his
back and gave him advice about how to
properly relax his body she reminded him
on how if he didn't take the opportunity
to relax then he's bound to collapse in
the real battle that they call life in
Times of Peace stick to your convictions
wear them proudly at times or conceal
them at others but never let go of what
truly makes you you for life is far far
longer than even the Battle of Kanan
Kima damn I love how poetic Yuki is with
this story and it makes me want to learn
just Japanese in general as I know for a
fact that the story would be so much
more in depth in a language that is
artistically based for example this
battle that Gabby's wife referred to was
actually the site of five or possibly
six different battles that happened in
the Waring States period between 1553
and 1564 if you want to check out like
the actual location it's situated near
the present day in Nano the battles
between commanders teada shinen and us
zi kinhin have become some of the most
romanticized pieces of Japanese history
giving rise to retellings reimaginings
Artistic representations and even movies
anyway after remembering how we told her
that she shouldn't cover her scar with
her hair he gives the same advice to May
about the marking on her back saying he
knows this lady with a big old scar
across her face and she's the prettiest
girl around as both girls taking this
new side of Gabby a causes May to become
star struck wanting to stay by his side
instead of scared of him like she was
before leaving the bath house now and as
the three walk back to hoko's Residence
Zari notices that Gabby Maru is truly
starting to change at the same time
Gabby Maru reminds himself why he's
exactly here he managed to get a
breather in and finally remembered those
feelings of his but his priority isn't
to bathe around no it's to make it home
and save his wife from her tyrannical
father inside of hoko's house ca who's
literally fried his brain after
Gathering so much information which is
just like me on this video right here
insists that they should spend the night
as there's still so much to unravel zi
tells him that he should rest for now
then but CA who's overheating insisted
that he'd be able to keep watch after he
takes a bath however once outside and on
guard Duty he falls asleep with Gabby
Maru who's just chilling right next to
him sitting there overthinking
everything that's happened so far Gabby
Maru decided that it would be better to
head out alone to harai before the enemy
makes their move against them as Gabby
Maru rushes for harai he says a number
of immobile tree creatures try to
strange sutras amongst the fog that was
a tongue twister and a half for some
reason while walking along he wonders if
they're praying and thinks back on how
Santa said it's probably dangerous to
act before they know what's really going
on even though Gabby knows that this
could be the most dangerous place in the
world if he doesn't press on there is
absolutely no chance he'll ever see his
wife again stopping for the moment
though he wonders how in the world he's
even going to know when he arrives at
Rai it's not like he Homeland with
roadsides at the same time an unknown
person is seen following him pressing
forward gabri Maru eventually comes to
find a massive gate remembering what
hoko said said about har being a place
of Splendor he believes that this is
where the hermit and the electure must
reside just as he goes to enter the area
though he stops noticing something
behind him coming face to face both
Gabby Maru and the same mysterious being
who just took out tins a steer into each
other's eyes randomly it becomes sadden
by his presence and drops to its knees
just asking him to leave explaining that
she had already dealt with capturing
another group of humans today hearing
this flicks a switch on our boy's head
and he immediately realizes just from
her statement alone that she turns
people into the elixir of life after
seeing each other as a threat the two
engage in battle jumping straight at
each other Gabby Maru lands two
successive blows on the woman and comes
to the conclusion that she wasn't Human
After regenerating her wounds turning
things up a notch he flips back into a
handstand spinning flame kick that lands
directly onto the face of the immortal
being he then activates the ability NPO
fir monk to completely incinerate The
Immortal with the creature smoldering
blow him Gabby Maru noted that it was
far too strong to even consider a
questioning when all of a sudden The
Godly being d straight back out with its
Char body and lands a direct head on
Gabby Maru sending him shooting into the
sky phasing into the sky in an instant
as well and then lands another massive
kick to the gout of the Ninja thinking
that it's destroyed the human it reforms
to its normal male shell but is
perplexed when he sees Gabby Maru
standing there asking if he was indeed
Lord tenson in a display of skill yet
unseen in the series both Gabby Maru and
the being known as Lord tenson continue
fighting in arai coming to a standstill
for a moment Gabby asks where the
electure is before diving straight back
in and throwing another series of kicks
and punches he notes that all of the
damage he's inflicting is pretty much
useless as it's regenerated by its
ability just too fast trading blows with
this thing is just like Roka wrote it as
well it's only going to result in
certain death what he needs is a
strategy that's actually going to hurt
it a cdic blaze didn't work so he opts
for a technique that he hasn't tried so
far he throws a small swift kick to the
gut or Tandon of the monster and notices
that the impact felt slightly different
from before somehow it actually did some
form of damage causing low tensin to
cough up blood and transform into a
Woman by the way whenever they change
into a woman I have to do so much
blurring or body modification so like I
apologize for that Yuki himself just
goes to ham with his art style and it's
amazing I just I just wish they wore
like tops sometimes for something anyway
continuing tinson tells gab that he's
probably not even aware of what he just
did and changes into another fighting
form that we haven't seen so far
becoming enraged it tells him to die
before sending what seems to be an
invisible Sonic energy waves that deal
an insane amount of damage not
understanding what in the world just
happened Gabby becomes over elmed as
Lord tenson sends out a barrage of
attacks that leave our boy with
physically no way to block unable to
counter Gabby Maru just throws away any
idea of trying to defend and grits his
teeth before charging out the immortal
creature he gets within thron hand's
range and begins doing his thing man
knows that if he survive he gets to go
home end of story that's it that's
what's going to happen even with parts
of him missing he will make it home he
speeds his attacks up through pure grit
and somehow manages to gain the upper
hand before basting the false god down
onto the ground defeating it after being
defeated gabar tells it to talk as he
just wants to find damn Elixir however
Lord tenson smiles and as its body
begins to bloom flowers it states that
they would be furious with it again in
that moment tenson loses its natural
shape and morphs into a massive monster
made up of those previously blooming
flowers after the Lord tenson
transformation gabri Maru calms himself
and tries to think of a strategy however
the transformed Immortal unleashes
uncontrollable bolt of lightning that
Blitz the entire area and badly wound
gas
throwing a massive Boulder aside Gabby
doesn't hesitate and darts back in
trying to land some form of hat on the
monster but it's utterly useless as he's
blasted back once more L at a heap of
rubble he tries to activate an aesthetic
Blaze yet it's once again useless as his
body freezes up on him making him
realize that he's already reached his
limit and has no stamina left at all
being unable to move the monster
overwhelms Gabby causing them to wonder
if this is real or if it been one long
nightmare waking up randomly in his
house his wife lets him know that he'd
been tossing and turning possibly having
some kind of bad dream breaking down
Gabby tells her that he had had the
worst nightmare he's ever had as time
passes we see Gabby chilling out on his
Veranda while his wife brings him some
dream watering tea looking at her he
says that even if this is a dream it's
wonderful that he was able to talk to
her again withough slowly becoming
confused with all he's saying Gabby
apologizes as he knows that there is no
chance he's ever going to see her again
sadly back in the present Gabby
reawakens in the grasp of the monster
moments before it seemingly crushes him
no no no no no no no Gabby ain't done
though instead what we thought was our
boy dying was in effect him starting his
last Stitch effort while remembering a
specific ninja principle Ironclad ninja
law rule 20 should death be upon you in
the moments before your doom inflict
Grievous damage upon the foe that would
ring the life from you bursting into
flames once more Gabby knows that when
facing death he has to surrender
everything even his subconscious having
activated nimpo fire monk giby
eventually bursts through the monsters
grip causing him to fall to the ground
below not having the strength to even
get back up Gabby Maru just thinks of
his wife and apologizes for not being
able to make it home randomly though May
then appears besides gabar and helps him
Escape by creating a crater using a
mysterious ability allowing them to
safely slide off the cliff enraged the
monster attempts to attack the two with
its lightning but fails to hit them
before they flee reverting back to
normal now tenson just wonders what in
the world was the reason for Ma's
actions inside of her ey all of these
mysterious ious rulers that each in
their own can also be called Lord tenson
are gathered for a meeting about the
humans that landed on the island chuar
which is one of the names for these
creatures becomes angu as sujan for
failing his guard duties and being
reduced to a kakai state he violently
attacks him but is quickly scolded by
the leader for causing harm to a fellow
family member he brings up that they can
only punish those which they serve and
because of that he may only harm zuo Jin
putting the failure that is zoen asde he
asks du far for any information on the
humans they've encountered so far ju
relay on how he dropped both toe and TOA
into one of the pets which in their eyes
is far too deep for any human to climb
out of massive foreshadowing I think so
anyway Mudan who's trying to take the
role of kind of like a boss here I I I
guess advises them to not underestimate
the humans if it had being just a soan
that was taken out it wouldn't have been
no big deal but since they managed to
slay a Mion things seem different about
these humans he brings up a terrifying
possibility that say they were able to
escape the pit Jew threw them into then
there would be nothing more fearsome
than a wounded Beast plus if every other
human on the island wielded the same
kind of strength then they might truly
face a terrible Beast unbeknown to these
goons that's exactly what's going on
here the leader then ask Zen if they
successfully won the battle they had
last night what he was certain they Sly
make a toast to longevity and zuin is
fully restored to his normal form so
what they mean by Kikai like I didn't
mention this earlier thought I was going
to but I didn't as the Monstrous plant
form that they evolve into under great
stress which is you know like the one
that we just saw saw before which is
also another representation of Yen and
yang if you look at it more like uh Rich
respectively the colors and all kakai
literally means demon corpse undo which
has some kind of aspect in the story
later on which we bring up as well and
it is a concept inspired by J Hong's
weakest Immortal hermit form the shii
Shian from what I've seen and like we
can obviously get so far the story dives
into the more Chinese mythological side
of things and especially the stuff from
this like jiong fellow anyways anyways
meanwhile and back with the main group
CRA apologizes this for accidentally
letting Gabby Maru leave his sight the
previous night hoko brings up that it's
almost impossible for any ordinary human
to travel through the Mist but sigiri
believes that if he did indeed sit out
he may have actually found a way to
navigate the area and if that's the case
they need to find him at once usera
though disagrees is it's not like
they've got any time to spare themselves
and wonder why sigari was even concerned
about Gabby Maru hoko interrupts and
offers to guide them through the Mist
seeing as how may left he has to go find
her anyway hearing this usera switches
up and is persuaded into finding Gab
once again cuz of hoker you know you got
to love the treated once they leave
sigiri notices that with Gabby having
run off it's now beyond the scope of her
duties still she can't help but hope
he's okay elsewhere Gabby Maro awakens
with May beside him and immediately
comes to the conclusion that the thing
he just fought was no God just a living
breathing monster pleased with the
realization he stands ready to figure
out a way to defeat the beast from the
battle so far it's obvious to him that
he can't do it alone but with two three
four or even more comrades it might be
possible in that moment he notices
another two newcomers appear directly
behind him the G's after encountering
Tamaya gusai and Yamada asimon fui gabim
Maru and gen tisai go back and forth
predicting each other's actions in their
heads before they make a move in the
actual battle stepping in between the
two though fui ceases their pointless
imaginary battle and instead plans to
extract information from Gabby Maru
having HED a special ability since he
was a young fellow that allows him to
recognize someone's strength at a glance
gabimaru decides to sit down and and
request an alliance with the two GSU
side draws a sword and swings at at
Gabby to see if he was trying to trick
them but after the previously Hollow Man
didn't Flinch at all figured he was
telling the truth still he felt
disappointed with him for Gabby showed
him just how truly weak he was and he
tells him that he wasn't looking for
cowards who bow to an enemy either way
fui asks to hear him out wanting to know
why the infamous Gabby Maru would go
this far with some randoms going over
everything that has like happened up
until this point both fui and gusai are
especially intrigued to hear more about
this random Lord tenson fellow fuchi
who's just blown away with gab's
explanation asks how it was able to
regenerate and was there any signs that
it had internal organs not knowing every
detail Gabby says that honestly he's not
even sure what happened he just needs to
earn that pardon and get back to a suing
someone just as intrigued himself gusa
agrees the teaming up and tells him that
he had no interest in the pardon but
rather to become a legendary figure that
will live forever confused because that
obviously means the dude still wants the
electure can
reiterates that literal immortality
would get boring fast what he wants is
to be able to perform fats that shake
the Earth then that way the name tamay
gai will live on for eternity he's a you
know he's a a true historian a true
warrior you know like that's history for
you the only way you get to really live
on is people write about you and talk
about you in the history box anyway
screaming to the sky he tells the gods
themselves to believe it one day they'll
paint pictures and write tales about his
strength fuchi who thinks his criminal
has absolutely lost his mind also agrees
after learning that an undy organism
actually exists having come to their
agreement fuchi asks Gabby to spill the
beans on what he knows agreeing he goes
to th off with May and explain her yet
as soon as he looks at her he's shocked
to see that she's growing a few years in
age fui who obviously you know hasn't
met Gabby Maru so far or may asked why
Gabby Maru was shocked to which he
explained that may has aged for some
reason then after hearing her speak for
the first time Gabby Mar quickly rushed
in and grabbed her asking if she was the
same as tenson and for more more
information on the electure noticing how
forward he was being Gabby stepped back
and thanked her for everything so far
but also questioned as to why she
couldn't speak up until now at the same
time usara curiously asked hoko what in
the world Lord tenson was finally it
explained to was absolutely confused
readers that Lord tenson is in fact
seven different Immortal beings
according to Legend it's possible that
it used to be one Immortal being but
obviously hoko is unsure as so much has
changed throughout the historical text
what's known though is that as the
Supreme Shandi samantabhadra Heavenly D
ashko enthroned juun amav vadra seus
dashn Ratner rant Wan Yun Tatar decorus
gong gong mansuri and defi djun kundi
obviously apologies for all of my
terrible translations or pronunciations
on those perks to any of my Indian
fellows that can actually uh speak the
language obviously you guys are insane I
don't know how you do it anyway
apparently the great Herman over a
thousand years ago reached in lien
achieved deification and thus split
themselves Sevenfold The Immortal beings
appearance and voice are shared between
them but they all vary in personality
and the role they take like C mentioned
in the island arc on how it was a poor
mixup of religions and cultures these
names are exactly the same they combin
titles from Chinese cultures and
mythology mixed in with unrelated bodess
deities and their Concepts funnily
enough and the Japanese version of like
the story itself they use the Japanese
pronunciations whereas in my video you
know we like big brain it by my
pronunciation and in the English
translation it uses the accepted
spellings from each specific religion
anyway continuing the tree man also
reveals that everyone of the island was
once human with abnormally long
lifespans in comparison to the average
man yet even still with their long
lifespans their prosperity ended after a
th000 years and eventually everyone hit
ocation once someone does begin turning
they only have a limited amount of time
before their mind goes blank and they
travel to harai to sit in these zazen
pose and chance strange sutras hearing
this information C objects to hoko's
previous statement on the island Benin
Zeno and believes that it's more likely
based around a man-made religion words
like harai ISU and zazen and even Lord
tenson titles all relate to existing
different religion spheres consider the
physical remains scattered all over the
island all of them reflect very real
human religions due to all of this he
can accept that this island is cut from
The Real World is some sort of spiritual
realm isolated for over a thousand years
he tells youa to remember and how he was
originally arrested for trying to
overthrow the shogunate by founding a
new religion altogether just like his
weird religion the one they've
discovered here is also made up from a
distortion of different faiths in his
mind hoko's stories have only supported
his theory that this island and
everything inside of it including them
being lowered to the island are all
works of a mysterious creator with his
explanation in mind user rehab believes
that it's pretty much impossible to stop
someone who's been planning everything
behind the scenes for over a thousand
years and assumes scabby Maru and may
are already dead from even been trying
to approach it however sigari believes
that Gabby Maru is very much alive and
is already formulating a plan of action
as no matter what he will see his wife
once more she you know even even saryi
on that Gabby wife hype train now back
with Gabby he inquires as to how in the
world may saved him back there may who
can't speak properly tries to tell him
that it was Dow weak strong Spirit
virtue brings up that the tandem which
was one of the words she said could be
related to the flow of chi or Shakra but
he obviously can't say for sure on the
other hand Hoku explain to the girls
that da is the energy that flows through
everything everything that exists comes
from the never ending flow of Da and if
someone is able to tap into that flow
then it could allow them to Middle with
creation itself elsewhere Shion and nuga
go through some like training exercises
after getting absolutely blissed by The
Blind King nugo pleads with him to
explain his swordsmanship but he refuses
her as he just couldn't bear to watch
another student fall before his eyes not
pleased nuga tells him that she can
sense he isn't any ordinary guy there
was someone in their Clan who could see
with sound but the level Shon is on is
almost otherworldly in comparison so the
reason big Shon is able to MK people
world blind is because just like taste
or smell all things in this world
possess unique waves and that's exactly
what he's able to perceive the technique
is so refined that he's even able to
tell exactly what the ruga hairstyle
looks like yet there isn't any said name
for this ability so he just calls them
waves so Mastery over da allows the user
to not only sense things but it boosts
their physical abilities to the same
level as a God tapping into that power
requires an extremely balanced spirit so
remember the stuff May was trying to say
well the strong weak more or less meant
balanced Spirit once someone achieves
Mastery over the ever-flowing Cycles
between rage and serenity like we saw
with saryi against rokur Roa then they
will begin to sense the waves according
to bodh text it's called the middle wave
the state of being able to draw out a
power that exceeds your natural
potential asking what the right wav is
then Shon gives her an example of how he
activates the technique he explains
everything from his stance to how he
holds the blade and even the feeling
that he gets while wielding the blade
with a bunch of Shan perfectly rolling
up behind Shion he displays just exactly
what he sees tapping into all of the
specific waves it reveals a dark world
made up of white waves weaving in and
out of the darkness creating the
creatures and Landscape around him
lashing out Shion easily takes down
every single Monster all while
explaining to naruga what goes into to
the use of his technique they both begin
taking on the remaining creatures
together he tells naruga that he still
refuses to become a teacher but she is
to learn as much as she wants from him
elsewhere Gabby Maru is also ambushed by
a large amount of soan stepping forth in
one of those freaking massive swings
geni takes out the first wave of
creatures with ease he knows that he
wants to learn this Dow thing but
sitting around and listens is so damn
boring for the Beast he teases Gabby for
how beat up he's gotten since making
landfall and tells him that they need to
learn In the Heat of battle with all of
these so-called training dubies in front
of them he asks May to jump down and
give them a few examples of Dow though
as he does so gab Maru notices an
unfamiliar presence among the soan so
remember that pit chob Anda were thrown
into you know a little while back so
that there was created by Lord tensen in
order to assimilate any humans dropped
inside making them one with the flowers
from that they are able to extract
something called tan or more
specifically the electure of life if
anyone tries to escape those pits of
theirs which is almost impossible due to
how just deep it is then the walls
themselves will hinder them still it's
Shan that their pits weren't deep enough
for the demon Brothers who somehow
managed to climb their way out after
escaping toas suggests leaving the
island but choba angrily declares that
he will take revenge on the two that put
them there man doesn't even need a
strategy as from the first battle he
figured out their weakness was the lower
halves of their bodies after offering
TOA a piece of fles to eat from the P
the two brothers are randomly taken off
guard when a monster rolls up and starts
chatting as if it dep part of the
conversation not meaning to frighten
them the random looking thing dressed in
a Chinese outfit tells them to not lash
out as it possesses some form of
intelligence and instead of fighting
they should just talk so this thing here
is actually used for scouting purposes
and a bunch of them have been sent out
to all of the still alive humans on the
island unlike the soan which are
incomplete beings that lack any thought
or emotion and aren't even allowed
inside of her eye or the monin who act
as guards for the area they are the
Doshi direct Disciples of Lord tenson
who possess intelligence and are taught
directly by one of the seven the DOI
explains that he was ordered to assure
that they were still on the pet becoming
tan while his other comrades were out
locating the other humans on the island
he then just casually asks for the two
to return to the pit however chob
responds by driving forth and attacking
the creature easily dodging a slow Blow
by the Doshi Choo lashes out disarming
the monster and causing it to jump
backwards knowing that this thing is in
touch with tenson Troy demands that it
tell him everything about those freaks
but the DOI refuses calling him a
foolish idiots bringing in some backup
it commands the soan to take out the
humans so he can return them to the P
not bothered by the freaking soan though
chobe orders TOA to fight off the soan
while he handles the Doshi himself as
the two continue to scuffle it's
revealed that Cho's attacks are causing
almost no harm to the Doshi because he
doesn't wield down this leaves a perfect
opening for the Doshi to fatally wound
chobe striking him in the face causing
him to fall face first onto the ground
below Cena bro fall down to becomes
horrified screaming at his name getting
up he runs at the Doshi who's taunting
him when all of a sudden chbe reopens
his eyes the DOI leans down to drag him
back to the pit when simultaneously
troby awakens and Spins on the floor
facing his opponent before striking a
blow directly to his face looking at his
brother try tells TOA to return to
fighting the F losers while he deals
with his F the DOI notices that ch's
throat has regenerated from the previous
damage and well baffled deduces that
during his time in the P he must have
been affected by the vines that Infuse
some kind of tan into him looking at him
some more the DOI takes note that it's
probably the case since his Dow has
changed shape in such a short period of
time realizing how dangerous he could be
if chob isn't dealt with now he
reignites the battle against the newly
evolved human instantly he breaks his
arms by manipulating the Dow around his
body but just as quickly choby manages
to regenerate them and Strike Back the
DOI questions whether choby feared
losing his Humanity after his
transformation but the demon brother
states that he couldn't care as nothing
in this world was set in stone fixing
his statement he says no there is one
thing that never changes that's always
current but pointed out that someone
like him wouldn't understand where he
was coming from he charges forward
asking to see more of this new power yet
this time he's actually able to
visualize what the doshi's invisible
attacks look like he then strikes the
monster's Naval causing damage and
showing proof to him that weakness does
indeed lie within the stomach so these
DOI fellow are kind of like The
Messengers and personal assistance to
these tens and fellows the word that
they originate from Doshi or Dai in
Chinese is a blanket term that refers to
DST priests monks and Masters back in
the battle and as ch's da begins to grow
larger and larger the DOI becomes
frightened trying to call forth the soan
to save him but sadly for a little Doshi
it's shown that the other bro had
managed to dispose of all of them
Welling fourth little dowy has left the
DOI creates some kind of energy orb but
is unable to use it as his hand is
crushed by chob B staring into the
terrified soul of the pathetic creature
chbe states that he now knows how to
manipulate his da it's simple he brings
it in from the environment around him
with nothing left to do chob activates
the exact same ability the do she just
used perplexing the creature who thought
it was utterly impossible now seeing the
waves of Dow and a similar way to that
of Shion chobe Smiles knowing just how
weak his enemy is before finally dealing
the finishing blow while CH begins
interrogating what's left of this doshy
creature Tomy looks closely at the
markings on his brother's neck and
notices that they are beginning to
spread snapping his head towards his
brother Toma gets frightened by chob but
soon comes out of the days he found
himself in walking in to help tie up the
dohi Toma takes and even closer look at
ch's neck and notices that his scars
look plant likee meanwhile while
fighting off the Shan gen kitui asks May
if he was starting to understand D but
may shakes her head in disagreement
stating that he was focusing too much on
strength looking at over at his Fierce
rival who's absolutely destroying the
other soan he asks if he was starting to
understand da just like himself though
may also states that he was also
focusing too much on strength fui who's
like off to the side examining the
remains of the creatures becomes
delighted with his inspection of the
soci anatomy and relays the information
to Gabby Maru he finds it odd that even
creatures who share the same outward
appearance have completely different
anatomical structures from there alone
he's able to deduce that each opponent
they go up against has its own weak
point however that doesn't exactly
explain what is as well in their eyes
after remembering how she helped him
Escape Gabby Maru comes to the
realization that no ordinary human would
have been able to pull off the feet that
she did when they escaped finally he
intently looks towards her wondering
what she is but as ma sees him it causes
her to break down and begin crying for a
fourth time this always gets me but as
gabian Gant continue taking out F soan
he asks Taya if he was married as well
and the big man lets him know that he
has wives all over the continent
absolute freaking King but anyway anyway
taken by surprise gy side then blocks A
Sneak Attack by Doshi trying to strike
back he swings his hook arm towards the
creature but he was sadly unable to stop
it from weaving between his attacks and
taking May off his shoulder now back a
feir distance from the main group The
DOI greets May in a polite manner
stating that it had been searching for
her in secret for centuries after she
vanished from herai it caused the dohi
to fall into dispair as they were unable
to search for her publicly due to Lord
rayan's orders now that theyve finally
reunited he begs her to return to harai
as they are in great need of her Aid hm
so I what in the world may could
possibly be or the relation that she has
to the Immortals in herai what do the
doshy knew do for so desperately and who
in the world is this Lord rean fellow
still so many questions of course like
with us being almost a third through
this story here I'd love to know your
thoughts on it all down below I find
some of the things get repeated quite a
lot but that's always going to happen
when you've got like three or four
different groups all needed to learn the
exact same information so hopefully I
was able to slim down the repeat info
here and there and make it more concise
though the way Yuki does it where it
swaps around between characters as he's
explaining parts of the world is really
damn good and I can't wait to see what
the anime does with it cuz I think it'll
be quite exciting on how they like skip
around between characters as they're
learning what it actually is it was just
hard for me to portray here but either
way continuing forward wanting to know
what in the world is going on Gabby Maro
insists that the DOI tell them what may
is firstly it tells them that it is none
of their concern as May is not supposed
to be near humans yet since they helped
with her return it says that she is
similar to Lord tenson unnourished by
the lives of humans finding out that she
isn't human pushes Gabby to the edge
because he knows that getting caught up
in something he doesn't understand will
only result in death he needs to
remember why he took this Mission but
after seeing the tears beginning to fall
from May's face he rushes to her side
and puts himself between her and the
Doshi creature he knows that acting on
impulse is usually the last thing he
would do yet despite not having any
association with her he can't bear to
make her cry again furious with this
interference the DOI Partners himself
with another similar looking goon and
declares they will turn them into tan
and retrieve May if that's truly the
case after noticing the second does of
appearance and how it manipulates the
bugs around them gusai realizes that
he's the mofo that made him lose his
hand he's the butterfly boss watching
the two DOI summon a swarm of their
respective insects Gabby quickly comes
to the conclusion that they're able to
manipulate the insects around them
before he could strategize any further
gusai steps in and cuts down the
butterflies and states that he seeks
revenge on the butterfly Doshi for
causing him to lose his left hand he
lunges in for another attack angered by
the fact that he had to refine his sword
style but is hit by an invisible attack
by the CER Doshi that grazes the side of
his face initiating a closeand battle
the two DOI charge forth pushing our
boys back into a defensive fight bugs
weave in and out of the battlefield in
combination with the DOI blocking their
vision and causing them to accidentally
end up hitting each other with the boys
beckering between each other now the
second DOI watches they D controlling
the centipedes asks to as why they
wanted to protect May despite not having
any connections with her Gabby Maru
knows that if it was The Oldham he would
have just left her as soon as possible
but now he wonders as to why he's begun
changing ever since he landed on the
island excepting this as they knew him
he replies to the creature that he was
just repaying a de he then flipped the
conversation back on the dohi curious as
to why he was so fixated on a girl that
doesn't want to even leave with him the
inosi explains that his kind trained
themselves in the way of Da just like
the Lord tenson does for them may is a
key component to their training and the
ways of Dow there are five acidic
methods to training one's body and DOW
which makes me wonder if gab's acidic
form is also one of these five methods
or something but Doan koku shu
and shuen are the first four and you can
train them all by yourself however the
most important of them all is hot steamy
botchy Jutsu which as you can probably
pick up on Demands a partner of opposite
gender this is due to how I brought up
earlier in the video for the cycle of
Yin and Yang to complete a demand's
intimate Congress what's actually really
cool is that these five meditation
methods come from real life Chinese
history through both DST and G Jong
practices all things inside of this
world possess Chi either of Yen or Yang
affinity even those that do not live the
higher levels of a specific Affinity
will result in an even greater level of
D when someone performs botu Jutsu Doan
or Doan I don't know how to say it
properly someone tell me down in the
comment section below I'm probably
completely wrong ta soku and similar
things will prepare someone's mind and
body but the method to join both is
through botu Jutsu those who are able to
hone their Dow through this method
unlock the ability to reshape the fabric
of reality Lord tenson has apparently
achieved this level of power and is now
an ascended being and which the entire
and yang cycle flows unbroken thus it
has been this way for the past 1,000
years as Lord tenson manifests the
ultimate Dow the reason that they need
May is because the DOI are made up of
Yang energy and in order for them to
complete their training they require
May's assistance since she possesses Yin
Energy may in their eyes is a failure as
one of the tenson as instead of
possessing both yin and yang May was
only able to produce Yen aligned Chi
therefore Lord ran banished her from the
palace and offered her two different
options
either she could pass away or obviously
like she chose reforge herself from the
start as their training partner which is
utterly disgusting when you think about
it I'm purposefully like not going into
depth on certain aspects of things or
showing half the panels here otherwise
this video will be taken down and I want
it to stay up obviously and I want it to
be like fit for younger audiences so
that they can understand the story in a
uh in a in a friendlier way not in a
such a dramatic way that Yuki puts it in
sometimes so you know if you guys want
to get it in in Yuki's way obviously go
out there and read the uh the actual
manga but obviously like I'm dming down
things here because like the reality of
the situation is just sad I can fully
understand why may wanted to break down
after being threatened with going back
that's all I'm going to actually say on
that and in that there hearing all of
this though both Gabby Maru and gusai
like myself become disgusted with this
information Ang good toor tells him that
he'll take on the centipede creep but
looking at his boy he's blowing away to
see just how enraged he also is stepping
in and asking if she's marked he tells
them to stop their rude explanation of
May and treat her like a proper normal
person not an object not bothered with
the threats of a human though the DOI
transforms into its shikai form and
declares that they will take them out on
this spot gusai then makes the first
attack jumping up and swinging at the
butterfly Doshi who retaliates by
sending a swarm after him he notices
that they're easier to attack when
bunched up but gets caught off guard by
the powder coming off the butterflies
slowly becoming dizzy he asks for Gibby
maru's assistance but gets told to deal
with it by himself as he's just as busy
with fighting the the Doshi shooting out
an attack itself the DOI uses a similar
blast to Lord tenson to push gab Maru
back yelling to his teammate G lets him
know that the butterflies are dangerous
hearing him Gabby Maru uses nimpo paru
bridge to expel a torrent of fire that
seemingly Burns all of the butterflies
and soaks the DOI in a cloak of flames
looking at his enemy Gabby realizes that
he won't stand a chance unless he finds
a way to sense Dow you know so uh
remember fui who's just been chilling
here this whole time with May in the
middle of this well after interpreting
her words from ear earlier fi yells out
to Gabby Maru that he's focusing too
much on strength to perceive Dow your
heart must accept both strength and
weakness and unless he accepts his
weaknesses he won't learn it may also
helped fuchi sense his own doubt by
touching his hand and giving a
demonstration on how she uses it Gabby
Maru tries doing the same with her but
once she activates her da he can only
slightly feel something however that's
it he can't see it yet after hearing ma
state in her own weird way that weakness
gives birth to strength Gab Mar is
reminded of sigar's words and how his
love for his wife that he thought was a
weakness is actually a strength finally
understanding what the strong weak is
that may keeps going on about Gabby Maru
watches as some form of glowing energy
appears around his hand stepping forth
towards the heat of battle the
previously hollow man tells fuchi that
he thinks he gets the G of it now
watching him walk ahead of him May
notices just how large Gabby maru's Dow
truly is having felt the sensation
before Gabby Maru is able to see the
invisible attacks from the Doshi and
Dodges them with ease blowing away with
just how quickly he caught on Gant
states that it's probably due to the
specific training he went through as a
member of the UR apparently the people
there even have other worldly moves and
inhuman forms that they can take on at a
moment's notice it's likely that it's
not exactly D but possible the
techniques are based on similar
principles however May shakes her head
in disagreement as he continues to fight
the centipede Doshi Gabby Maro begins to
understand how D works and begins
perceiving everything around him not
just the strong AA but also the weak and
dying ones he also manages to understand
why he perceives sigari as such a
terrifying Force even with all of her
doubt she still pushes forth making her
a stronger person with the cped DOI
throwing a fat right hook towards Gabby
Maru our boy just puts his hand out and
simply blocks the strike being able to
distinguish every insect apart that
makes up the monster's form he then
reverses the polarity of the monster's
Dow exploding the arm of its shikai form
now with the upper hand Gibby darts up
and screams that the pathetic Doshi no
longer stands a chance spinning a m here
giby lands a fat Kick that pushes the
creature completely out of its shik form
feeling gassed up now Gibby tells the
CIP dohi that he's finally ready to
throw some hands with him Master laying
there on the ground now after being
defeated the Doan pears Gabby maru's
abilities to that of Lord tenson blowing
away with just how accurate he was with
his strikes annoyed Gabby Maru demands
that the DOI tell him who he was working
with and where he can find this Lord
tenson seeing no other option the DOI
explains that itself along with two
other Doshi were ordered by Lord tensen
to observe the human that arrived on the
island they were to discover how this
new group differed to those that had
made land for in the past mainly though
it was to assist if leaving the humans
alone would suffice or if they could
present a threat once he to make the
final blow himself gai swoops in to
steal the day with Gabby Maru turning
around to look at him the two Doshi used
their abilities to attack our boy while
his guard was down Gibby though having
achieved Bliss perceives the attack and
quickly manages to jump off G side
towards the butterfly Doshi falling down
upon him now Gabby uses his NPO Stone
storm to peep at his opponent while
simultaneously toay again kills the cped
DOI with Dow still a mystery to him
Gabby Maru figures that if he
experiments more with it he can find a
way to damage his enemies since they
can't question the like obviously Merk
to DOI now fi considers asking May for
more information but gusa thinks it
would be best for her to return home
having saved his life twice gabim Maru
wanted to repay his debt to May by going
along with whatever she wanted to do
knowing of the notes that Tara had
written on Gabby before the mission had
begun fuchi notices that his behavior is
different from what she had interpreted
and wonders if this new soft side of him
will help him on his mission suddenly
though gabimaru begins bleeding from the
nose before collapsing to the ground
confusing everyone around him this is
for the fact that da is life force
itself to employ it in battle is to eat
away at one's life force using too much
will cause the backlash to not only
affect someone's body but even their
soul this is for the simple fact that
the body and soul are one and the same
they a manifestation of D meanwhile in
harri one of the seven as scene showing
ran the new training area which features
an indoor pool after presenting the
final part of the room which was like
the bju chamber you know like the old
sneaky room and other tins and
criticizes how ridiculous the idea was
but ran objects saying that by
copulating with others it can bring out
new powers duar then comes out of the
chamber absolutely covered in some stuff
after having go in an absolutely insane
session with another tenson and has
offered tan to recover after grabbing a
fresh glass of the immortality liquid
duar asks Ren about Mudan where out to
which it's revealed that as seiri enters
the gate to harai Mudan had gone to
confront them upon entering the Gateway
sagiri USA CA and hoko don't initially
see Mudan as instead they're Blown Away
by just how weird the surroundings are
bringing them all back to reality though
Mudan waves his hand causing hoko's head
to fall clean off finally so like with a
bunch of these names actually revealed
here I can tell you how dopee Yuki
actually is so each of these tenson true
names refers to Chinese names for
flowers rean is lotus Mudan is p zujan
which was the other guy's name I didn't
mention I'm pretty sure is hibiscus and
duar is chrysanthum which itself fits
into like the whole theme of fake Beauty
like I'm not entirely with the
flower meanings themselves but from what
I read online their meanings almost
perfectly reflect how each specific tens
and tries to act with the outgoing
appearance and all that kind of stuff so
elsewhere and back on the mainland in an
in in the Satsuma domain and after
learning of his return from the island
the Shogun officials ask your asimon
jica about the events that had occurred
jica explains that before they even
arrived on the island chobe killed his
assigned criminal so with a hiy heart he
had chosen to return back from the
mission even still the current had
forced him to the island eventually
though the man did make it home after
cutting the story short about how he
even managed to escape an official bed
him to explain in detail about what
exactly happened during his Escape but J
refuses saying that explaining it would
only be Troublesome and he no longer
wanted to be involved with that hellish
Place Another Yamada of Simon then
interrupts and bow while apologizing for
ja's Behavior knowing that the Yamada
now before them isn't any ordinary man
the representative overlooks his offense
and ra a message from the Shogun
ordering more asimon to travel to the
island after the meeting ja complains to
like the Star Wars Anakin want to be
over here how the asman were being
treated as porns but the young bloke
shugan reprimands him for his behavior
towards the officials hearing J's half
Lex reply about Shan's presence being a
help to him in the meeting shugan
becomes Furious and tells him to change
his attitude as it is be fitting for a
samurai J apologizes and then like
obviously instead of pushing the issue
further inquires as to what
reinforcements they' bring along on this
journey to the island shun informs him
that instead of criminals the Shogun
plans to hire ninja from iag gur during
the time chica was returning from the
islands another screening was held to
gauge the average strength of criminals
once the battle commenced every single
one of the criminals was annihilated by
iur Shinobi the reason for their
involvement in the return to the island
is because and obviously the chief wants
to make certain of someone's demise
shugan explains that they will make for
the island in a few days and bring a
swift end to the mission having walked
outside now a random dude then comes up
to JA asking what they should do with
the random giant monster here that he
had brought back from the island J's
like actually goated man so cooked that
he completely forgot to even bring up
the evidence he managed to grab or
fleeing the island either way he states
to them that it never really felt like
the right time to reveal the literal
monsters had fished out of the ocean
walking up shugan then takes a closer
inspection curious as to what in the
world it is but the worker warned him
that it might be alive however the
Anakin looking wannabe states that the
creature was indeed deceased as he
couldn't sense any waves of Life Force
coming from it honestly you know I keep
bringing up the whole Anakin thing but
like when I first read through it at
this exact point and without even
knowing his backstory yet I feel like
this dude had just merked a whole
village or something he just has that
weird demeanor about him you know what I
mean like he's just got something going
he's just he's just a little bit odd
nearby and after having met with two
shadowy figures it's confirmed that the
rank 2 shugan and rank three jica will
be joining them on a journey to the
island that's based purely on someone's
ability skipping back to like the
moments before our main crew entered
harri so after traveling for a day
sigiri Yara cinta and hoko finally
managed to reach the gates of harri just
like before they taken the odd
surroundings when all of a sudden a
random figure in front of them cuts off
hoko's head from a distance Mudan cruy
jokes that is impressed with him is they
the first humans in over a millennium
who have made it inside of Rai usara
senses everything thing in front of them
definely wasn't human and attempts to
flee but is caught in an instant by him
Zari draws his sword and demands to let
USA go when from the ground below hoko
states that he is Lord tensen the peion
spirit enthroned fuku jukon obviously we
know him as Mudan one of the seven
gender Benders and as he looks at the
tree quickly figures that hoko was still
alive however due to his size being
reduced to only his head now he tells
the others that his aration process will
only speed up from that point onwards
Hoku accepts his fa since he obviously
believes that his soul will rest in her
rise yet and probably the biggest gut
punch for the Bonsai King Mudan Smiles
stating that the religious beliefs of
his were all lies in order to maintain
the peace and structure on the islands
in truth every living thing on the
island was the result of
experimentations and the humans that
ventured to the islands were merely
research materials leading intellect
that entire theory of just research
materials on humans coming up behind him
he presents the Kyoshi as examples of
his experiments by the way these Kyoshi
are like Yuki kaku's messed up take on
the historical Jang XI or China hopping
zombie or vampire so they just you know
like an interesting parallel that Yuki's
gone and chucked into the story again
anyways with the others disgusted with
what he's done Mudan states that he just
loves tinkering around but this isn't
even half of what he could do and that
the higher quality humans usually become
tan hearing him bring up this random tan
thing Cent questions if he was actually
talking about the elixe of Life quickly
realizing what Cent was referring to
Mudan tells him that it does exist yet
The Elixir doesn't actually benefit
humans as it will only turn them into
trees so if they are actually here for
that then there isn't any chance they'll
find what they're looking for after
hearing this piece of information saryi
worries over gab Maru as now it doesn't
even seem like there's a way to complete
the mission breaking a train of thought
though Mudan just asks that they
surrender as their mission has ended
here catching them by surprise though
usera substitutes herself for an arbide
tree appearing directly behind him she
throws a bunch of kunai into the back of
Mudan then as she begins to fall pulls
out her sword while chanting and slices
The Immortal being just as quickly
darting away from the monster she grabs
A's shoulder turning the direction she
was facing and telling her that they
need to escape while they have the
chance with the others trying to Gap it
a regenerating Mudan comments that she's
extremely impressive but got one thing
wrong the Kyoshi are not servants but
toys again with a flick of the wrist
Mudan commands the Koshi to jump at Yara
and detonate upon coming into close
contact getting caught between the two
of them Yara only barely manages to
avoid the explosion rising to her knees
Mudan notes that though she's hitting it
extremely well she can already perceive
Dow wanting to back up his girl Center
steps forth telling M that if this
concerns her life and death then he'll
have to go through him becoming
intrigued The Immortal comments that if
user has the aptitude for it then he'll
teach her how to properly whe down if
not then she'll make quality tan either
way having watched centa step out in
front of her prepared to put his life on
the line sigiri wonders if he had any
attachments to us a Rea not interested
in anyone but the Shinobi mud rushes
towards sigiri telling her to move aside
before launching her across the area
using a distant strike turning his
attention to usera m asked if she
observed how we gathered down together
before going any further though CA who's
like way quicker than I ever expected
cuts off both of mud's hands saying that
he will have to get past him first
jumping him from behind Yara tells the
number five to back off before using her
nimpo slime strength to trap the
creature wondering what could possibly
work on him she uses NPO nect to poison
to melt away the immortal shell then
follows up and annihilates the rest of
him with NPO Grim garat Reviving himself
as a bunch of thorns he taunts TOA
calling her application of D nothing
more than a child flailing around
thinking that if they keep him blinded
they might stand a chance see to cut the
top part of mud's head but it's utterly
useless as he taunts them while blind he
also ceases the Regeneration of his eyes
and Dodges every single one of their
attacks getting in next to usara he
grabs her leg and swings her towards
Center knocking them both to the ground
the reason that Mudan is able to
comfortably fight back even more blind
is obviously because Dow is felt not
seen with someone's eyes if he cloaks
himself in it it allows him to feel out
the movements of his opponents and tells
him that they are utterly no match for
him sing there fully tapos out of his
mind the immortal God Rew welcomes them
to harai causing CA to fall into dispar
upon not knowing what to do against such
a monster nearby sigari tries to recover
from mud's earlier attack stating that
it was like it affected her very Soul
she pleads with hoko to think back over
all of the Tex he owns for anything that
relates to a possible weakness hoko
though who is obviously going through it
realizing that everything he's even KN
was a lie says that he just he can't be
stopped since he has the powers of a God
and he's already accepted his passing
unable to just give up though sigari
encourages him to try and remember
anything and remind him of the fact that
if they don't survive here then he'll
never see May again cutting in Mudan
notes that user rehar substitution
technique and other uses of Da appear to
have the same attribute as him though
this left too confused as to like what
he was even talking about not noticing
saryi behind him obviously he considers
taking out ca but quickly catches on and
avoids the sneak attack having figured
out that he was using someone's intent
to figure out the next movements saryi
throws his sword forth wondering what an
without intent would do Mudan I swear
this like this man just closed his eyes
or something but this dude just watches
as sigar's blade flies straight into his
Tandon with hoko screaming at her to
finish the job sigari catches up to her
blade and Cleaves down pulling the blade
through the monster's Tandon the reason
that the tanon is such a vital spot to
attack throughout the series is because
Dow is born there then from there it
Cycles around somebody's body before
returning back to that point so on the
case with sary even if someone like tens
and takes damage in the tendon it should
theoretically destroy them Over time
however mud reveals himself to be
perfectly fine explaining that attacks
without doubt do not harm him having
already come to that conclusion sigari
thanks him as all she needed was to get
in close and confirm exactly how it was
activated taking a breath sigari
releases a massive burst of Dow
completely confusing the immortal nerd
shocked by this phenomenon Mudan leans
back just enough to avoid the lethal
swing trying to think about what in the
world just happened Muran quickly comes
to the conclusion that Ziri can also
control da and gleefully smiles to the
stuff that so far throughout the series
like her experience with being near
Gabby Maru and fighting Roku Rota Zari
knows that she's already able to
perceive da all she has to do now is and
put a certain amount of energy while
controlling her breathing patterns after
learning that sigar's Dow can indeed
harm him Mudan screams in Delight
wondering if she become another piece of
beautiful art or manage to kill him
first placing his hands together and
using hojutsu earthy night Pilgrim he
instantly vanishes and appears before an
unaware sigari attempting to attack her
seeing through his trick usia restrain
bra Mudan using her strings and calls
out to saryi saying that he's using a
similar ability to her substitution
technique seizing the opportunity sigari
tries to take out Mudan but the immortal
uses the sent two technique to release a
burst of D from his mouth that afflict
the attack allowing him to kick her back
then with both girl somewhat occupied
commands the Kyoshi to attack usera
coming in clutch though CA quickly Cuts
them down before taking a distant Dow
strike directly to the chest thinking
that the battle's going smoothly for him
Mudan taunts the group letting them know
that it's easy to read their movement
yet and that typical think before you
speak manga way of doing things dude has
his leg forcefully detached by user
rehard using a nimpo whip slash closing
in the group absolutely ravages The
Immortal while he simultaneously taunts
them for just how well they're doing
quickly escaping the mess before secury
strikes Mudan levitates up into the sky
above them using Hutu Earth Yang Sky
Pilgrim speaking as if this dude's a God
or something it says that those ignorant
of the way of D would consider his
techniques to be divine having summoned
large water droplet he then activate
senjutsu tin splitter sending all of
them rocketing towards the ground below
cracking the very floor that they're
standing on with blood beginning to fall
from who knows Zary notes just how much
of his stamina is being robbed by this
Dow remembering mud's previous statement
about different types of Dow usea and
forms her that her Dow might be the
specific type that coun as hiss needing
to force an opening for sigari to strike
him down she steps forth and uses that
sticky string ability of hers to bring
the immortal closer after withstanding a
point blank showering for mud's 10
splitter she ropes the creature towards
the floor while screaming out to saryi
to finish the job reappearing himself
the Beaton and Bru centa seizes his
chance to pen him down allowing saryi a
few more moments to prepare her attack
boosting in saryi slices straight
through the Tandon of Mudan while
implementing her specific affinity for
da finishing off the supposedly IM
mortal creature absolutely naked from
the battle they just endured both Yara
and sigari quietly Rejoice after finally
ending their fight with Mudan scary
comes to hoko's Aid and Recaps what she
knows about da the amount of Da depends
on a specific individual and it can be
boasted or Listen by manipulating one's
spiritual intensity there are different
types of attributes Each of which can
give someone an advantage over the other
however the most important thing that
the group confirmed even if it
disappointed them was that the elixe of
Life didn't even exist not in the form
that they suspected at least due to that
realization usera states that they would
have to come up with another plan but
it's no use thinking on something that
they can't do anything about looking
over though she sees the massive golden
head statues and considers the idea of
replacing the elixir with a massive
amount of gold putting that aside for
now though the group just decide to sit
down and rest sigari sits down with
centa and hears him give yaria a
compliment making her question if he had
any feelings for her CA denies this and
says that it's actually he's more
envious of usaras and AE Freedom during
his childhood he really wanted to become
an artist but for Generations the boys
inside of his family had been sent to
train under the Amada Clan he couldn't
deny or change his future because it was
tradition though in truth he hated it
all the idea of killing most of all
struck a note within him that led him to
seek religion and eventually become a
scholar in the end centa chose to
abandon his dream and carry out his
duties as an executioner he recalls how
moments after taking out marrow yaria
managed to see right through him and how
he admires the way she seems so free
feeling similar about Gabby Maro and how
he's changed over this Mission saryi
brings up the possibility that in the
future all of them could work together
on the island nearby usan notices that
mud's body is continuing to turn into
flowers at a progressively alarming rate
instantly a launches towards Yara taking
her by surprise CA though like the weeb
king he is quickly comes in shoving her
out of the way but sadly receiving a
direct hit by the plants falling into a
hallucination as show CA thinking about
Yara while showing the beautiful artwork
he made of her deeply sinful was the way
of his work yet she was the Gale to
completely change the perception he had
about everything back in the present the
effects of mud's last dit attack caused
flowers to instantly begin sprouting
from the head of centa confirming his
demise rest and peace big senser
absolute wee Legend above him though
sigaran usera turn up to watch in horror
as Mudan starts to transform into a
monster before completing his
transformation as a visual
representation of Yin and Yang at last
the flabbergasted humans knowing that
they now are completely unable to do
anything against another attack reading
itself it shs up ple Thora of similar
Stingers towards the girl however saving
the day the Blind King Yamada asimon
Shion arrives on time and beautifully
Cuts The Stingers quickly acting he then
orders and nuga to remove the growing
flowers from ca's body and tell sigari
that he will stand in for the fight
against this creature after naruga helps
remove ca's blooming flowers saryi asks
hoko if there was a way to save him
unfortunately hoko states that it was
beyond his control either way she helps
centa by giving him medicine to slow
down the bleeding sary looks towards
Shon and asks about his current
condition but nuga informs her that Shon
is more than capable enough to fight the
monster and that they came with the
purpose of finding a certain someone
using the knowledge he acquired from the
experimentation on the sohi Shon fends
off a bunch of The Stingers before
sprinting at the creature and using
fiend's flurry along with Autumn RS to
injure it not bothered Mudan shiko form
just annihilates the area by creating
more T Splitters to rain down from above
throwing his sword forth through the
smoke as a distraction Shon then appears
himself and kicks the monster across the
courtyard however random flowers start
sprouting up all over Shon due to the
scratches he was given by the monster
Stingers without even considering the
damage that he would take he removed him
by slicing away the steam of every
flower on his body this despite the
setback shiran refuses to give up
stating that he has no Death Wish yet if
death lies in the coming road then he'll
accept it without hesitation sigari
tries to help Adam but naruga stops her
stating that she can even barely walk
herself let alone fight regardless
sigari explains that she can allow Shion
to sacrifice himself for the lives of
others however if she does intervene
then by working together they could
actually win hearing this nuga is
persuaded to fight alongside but Usha
complains that she just can't and she's
too low on energy walking over to them
rugi randomly hugs both Yara and sigari
explaining it as this weird way to
restore stamina that she'd been doing
from a very young age and now after
learning of Da tried to implement it
differently able to move now because of
it Zaria and nuga ready themselves to
step into the battlefield before doing
so though the two coat themselves in
bandages from usera as protective fluid
as a way to prevent infection from the
monster Stingers then they both step in
a fight alongside Shion getting new
blind King's attention she informs him
that she knows the monster's weak point
so they plan to take him down will be
distracting the monster while he gets in
behind and takes out its Tandon rushing
at them M attempts to take out naruga
first who somehow manages to weave in
and out of all of The Stingers not
seeing his hand though Muran almost
manages to slam down on arug guy however
secur manages to come in clutch slashing
at the hand and defending himself from a
secondary Stinger attack rushing to get
behind the monster himself Shion uses
his Harvest shower technique to create
an opening but it's just no use as the
monster quickly retaliates shooting a
blast of Da towards the samurai refusing
to be pushed back Shion charges forth
jumps into the sky and Strikes down on
the creature yes this was all actually a
ruse as he uses this moment to land on
the ground and strafe under the
monster's leg as it was still coming
down appearing behind its back now Shion
unleashes a flurry of slices that
seemingly cut through its branch-like
legs dropping it to the floor below now
at somewhat of a similar height the
monster tries to defend itself but Shon
forces himself through the attacks while
sigari restrains one of its hands with
his sword allowing Shion to get behind
the Monster again thinking about
everything that has happened since he
made landfall Shon becomes enraged the
that all he could do was flee while his
disciple was dying as unforgivable for
his own unforgivable crimes of weakness
he curses the gods stating that until
this fo's life ends Yamada a Simon Shon
Shan know exoneration this next
technique of his took years to craft
thousands of lives made this hidden
technique so lethal for Shion
manipulating these ways of Doubt is akin
to manipulating his own life force and
spirit swinging his blade down now he
threatens these false gods telling them
that it's time they learn about the
fleeting nature of a normal life life
it's Beauty and Terror Shon swings his
blade down towards the monsterous Tandon
but halts himself after not sensing any
strong waves making himself wonder if
those were even its weak points which is
massive after the like the just the
whole speech he went through before that
knowing that he doesn't have time to
overthink the situation Center the goat
arises From the Ashes for a moment to
scream out that the monster's weakness
is it oval since his body is plant-based
guiding him to exactly where the ovules
located on the creature Shon Dives forth
dodging The regenerator Stingers and
slashing at the weak spot causing more
multile Mudan heads to begin sprouting
out one of the heads becomes captivated
by shion's unwavering ability to face
death stating that they truly achieved
Bliss Yen and yang in Perfect Harmony
slashing at the open weak spot now Shion
finally manages to take down Mudan
sending the massive creature he formed
crashing onto the ground below with it
beginning to dissipate now the
surrounding area becomes covered in
beautiful looking
flowers after finally ending the battle
saryi rushes over to Center who's still
like somehow alive at this point but
really succumbing to his wounds sary
begs use Rea to apply more of her
medicine to him however she refuses as
it just wouldn't make sense to use the
remaining amount she has left on centa
when he's guaranteed to die instead
she's more of a realist and understands
that centa knows he's at the end of his
road so it only makes sense to give the
rest to sh on user her comfort center as
she tells him to let go of his duties as
an executioner and think about something
that he truly desires as his last
memories crouching down beside centa in
his final moments she tells him to think
about something else instead of this on
bound stuff think about something that
he holds dear like a family pet or a
lover he won't ever see again and if it
helps she'll hold him close in these
dark times slowly passing away now Santa
just thinks about the few small Joys he
had in life and now the beautiful Yara
next to him as he dies with a smile on
his face in a moment of silence the
group buries his body and decides to
rest before continuing on their Journey
scary thanks usara and nuga for their
help but states that from now on she
will not suffer the death of another
Ally all of them will survive and escape
this island no matter what elsewhere and
after waking up from his unconscious
State Gabby Maru instinctively jumps
from where he was to see gen tiu saai
fuchi and may all just chilling out
staring at him fui informs him that
they're situated in a cave halfway up
the valley and it just stopping for the
night gabu thinks to himself that he
can't seem to remember all of the
details to how he fell unconscious with
them awake now though thei begins going
over what they know so far about da
meanwhile sar's group into harai and
settle inside one of the buildings to to
go over what they know so far Yara and
nugi happily use the opportunity to
change into some like Chinese looking
clothing while Shion tries to discuss
what they know about Dow he explains
that if use da wisely or there will be
grave consequences for their body mind
and in the worst cases even death
remembering what Hoku had told him Shion
brings up the idea that multiple types
of waves or Dow actually exist in his
eyes there would have to be wood fire
earth metal and water these five
attributes are locked into a weave of
constant influence some types would help
to heal or restore someone's D whereas
others would do the opposite and hinder
someone's to a greater extent Shan
believes that if they can exploit these
attributes or types then maybe even the
Immortals might be failed nuga then
reminds him that they need to also focus
on acquiring the elixe of Life watch
from what we know doesn't exactly exist
in Fruit likee form yuz states that from
like what Mudan had said about the
electure during the early stages of
their fight it's not actually what
they're looking for however according to
Gabby Maru his village Chief is Immortal
because of an electure which proves that
something must exist exist being a
kunoichi though usera just knows how
these villagers work behind the scenes
and explains the possibilities of the
chief using an illusion known as gutu to
try and fool his people into thinking
that he was an immortal in order for
them to bend to his authority meanwhile
fi interprets May's words and explains
to them that the proper use of certain
attributes will help them defeat the
enemy while listening Gabby Maru wonders
if he has some kind of Amnesia or mind
blank as he still unable to recall
anything from the past with this in mind
and at the same time usera explains her
theory that Gab gab maru's wife might
also be an illusion set up by the clan
in order for Gabby Maru to have a
purpose in surviving his missions so
Gary stands there shocked unable to
reply while over there in the cave Gabby
Maru confirms that he can't remember
anything once more he knows that he is
Gabby Maru the hollow the strongest
Shinobi in IA gur but because his memory
is fragmented decides to currently go
along with what's happening until he can
determine whether the people around him
are allies or hideing their true nature
having finished discussing what they
know about D POI decides that they
should get some rest for now and move
move off tomorrow later on as the others
sleep May walks outside to check up on
Gabby who tells her he's okay but may
becomes shocked after seeing that half
of his head da is completely gone at the
same time inside of her ey scary sits
outside until she's also joined by Shion
the two J around for a moment but saryi
can't help to think about all of her
Fallen comrades what could have possibly
happened to Gabby Maru after hearing her
concern Shion asked if secui had
feelings for Gabby Maru however she
stops him Midway and denies his
allegations nevertheless she explains
that she feels sorry for Gabby Maru he
was born into a murderous Village and
his past still haunts him plus what's
even worse is the fact that if user Rea
is correct about his wife not even
existing then his motivation for
surviving this mission was a complete
fast Zary apologizes to Shion for
spewing out all of her thoughts onto him
however Shion explains that he
understands what she was talking about
and says that he can overlook this
matter causing saryi to laugh at his pun
you know like obviously cuz our men's
blind and everything the next day though
Gabby Mar's group then leave the cave
and travel up the rest of the valley
before encountering the brothers chobe
and TOA hearing fi say that More Humans
might mean more friends chobe smiles and
spin kicks Gabby Maru back on demon time
Gabby vanishes from in front of chobe
lands on his shoulders and Sam takes him
out in one swift move however May
screams out warning him that ch's Dow is
massive randomly grabbing a hold of him
chob stands back up and rips Gabby into
the ground telling them that he isn't
interested in becoming allies elsewhere
and after having LIF the mainland now
Lord Aoki finds it foolish that the
Shogun has plan is sent off around 50
iur ninja believing that their leader
has motives of his own shugan tries to
calm the Lord down assuming that his
concern is with the multiple Ninja on
board randomly though aoku questions if
him and the other three as men were
capable of controlling these ninja since
two of them seemed to be unranked yo so
uh rolling up to the island along with
rank four jaica and the egy eyes in
standing is the little man Karu and the
Beautiful but still in matched Isuzu the
little man himself Kio he isn't ranked
because the man is still young to
actually take part in the system and
Isuzu isn't as well because she takes
the role as a combat instructor employed
personally by the Shogun Shogun states
that they don't just approach this
Mission as mere observers no the whole
purpose for the expedition to the island
is to back up and support the Vanguard
Karu who's just like obviously listening
to all of this becomes annoyed with Aoki
as he thinks it's pathetic some random
Old Fart Can Judge them because they're
unranked when in all reality he could
probably take them out before the dude
even knows what happened to him asuzu
tries to stop him but kiar reflexes the
fact that he could literally take down
everyone on the ship alone and cuts the
mask of the Ninja that appears next to
him furious with kir maru's rude
Behavior Isuzu draws her blade placing
it near his neck and demanding that his
sheaths his sword were the two
exchanging cold glares at each other
another random EA kakur ninja tells them
that they mustn't worry about them at
all noticing him she awkwardly
apologizes to the male ninja but he
continues to assure her that he didn't
mind and if they still had doubts then
to pick any one of them then that a
chosen one will be thrown overboard to
show their loyalty intrigued K
hilariously tests his loyalty by
choosing the ninja who spoke up is the
one to take himself out crazily enough
it's shown that the dude was the leader
of the Aur Squad and before following
through with what he promised passed on
the leadership to the ninja next to him
following through with the order now he
takes himself out proving the Loyalty
the squad commands crazily enough like I
didn't actually say it while he was
passing away there but he mutters a tune
just before passing away which is called
the toyan it's a tune that accompanies a
childhood game similar to like London
bridges falling down when you're in the
pool and you go under the water type
thing and funnily enough it's still off
often used on the modern day crosswalks
as they tun to let people know when it
is and when it isn't safe to cross When
the Music Stops obviously the game is
over and that was representative of like
the tune the dude sung I thought it was
quite uh poetic Yuki right there anyway
continuing on having gained leadership
the other ninja speaks up saying that
the only desire to exist is tools and
pleads for their trust at that moment
one of the other Ean ninjas walks over
to his former boss and remembers the
orders given to them by the chief
infiltrate this Mission and kill Gibby
Maru ensure that he is per from this
world even if you have to sacrifice
yourselves for the cause over on the
other side of the boat Karu discusses
the validity of like what's just going
on with Shun calling them all just
random weirdos shun agrees explaining
that it doesn't matter as he's never
like trusted them to begin with all he's
ever seen them as is criminals they
themselves alone are enough to find the
electure of Life becoming enraged with
the thought of losing even more loved
ones shugan States has resolved to have
every Criminal on the island executed so
as clan members can return home K throws
out the possibility of of already all of
them being failed yet after receiving a
vicious clear Sprints off I always laugh
at this as well but shugan hopes that
eizen has big man the rank number one
and that everyone else is still safe on
the island meanwhile chica questions
Aoki if bringing in all of these Shady
dudes was going to make the mission more
difficult again it's reiterated that
it's the shogun's plans to make a swift
resolution and he thinks that the
Vanguard will be overjoyed by the
upcoming arrival however chica knows the
reality of the situation the ship isn't
the bringer of Hope no only chaos and
death the personification of a vessel
equipped with people to drive them to
hell even faster the stuff of nightmares
well this in mind ja tries one last time
to get him to have the ship to return
home however it's obviously T like no
use honestly I really really like ja his
characters too cool and he's really
really mysterious kind of reminds me of
the old ogan at this point in the series
or similar characters either way like
they're just so many amazing lines in
the story that are almost artistic with
the way that they spark some sort of
vivid image in your head both sh when he
was like trying to fail Mudan and both
here with jaica are prime examples I
think it plays into the whole time
period that Japan is in throughout the
series it's one where like art and
language flourished and I think it's
perfectly adapted into the story in its
own kind of like subtle way with like ca
passing away for example and how like
you got to see his own artistic
representation of what usera would have
looked like just really cool I don't
know moving forward floating there as he
rebounds back off the ground Gabby Maru
knows that chob just healed a fatal
wound and figures that he's most likely
also one of those Immortals Gabby shoots
a towards chob but it's comfortably
blocked having a hold of his leg now the
criminal then flings Gabby over and
smashes him into the ground below as if
he had some sort of like superhuman
strength Gabby Mar who's still tripping
at this point focuses his mind on trying
to take out chob he screams and he's
going to tear him to pieces before
pulling up his mask and activating nimpo
blooming needle shooting at a rock
straight towards his opponent TR manages
to dodge but Gabby Maru uses the
previous attack as a distraction to
quickly get above his Target a moral or
not Gabby foolishly assumes that if he
targets the brain and other senses then
it should allow him to get the other
hand however as we've learned so far
when someone can manipulate Dow that
that just won't work instead try kicks
Gabby in the head knowing exactly where
he was just off presence alone Gabby Mar
then bites at him as a last TCH effort
which completely throws chobby off
jumping back he wonders as to why he's
acting so uncivilized while at the same
time Gabby still on the animal Vibe
tries to bite his opponent in vital
areas managing to get on his shoulders
Gabby tries to bite down once more but
is unable to do any damage as ch's
wounds are instantly healed standing
opposite each other now chobby steps it
up a notch and Stomps the ground causing
the area to break apart leaving Gabby
open to a free hit as he struggles with
his footing Toby comments that gabaro is
weak and uses his Dow to strike him
standing nearby and having watched the
entire battle so far G wonders why Gabby
Maru is fighting poorly in comparison to
his last battle and asks May if she has
any idea being able to see da clearly
May knows that gab's energy is lacking
its form and he lost something extremely
important to him but due to her
inability to communicate properly the
others can't follow what she's saying
beginning to take a fair amount of
damage now troby calls outat to attack
the others listening to his brosi T
flies forth and goes after gusai
assuming that because he had lost his
hand he's easy taking toay gusai the
dragon utterly perplexed by this
person's choice to attack him first
catches his sword and headbutts TOA
while stealing his blade in the process
insulted with the thought that a kid
could take him out he throws the former
of assignment's Blade down telling them
to get ready for the real battle in to's
mind he only sees himself as an
extension of his older brother and his
brother decides the order of things
screaming at the Doshi Tom then gets it
to join the battle commanding it to
attack the smaller ones bu fuchi who
still with May steps in to guard her
back in the other beat down and seeing
as how he was being overpowered gabimaru
ignites his body and solely focuses on
destroying chob he knows that when on
the verge of death a Shinobi can wreak
Untold levels of Destruction upon their
enemy now completely Ablaze he Sprints
towards the immortal criminal and uses
Nimo Burning Bridge in combination with
nmo Stone storm to send a bunch of
heated rocks flying through chob
crashing to the ground Gabby Maru gets
on top of him prepared to send himself
and chob to the shadow realm the
criminal tries saying that they'll both
perish if he continues but Gabby
literally doesn't care he doesn't even
know why he's on this random island or
partaking in this mission to begin with
if he dies right now it's not like it'll
even matter his village will just send
another person to take his place as at
the end of the day Shinobi are just a
hive with nothing to lose and those who
cling to life will never win hearing
this and becoming enraged with the idea
that he can't win because he has an
attachment to his brother CH thanks
Gabby Maru for helping him realize his
resolve so remember may and like the
strong weak stuff from earlier on well
as chobi states to himself that he does
indeed have something to lose his mind
becomes weaker and his body begins to
transform into his breakdown State
remember how I brought up earlier in the
video that kashiki literally means like
demon corpse undo or something like that
this literally here is I guess chobas
version of the Kikai form with his
breakdown State literally telling his
body to come apart or break down down
anyway moving forward I just love how
this form is called a breakdown cuz oh
my Lord these boys about to dance having
unlocked this new form try unleashes a
transformation and uncontrollably
attacks Gibby Maru Gibby tries to Ward
him off by releasing a large burst of
flames using Nimo Burning Bridge but
it's no use as the demon slashes his way
through them unable to block in time Big
C sends a bunch of tentacles shooting
through the hollow allowing them to toss
Gabby across the entire area activating
nimpo atic Blaze Gabby just barely
manages to detach himself from the vines
unable to see anymore to's Consciousness
begins to be consumed by the darkness
causing him to slash out in anger
wondering where in the world the ninja
could have gone with the other groups no
longer fighting gusa wonders why Gabby
isn't using Dow to fight like he did
yesterday May who knows what's coming on
obviously says that he is unable to use
da and can't win against chobe as the
man is just too strong falling into a
moment of deep thought Debby Maru makes
the conscious decision to use up his
remaining Life Force to kill chobe
however he is briefly stopped by a
vision of someone long forgotten
ignoring this uneasiness he rushes
towards chobi ready to do whatever it
takes watching these beasts become more
and more confused VCI just notes that
both of them have completely lost
themselves turning and seeing his
brother become more Beast than man Tomy
remembers g tiu's words from earlier and
realizes that chobi has been fighting
for his sake back in the battle chobi
continues on his Rampage sadly though he
soon comes to see that for the past few
blows as he wondered what he was he
unknowingly attacked his brother TOA who
would just tried to make him come back
to his senses stuck and unable to move
taking in what had just done TOA tries
to break through to his brother shell
telling him that he's everything in the
world to him sadly as he was doing this
though Gabby Maru saw the perfect
opportunity to deal the finishing blow
and prepared himself to do so not
wanting Gabby to burn away the last of
his D because he'll die May rushes in to
stop him from doing anything else
standing behind him she releases a
massive Blast from her Dow creating a
crater that causes Gabby Maru and the
two siblings to start falling Gabby Maru
manages to get himself to safety and as
chobe turns to look for an Escape Route
throw Stones forcing him deeper into the
hole thinking quickly choby uses his
Vines to throw to to safety while
telling him to wait for his return so
remember how gantai and fuchi don't
really know may yet like the S the hoko
group from before and seeing who used
this level of D makes them question just
how she accomplished such a feat and an
even more surprising Revelation for the
two it's shown that may was now fully
growing meanwhile inside of herai sari
suggests that they go outside and
reunite with gabimaru and the others
however uzia doesn't agree and instead
thinks their focus should be on trying
to escape from the island zi sees
through her intentions of wanting to
save herself and reveals her own plan to
return home safely with every remaining
person is then that way they have an
alibi Zaria reassures her that her
desire to escape hasn't changed it's
just that everyone will be leaving this
place together switching the
conversation up she Ponders if gab Maru
managed to arrive at the gate from the
very beginning toward us re her reveals
that he definitely did as she found
evidence that he was here before they
came in her eyes their best bet to bump
back into Gabby marrow now is actually
wait around that gate after deciding to
head over to the gate the girls note
that seeing her ey clearly during the
day is absolutely insane looking around
The Godly setting the group becomes
captivated by its Mystic Aura Hoku
remembers mud's words about Lord tenson
experimenting with humans lives and the
humans on the island acting as test
subjects curiously he asks himself if
the current humans on the island will
bring a change after seeing that they'
managed to take out an immortal and
wonders if he will still be alive when
they do so once they reach the gate the
group encounter f G tiai May TOA and an
unconscious Gabby Maru after the initial
surprise of everyone noticing each other
both of K and fui asked what happened in
their time apart after noticing that may
was still okay and had matured after
using her power Fuji expresses his
gratitude that her allies kept her safe
confused on how they even arrived here
hoko asked if they came up from the
ocean pets and after learning that they
did Hoku can only think that throughout
the thousand years he's lived no one had
managed to accomplish these Feats and
because of that believes that the
current Travelers are humans Beyond
Compare
after being informed of his boy's
passing Fuji stands next to C's grave
and cries in sorrow after confirming the
deaths of most groups and seeing the
remaining survivors Shon expresses
regret that so little have survived the
ordal on the island however gusai
comments that his feeling of regret was
wasted on the condemned criminals since
they were fed to kill each other the
moment everyone made landfall unlike
Shion thought he also states that
thanking all your comrades would survive
as ridiculous he then points towards
Toma sented like obvious the dude was a
traitor and offers to get rid of him not
wanting him to though Zary steps in to
stop him as without chob around as well
he really doesn't pose a threat at all
Uso is just being chilling there this
whole time interrupts and has everyone
around Focus their attention towards
Gabby maro's injuries stating that the
dude's literally knocking on death's
door rolling up fushi elaborates on what
happened before they got here and how he
expended far too much Dow he did what he
did when he came to killing him but
because the injuries go beyond physical
he wasn't able to do much kneeling down
and looking at her injured friend scary
watches as ging a rewake and instantly
tries to stand up saryi says that they
should look into his wounds but Gabby
Mar shrugs her off while saying he's
fine Jan warns him that without proper
treatment he will die but Gabby claims
that he's already accepted this fact
stunned with hearing the old Gabby again
scary just questions who he is looking
at her Gabby answers that she already
knows who he was he's Gabby Maru the
hollow launching himself forward Gabby
Maru attacks aary luckily for her though
big fuchi and Sh noticed what he was up
to and blocked the strike knowing that
the disturbance and one's Dow aect
memory sigari explains that Gabby Maru
has lost all of his memories due to
every battle he's fought wearing away at
the construction of his very Soul sigari
tries to Reas him with a confused friend
explaining that she is truly an ally and
just wants to help him after he
repeatedly tries pushing her away saryi
becomes enraged and uses Force to pin
him down Geno watches thinking they're
doing like the sneaky bju Jutsu or
something though fui doubts this while
May blushes saying that this act was
different yet similar in some fact which
you know what do you mean by I'm
confused scary on topic Gabby explains
that they don't really have times for
Such trivial activities but they need
his strength to escape this island so in
an attempt to wake him up even quicker
she reminds Gabby that he has someone to
return home to then finally in that
exact same moment Gabby maru's Dow is
restored and his memories began flooding
back in which is really confusing like I
I always get confused on how he managed
to gain his memories back there but it
gets revealed later on so don't you
worry so uh throwback boys and girls
remember after the crater incident that
happened earlier well after reaching the
very bottom of the belly and
regenerating his limbs Toby reflects on
his actions during the fight with Gabby
Maru looking at just how far down he
fell dude literally cracks the code and
figures out that the island is shaped
like a bow with ridges connecting the
middle part he then spots a group of
soan and decides to use them to test out
his applications of D meanwhile all of
the remaining survivors relocate to a
cave that g TI was I found to remove
themselves from Lord tens and sensor
ability that he has over her eye this is
just due to the fact that theader who is
ran if you haven't kind of figured out
by this point can sense with where they
are at all times using the Dow and the
ear remember like how there was a high
level of humidity to the island hiding
it to start with well it's my thought as
well that he uses these abilities to
hide the island while bringing in a
select few to turn into tan I'd love to
know like what you guys think on that
down below though so of course let me
know after again to like call Shon a
coward because he was scared of Lord
tinson and warned everyone to be
cautious he receives judgment from Yara
and nuga who also reiterates just how
dangerous they are having regained his
memory Shan asked Gabby Maru if he had
fought one as well and he confirms it he
also confirms to them that he knows how
to manipulate down now but wents about
learning it the hard way along with
finding out just how terrifying Lord
tenson truly was having told his
experience user rehard gives her opinion
that it would be best for them to escape
the island but Gabby Maru objects as he
knows that without the pardon he'll
never Escape hearing this Yara goes to
tell him about her Theory but a shocked
Gabby cuts her off knowing that she was
going to say his wife was just a form of
gutu he tries just pushing past what she
said but Yara wants to make sure she's
not walking into a trap our boy he knows
she exists though as he can tell just
based on the sensation he has when he
thinks about her wanting to know more
info that isn't just like sensation
based as it's not very logical of him to
think that a sensation is real Gabby
Maru describes the little things he can
remember about her like her voice or the
shape of her eyes and says that even now
on beautiful days like this when he's
drenched in nature he can sense her
nearby phasing into a blissful memory he
reveals her name is UI which I hope I
see right saying that this was the only
proof he had the only way to be sure was
to make it home and find out if she was
actually real his confidence causes
saryi to feel delighted and get huai who
kills her boy a man's man to feel like
he finally found a perfect fighting
partner I actually love G to say he's
such a damn cool character USA though
found it weird that a Shinobi like Gabby
Maru can talk about his weaknesses but
sheon adds in the fact that he could
sense Gabby maro's Dow growing which
proves to him that his wife is real and
people who have something to lose are
considered extremely strong which is
just like chob for example with him not
wanting to lose his brother so uh
funnily enough and and continuing with
the possible idea that she doesn't
actually exist yui doesn't really
confirm that it is a person the Kani he
used for a name simply means Bond or
connection and it is the first part of
how You' spell out like marriage in
Japanese so does she truly exist or is
she a manifestation made up by the chief
of the clan I'd love to know her
thoughts on all of it down below before
we get to the end of the series and
obviously if you if you've read the
series then you know like let me know
her thoughts on the series down below
back down in the valley though and after
murking every single Shan around chob is
met by ran who quit if he was the one
who took out Mudan elsewhere fuchi
feeling in like no mood to examine the
Doshi after finding out about the death
of his comrades decides to set him free
over inside the cave now sigari informs
fui that may is feeling ell and hasn't
been able to recover any of her strength
so would he be able to make her some
medicine annoyed though after finding
out that she's the same as Lord tenson
fi agrees to help but demands that in
return may tell them everything they
need to know about herself and Lord
tenson meanwhile Gabby M sits outside
and makes a request to the other four to
help him train to utilize Dow even more
efficiently super eager to learn more
himself thas starts off by attacking
with G inze sword dodging The slashes
Gabby focuses on sensing the movements
of his opponent's Dow not tracking with
his eyes big G then comes in and makes
his attack on Gabby but he easily uses
his da to sense the strike weaving out
of the way and allowing him to examine
gantai weak spots he then kicks off the
da in the sky to put some space between
him and the group nuga jumps in and
tries attacking however Gabby grabs her
and uses her to push back the others as
they approach as the battle continues
Gabby Maru believes that it's pointless
to try and H more refined techniques
than the Immortals since they've been
training for over a thousand years
instead the key to defeating Lord tenson
as to use their own Dow against them
standing back up naruga approaches Gabby
believing that he was more than capable
enough to take down lord tinson however
Gabby Maru believes that he still needs
more time to improve Big G G his deight
asks if he's finished with the warm-up
though cuz man's ke to get serious
before randomly diving forth raging out
and preparing to strike down on Gabby
while the other two start freaking out
thinking they're actually probably
battling back inside the cave fuchi
explains to Zari and usera that the
island the monsters and Lord tenson were
created by a singular entity this being
is apparently a famed hosi who used San
principles in his attempt to research
ways to achieve immortality for those
confused on what hosi is pretty much
it's an ancient Chinese Mystic versed in
divination and other Healing Arts this
particular Mystic developed methods to
Tiner with da directly from this he
created crossbreeds of creatures that
had similar off ities for da then after
an age of creation Lord tenson was
finally born the bean as a fusion of
human and plant da that is both male and
female both yin and yang hence how they
can change genders in an instant gender
Benders life forms usually use da over
the course of their life but the Lord
Ton's energy has been polished for over
a thousand years far beyond the scope of
any human ability Yara like who's
obviously confused over why they're even
here asks what their purposeful living
on the island was then fi explains that
the tens have been practicing dosm or
more specifically the inner ways of tan
which is meditation and the outer ways
of tan which is making the electure to
achieve immortality hearing this user
Rea and secary become shocked realizing
that the elixir does indeed exist yet
Fuji tells him that it's probably just a
prototype a potion created from
harvesting and extracting the Dow of
humans in order to expand the tenson
lives knowing this Fuji tells him that
it's possible to take out Lord tenson if
they doubt is deated curious after
learning this you to re questions why
they going further with their research
since they already created tan May
answer is saying that it was possible
that Lord Tinton was following the will
of their Master juuu fui explains that
juuu also known as Joe fuku in Japan was
a hosi Mystic and served the emperor of
the shin Dynasty who journeyed off to
research the secrets of immortality a
thousand years ago but eventually came
to an end once he entered Japan perhaps
though he never really came to an end
and instead lives on as someone to this
very day hm I want to know who like your
thoughts at this exact moment on who you
possibly think that this person could be
as given us this image of this dank
looking foot so surely that hence the
someone of great age who is still indeed
alive so this zuuu or Joe fuku person
like obviously just revealed before is
actually a real man from way back in the
3r century BC and as I mentioned earlier
in the video he was sent out to search
for this mythical mountain and the elixe
of life he oversaw a fleet of 60 vessels
and thousands of crew members Artisans
and civilians in 219 BC he actually made
it back after the first voyage having
unsuccessfully found the election or
pingl yet after hitting out 9 years
later and 210 BC he never returned some
people suggest that he ended up making
landfall near like Mount Fuji however in
how's Paradise it's obvious that the
man's Voyage ended in the sea Southwest
of Japan well the girls in fui discussed
the Joe fuu's existence May Fall's back
exhausted also revealing that her left
arm had turned into a branch she
explains that her usage of D is causing
her body to turn into a tree and she
needs to takeen energy in order to heal
usera suggests using a restoration
technique however May says that it won't
work since she has little doubt already
and because ran broke her Tandon causing
it to constantly leak out after the
cruel past May went through was shown to
us hoko then like the Champion ear
offered his D to fully heal her due to
how Lord tenson can extract da from
living life forms it's the only way for
May to actually heal herself but
obviously she's hesitant to sacrifice
hoko big Bonsai though insists as soon
he'll go through the process of ocation
anyway to him this is one way he can
also atone for his sins explaining that
he ignored May's desires of wanting to
leave the island and instead choosing to
raise her as a replacement to his
deceased daughter mate tearfully tells
hoko that from the time he found her she
always thought of him just like a father
she then accepts his offer placing out
her hand and absorbing his Dow with
hoko's energy flowing into may she gives
him her final farewell before returning
back to her young State meanwhile the
previously raging battle has come to a
peaceful end obviously you know like
remember how GED was and Gabby went at
it just before we skipped away well yeah
Shon is left impressed with Gabby Mar's
abilities and believes that he may have
what it takes to defeat Lord tensen Tom
then randomly drops down on his knees
and big skin teachers decide to help
train him how to wield a sword so that
he can gain the power to escape the
island himself Big G doesn't believe
that he can trust him just yet but in a
show of Honor Toma then cuts his hair
and asks once again to help make him
strong impressed with the little guy's
determination ganta agrees with helping
TOA and tells him to come follow him
back down in the toan valley ch notices
that the thing in front of him had the
exact same face as the creature he
fought earlier fascinated with the
hybridization chob had achieved ran
explains that they create the Waton H
flow that converts human bodies into tan
yet somehow even as the root of that
plant dug into ch's da he still kept a
sense of sou once you to examine him
further R attacks chob with an attack
similar to 10 splitter causing him to
quickly Dodge while realizing that he
has no chance in winning this battle in
an attempt to fight back he transforms
into his breakdown State and dashes atam
before letting loose a flurry of strikes
and states that ran just barely managed
to block somehow choby actually manages
to overwhelm Ren but finds it difficult
to keep the vines inside of his mind
from taking over his true body after
piercing Ran's Tandon chobby expands his
Vines and destroys the immortal's body
assuring to him that the Tandon was
indeed the correct place to take out
these creatures however and really
randomly ran then suddenly appears
behind chob again revealing that he
destroyed only one of his many clones
that he brought along with him after
seeing chobby unleash Dow from the Waton
H flower ran expresses his satisfication
at the fact he managed to control it and
decides to take him back to the Palace
TR tries to attack but is unable to
resist the effects of the vines allowing
ran to bend down in front of him and use
a dow strike to knock him unconscious
slowly falling into a dream he
reiterates his desire of not making the
same mistake as his father by abandoning
his brother later chy wakes up in a
beard and sees Ren as a female standing
nearby tending the plants ran explains
that she finds chob to be the final key
to completing her research and wishes to
understand his doubts cycle better
through botu jutu yeah but you know we
can't actually go there so just know
that your man is the key to unlocking
the perfect being sadly there is like so
much I can't actually go over in this
part of the story but pretty much
because chob is revealed to be the
perfect being in this case I guess you
could say when his Dow is extracted then
it will allow these creatures to turn
everyone on the mainland of Japan into
tan so yeah that's I guess the big evil
plan that's in store for our main crew
something else I also wanted to mention
was that the kanji and watan Hua Ates to
outside tan and flower meaning a flower
used for the outer way of tan literally
anyways later on in the day Al G big
gide breaks down crying in pain that may
had reverted back to her child body in
his eyes it was way more comfortable
carrying her around when she was older
actual Chad though ain't ain't none of
that weird stuff that's why I like G
he's a he's a champ in my eyes either
way back with the main group Shon in
collaboration with Gabby prepares to
announce the next plan however May
catches their attention when she senses
that the second Landing party has arriv
red on the island she knows that it
isn't Lord tenson but due to how she
can't articulate herself well says that
their Dow is very strong having taught
this man Shon believes that it's most
likely shugan and the other reserver
Simon who was sent as reinforcements by
the Shogun fui also tells them that
another group of criminals were to
accompany them as well curious Gabby
asks sigiri as shugan as a potential
ally and she vouches for him saying that
he might even be the strongest amongst
him however gusde doubts his statement
knowing that he'll need more than just
strength to survive here thinking back
on the past Shon confirms that shugan is
already able to perceive da since it was
actually him to First notice the six
scenes and call them waves over at the
coast shugan hands off his blade and
confronts a shin obviously man's yolked
up already able to perceive the
environment around him through the use
of Da alone the monster somehow manages
to grab him but through what he learned
while training with Shion Shan easily
lifts the monster's hands from his
shoulders and defeats it bear handed
back with our main Squad naruga is
impressed with the idea of how strong
shugan is however user mentions a
certain story that made him Infamous
Zary explains this story of how shugan
took out all of the captured members in
front of their leader in order to reveal
the remaining hidden members after he
revealed their location they too were
all arrested and well yeah you can
imagine definitely what happened next
hence how he gets the the Anakin name
those those poor kids the Shogun was so
impressed by his brutality that he
presented the young as Simon with a
ceremonial outfit and a named Blade the
fury butsu kanaki the group becomes
concerned but saryi reassures them
they're deep down he's a guy leading
fuchi to state that shugan was sari's
first crush she says that even if that
was the case she merely admires his
involvement and her earning a ranking in
the yada Clan back over with a sneaky
man and after taking out a group of soan
Isuzu and kumaru come to his aid but
shugan reassures them that as their
senior he will take responsibility on
taking care of the Lesser matters like
fighting the pathetic monsters moiri
believes that shugan will come to their
aid Shon disagrees and reveals the full
story of how suan not only merked the
entire silver serpent group but also
their loved ones since they might hold
some form of Vengeance towards the
Shogun Shan explains that shun despises
criminals and would not think of allying
with him or have anyone he Associates
work with him at all as the new group at
the shore begins traveling Chan stumbles
across his site where Isen was turned
into a pancake by Roku Rota after both
of his parents were taken out by an
Infamous Bandit shugan was dropped at
the door of the Amad Clan obviously in a
flash back and as the two begin talking
about what it means to be an executioner
shugan tells Isen that he fails to see
the logic and their Clan's way of
executing criminals and wonders why they
can't give them a painful death instead
Isen explains that such an act would
defile the execution grounds and the
chipping of his blade would be
meaningless being an esman means riding
yourself of that hatred and he'll hone
him into a great man he then tells him
that he looks forward to the day he
becomes a glorious blade in the present
shukin screams in pain over eisen's
death and instead of moving forward with
a mission makes a decision to lay his
soul to rest while giving him a proper
burial one of the Ninja thinks to
himself that three of these people are
extremely odd and J is just as random
himself with a priority for them being
Gabby Maru they all plan on using the
dangers of the island to outsmart the
Samurai and complete their mission out
of freaking nowhere though a massive
flower type thing drops down on the 50
or so ninja catching a few of them
looking up the group see a bunch of
monchin rolling up and trying to capture
them commanded by a Doshi another
massive flower thing drops down on the
trio but KO and Isuzu quickly cut it to
shreds while Shan sat there unmoved
still mourning eisen's passing so the
ninja also dispatched two squads of gin
to assist in bringing down the monin
after finishing his sutras shugan
finally says Isen can rest in peace not
even standing yet suan then swiftly
draws his blade and cuts down a Mion
that attempted to attack him from behind
angered with everything that he's seen
shugan smashes his brand new named blade
against the monster staff to repeatedly
damage it standing there and bleeding
from the eyes with rage he swears
Vengeance against all that reside on the
island hearing shugan declaring his
wrath to him the dohi prepares to attack
him with D however the fight quickly
comes to an end with shugan utterly
obliterating and stopping him from
regenerating he then starts to do some
really questionable acts J like
obviously gets him to stop and tries to
reason with shugan and returning to the
mainland with the information they've
gathered so far but is angrily told that
that's not going to happen he then asked
J why he hadn't drawn his blade yet
leading the old dude to state that he
can't even still shugan knows for a fact
that he can making him get even more
Furious cutting in on the boy Isuzu
tells him to calm down making him
realize the stupidity of his ways
quickly changing his demeanor shugan
apologizes to ja but States at his
earlier statement of eliminating
everything on the island was true so
don't forget that hearing this one of
the Ninja recommends that they should
handle everything in regards to
collecting information since the ninja
has special tactics in their area
meanwhile and back with our main Squad
the survivors of the Vanguard party
listen to shion's plan of separating
everyone into two groups where one finds
an Escape Route and the other finds the
tan elixe after Gant asks how exactly
are they going to fight Lord tenson Shon
repositions everyone and creates a
diagram on the ground of the Dow
attributes that each of them possess the
idea is that they will use their
attributes to hand each member of Lord
tenson and defeat them usera though
believes that it's hopeless to continue
due to the risks and not knowing who
they up against at the coast of the
island she then suggests an alternative
Way by finding a way off the island and
instead going into hiding as a way to
possibly survive Shon understands where
usera is coming from and knows that
there are honestly just too many
unknowns in the coming future so because
of this he takes everyone thoughts on
the matter into consideration by giving
them the option of going their own
separate ways or working together and
surviving after walking into the cave
Shon immediately senses the presence of
every single person behind him deciding
to move forward with his plan due to
their own personal reasons and surviving
with the situation growing more dire
Shion is at least relieved that they all
came to the same decision and tells them
that they are all each other's last
chance of
survival so after May does with thing
fuchi interprets for the group and
begins explaining the plan they're about
to undergo from what they can learn
harah is designed to be a massive
Fortress modeled of China's eang Palace
and these sea monsters prevent anything
from leaving the island however May
reveals that harai contains a numerous
ships at an underground Floodgate that
allows departure along a safe current so
the mission is to avoid confrontation
Acquire The Elixir and steal a ship to
make it back home on Gabby Maru tells
them that according to May the tan elixa
is located in a laboratory but the
palace's interior is constantly changing
what time during closer to the moment
they invade enemy territory Shion pulls
gabimaru and use ARA over to have them
instruct the group and the Art of
Espionage using Dow looking like an
absolute babe with these specs on USA
teaches the group on how they to M their
prisons by suppressing their Dow
afterwards Gabby Maru also nerded out
teachers his lesson and using Dow
against their opponents after the
training was over everyone is divided
into two teams the Escape rout team made
up of Big G Shion nugi Toma May and fui
and the elixa retrieval team made up of
the other three so while the three
powerhouses are off doing their thing
sourcing the elixe the Escape team needs
to find the boats and open the
floodgates realizing that may has wanted
to leave the island for a while now
Genai suggests that they let her depart
alone and not wait for the Electra team
however Gabby Maro asks May if there's
anything she desired to do before
leaving the island surprisingly May
tells him that she actually wished to
meet with ran and Jo fuku again to ask
them why they changed from how they were
before then escaping remembering his
wife's words to him about valuing every
day and living a decent life Gabby Maru
promises to fulfill May's wish no matter
what at a similar time inside of Rai
delar greets chob at the end of the
Doshi ritual ceremony but is stopped by
duar he cruy tells the other tenson that
there is no need to communicate with
livestock and just breathing the same
ear makes him feel ill angered by his
presence duar lashes out at chobe who
easily manages to block the strike
realizing just how much stronger he's
become troby tells the immortal that he
should have finished him off in the last
fight because now he can see through all
of his moves stopping him from further
escalating ran orders jar to behave
himself and has chob follow him to his
laboratory so that he can study his da
as the two walk and talk chobe notices
that he is starting to get used to this
new power but after looking at ran
senses that his D is on a completely
different level initially he was
planning on escaping as quickly as
possible and running back to TOA however
after seeing the difference in strength
decides to stick around in case he can
find some sort of weakness once entering
the laboratory we see a massive watan H
flower which is called a Bano these
flowers don't allow them to store extra
tan but unlike these smaller flowers it
can process a far greater quality of tan
all in one go the reason tan can't be
preserved is because over time Dow is
away at that of the human's life force
eventually and just like the human the
plant will soon weather before it can
produce the perfect quality tan this is
why ran desires ch's rear D to complete
his research again with Yuki like
referring to something from our world
here this Bano or pangu in Chinese is an
entity that appears in prominent
creation myth and this creation myth it
explains that in a world of nothingness
Bano was the giant who emerged from his
egg separated Yen and yang with his a
elevated the sky above the Earth and
upon his death turned himself into the
Sun Moon landscape wither and animals
pretty much it's the god of Earth in
this creation myth and possibly even
something similar in Hell's Paradise
meanwhile The Elixir retrieval team
infiltrates R and once safely landed on
the roofs signals to the others that the
area is clear to enter scary notices
that the plan is moving quickly and
wonders if it's truly time for the
mission to come to an end pulling up his
mask gabimaru states that they always
knew they were on a timer so yes
everyone will leave this island tonight
flashing back to the preparation fui
breaks down May's explanation and gives
out a basic layout of the castle he
reveals that each tenson has a sanctuary
of their own and the elixe and the
Escape ship are most likely in the
center area popping in May tells us who
was in each area of the castle in her
eyes the elixa is most likely with Ren
in the laboratory jar and daa will
between the old silly inside of the
bojutsu sanctum the taisu sanctum is the
domain of zujin shuu sanctum is the
meditation domain ruled by Gua and
finally the shuen sanctum run by Mudan
but you know that man ain't around
anymore so there's probably no one there
for the time being at least she also
states that since the bco flow droops at
night Brien will not be in the temple
conduct in research instead he'll most
likely move to the main residence where
Joe fuku resides making it possible to
also avoid running into him after
securing The electure Gabby Maru then
explains that he and Yara will land a
top the in Gates and will survey the
layout of the castle using their Dow
sensory and the present sigiri notices a
dreadfully Sinister amount of Doubt
coming from the palace and starts to
fall to her Gabby and Yara though
console her stating that it doesn't
bother them as they're already used to
it using what they learned in
preparation for this Mission both Gabby
and user take out all of the guards
while constantly keeping their Dow
supressed not to elute anyone after
taking out all of the Doshi the elixa
retrieval team successfully make it
through the first part of their
predetermined plan and enter the castle
most instantly after getting inside they
make it into the supposed room with the
electure Gabby opens the door and senses
the layout of the room but suddenly sees
Dow forming an entity in the middle
surprised if someone knew he was there
the Dow silhouette is revealed to be ran
who had the same idea of suppressing his
energy if you ain't subscribed yet by
the way just just over it stepping forth
May asks her younger brother how he knew
of their arrival ran commends them for
their attempt but reveals that chob has
already informed them that the humans
would be coming to invade the palace and
agreed to keep track of their arrival by
sensing the D on one condition this is
just due to the fact that after hurting
his brother in their last battle chobe
was able to track his exact location and
because you know Toma is with the group
he probably knows where the groupers
just like when he went up against zujun
Gabby Maru finds himself in trouble due
to ran possessing the water attrib which
hinders his fire attribute the plan if
they bumped into an enemy with a
stronger attribute was to run as if they
try fighting with such a heavy debuff
they've got no chance hopping into a
JoJo isk pose ran becomes delighted to
see May once again and begs her to
return back to their side explaining
that they no longer need to follow the
outer way of Dow since they've completed
their research in creating the electure
odly shocked Gabby asks for more info on
what he just said obviously because of
the fact that the tents and discovered
chob they feel that with his cooperation
they'll easily be able to create a
potent enough elixe all they need to do
now is produce more tan that has a
considerable quantity of exceptional
material that's why for this exact
reason ran has started the right of just
consumption as the end is indeed coming
near despite his plea May refuses and
says that she only wishes to say goodbye
to everyone to her now it's obvious that
she's different to them but dying is sad
instead she came to say goodbye before
leaving the island with everyone else
disappointed ran States that the ride of
just consumption would have to continue
and she can become another offerin after
sigi asks what he meant ran explains
that it was a ritual to capture and
offer the humans to the Grand Master
over with the boat Squad gen tiu sa
fuchi and Toma get separated from Shon
and nugi due to a massive cloud of mist
that obscures their Vision pushing
forward either way the three then bump
into dalar and du far while Shion and
nuga are approached by zuo Jin for a
second time knowing that they plan to
avoid Lord tenson has failed group
decided to move onto this second plan
which is just it's just straight up
hands giving everything they've got cuz
it's not like they're ever going to
outrun these FS not phase our boy
announces to Rand that they won't give
up without a fight and instead they're
going to beat him down and say goodbye
to this island seeing as how the ritual
has already begun ran prepars to let
loose knowing that all they need now is
sacrifices so I just want you to all
think back to the uh pod analogy I used
in one of the earlier videos I'm pretty
sure it was the very first video and how
it was literally shown to us on the
panels themselves now think about like
how what they're doing with us elixa is
simply another form of this old school
Japanese curse they're sticking all of
these venomous beasts into the island
which is literally shaped like a pot and
the hopes that they can procure a vile
of immortality juice I don't know it's
just something that clicks in my head
right now but I love how early on it's
foreshadow that this exact thing would
happen with chobe figuring out that the
island is kind of like a bowl knowing
that even though he's going up against
someone with an unfair Advantage Gabby
Maru tells thei and may to go search for
The Elixir while he and yera hold off
the creature however May warns him that
they are not in Ran's Temple shocking
Gabby Maru sing the kit coming at him
from behind though he quickly Dodges and
jumps back before flying forth at the
immortal trying to land a kick himself
but ran comfortably weaves out of the
way hopping into an unrealistically
messed up POS ran confirms his sister's
comments as he had reconstructed the
palace before they arrived apparently
the Dow of inorganic material was even
easier to manipulate than that of living
creatures constructing buildings and
renovating are all tasks that actually
fall to Ran So it's even easier for him
to control that than others with that he
creates some spikes from the floor that
trap May leaving her with nowhere to run
as he slowly closes in on her needing to
protect May gabim Maru decides to fight
but is unable to harm him due to not
possessing the right attribute user rear
sees an opening to attack and throws a
dow inbu kunai however the kunai bounces
off his body due to ran cloaking himself
in a dow likee armor getting caught off
guard ran slaps him with a fat double
kick that pushes both Gabby and user Rea
back observing his Dow Gabby Maro can
visibly see the thick layer of armor
protecting him from any attacks the
crazy thing about Ran's armor is that
unlike traditional armor that has holes
under the armpits and other vital spots
where you like have to move obviously
ran has no gaps at all to exploit it's
almost as if his Dow and muscles are in
Perfect Harmony flesh perfected needing
to force an opening Gabby reenters the
battle and fights ran vertically while
they both stand on a bunch of massive
pillars ran jumps at Gabby kicking away
a massive chunk of his pillar however
our man uses this to his Advantage as he
picks up the rocks and and activate Nino
Stone storm sending them rocketing back
at the immortal not phased due to the
like Elemental death ran just Returns
the ability by kicking him back at Gabby
causing him to drop to the ground Gabby
then tells Yara that it was time to
begin their next strategy confused after
hearing this ran exam his D and notices
that nothing has even changed so he
can't see how things would also change
in the battle Randon readies himself to
fight Gabby Maru who's now closing in
however Gabby then suddenly vanishes
from his sight before reappearing and
Landing a fat blow that sends the
immortal tumbling across the sanctuary
so back before the mission began
gabimaru explained that Dow was like a
current of water flowing around one's
body it's even tangible allowing the
user to change the speed size and
strength the attribute of got determines
which direction your energy flows you
normally have ways of competing opposite
attributes sadly though the doubt of the
current L tension are so massive that
the normal rules do not apply because of
this gab theorizes a three-step process
to use the enemy's down against them
firstly you weaken your own energy
around a specific part of your body to
take in their Dow then you ride the
current so that the boast of Dow
spinning around your body doesn't damage
you but floats around till you can
reverse its polarity and send it
straight back at the opponent in the
present gabimaru smashes ran into the
ground by redirecting the tenson Dow he
sinks his breathing with rain and falls
into place between tranquility and
serenity finding the middle ground and
allowing him to ward off any incoming
blows realizing that even getting grazed
by one of the Immortals attacks would be
brutal he considers studying the second
step to his plan but decides to hold off
for now slowly healing himself ran
becomes impressed by Gabby maru's skill
with Dow he explains that the thick
clouds of M tend to activate a person's
hidden Powers when they arrive yet he's
just something else Gabby in his eyes
possesses sheer Talent however Gabby
Maru does agrees with his comment
stating that everything that has
happened was because of everyone's
effort and the sacrifices they've made
along the way for the sole purpose of
defeating the Lord tenson while ran is
left shocked with gab's pure
determination scary quickly frees May
from the restraint and lets the others
know they've going ahead for the
electure screaming at them to behave
themselves though ran swings around and
attempts to stop them but has stopped
himself by Gabby Maru who yells at the
others to get it done still trying to
get past ran quickly figures that Gabby
is using his own da against him and
decides to suppress it yet as soon as he
does yaria comes in and slices the plat
man in two dting forth once more she
goes to finish the job but is warned by
Gabby to stop ran standing there and
impressed with the skills of his enemies
decides that in light of the ritual he's
not allowed to toy with them his body
then suddenly begins turning into a
bunch of flowers and vines before
exploding into his forearmed Kikai
State elsewhere rean sits in the ritual
Circle and reviews the names of the
human Invaders given by chobe with zujan
encountering Shion and nugi ran believes
that he holds the advantage since
shion's wood D will have no effect
against Zan's water D and nugi isn't
able to use hers yet still he does sense
a great deal of Rage coming from them
and knows that anger can greatly
increase someone's ability also at a
similar time gusai and fui face daar and
duar ran believes that his team will
defeat them with ease as neither of
their opponents have refined their Dow
though he does take note of Gabby Maro
as he can sense that they need to be
extremely careful with him after he
finally finishes his review ran presents
the completed elixe of life to Joe fuku
and announces that once they defeat the
human Invaders they will be ready to
depart to the mainland to continue with
the ultimate plan meanwhile the
assignment for the second Landing party
become exhausted after traveling so far
in such a short amount of time after
making it to the tan pits all of them
are disgusted and disheartened once they
find what remains of tenza and Genji
furious at the fact that more of his
close friends have died before he was
able to save them shugan states that
they have to make for harai now once
there everyone the Hermits and the confi
will be aerated having also stolen one
of the special floats the DOI used to
control the Mion shugan blows it and
commands them to carry him and his crew
to harai at once
back over with Gabby and remembering his
past discussion on how if the enemy
manages to redirect its Tower during the
fight it'll be impossible to win Gabby
Maru comes up with the idea of boosting
yia's Dow and bued weapons with his own
to defeat Lord tensen back in the fight
Gabby sees ran going into attack and
prepares to use the same plan of
redirecting his Dow however he and Yara
are completely dumbfounded when a single
punch from The Immortal Kikai State
blows apart the surroundings while also
knocking them back following up ran
absolutely pummels the life out of Yar
and Gabby sending our boy shooting
outside of the building and causing yera
to drop to her knee severely injured
elsewhere sigar and may run throughout
the palace searching for the laboratory
May notices the loud noises coming from
the Doan Temple and becomes worried for
the Allies SAR assures May that Gabby
Mara will be all right since he has a
backup plan but even still the idea of
him following through with that plan
worries her taking things upper level
the kakai monster needs Gabby causing
massive damage before following up and
smashing him into the ground
disappointed in how easily he's being
beaten Gabby takes note of how unlike
the previous kishiki they've seen Ran's
mind is still in control allowing him to
perform his techniques to an even higher
degree despite her past warnings that
when push comes to shove she'll dip out
of the fight usera lets loose her Rob
ability to grab her teammates in an
attempt to try and survive however ran
catches up to them and as she realizes
that if she doesn't Block it's the end
for her Gabby Maru manages to block the
attack just in time having had enough
with this pathetic cockroach of a human
ran throws away any idea of using Gabby
Mario for tan and instead smashes down
breaking his guard and seemingly ending
our man's journey home to top it off
Randon throws Gabby into a pillar
leaving him there to live out his final
moments lying there and remembering all
of the times Gabby had said that his
life takes priority and that he wouldn't
die until he makes it home he again
reiterates that thought as man is not
about to end at all no no no no no
pricking his finger with one of them uh
sneaky old flowers the young man chooses
to sacrifice whatever it takes in order
to be back with the one that he loves
regaining his footing Gabby Mar stands
back up somehow fully healed while
revealing his black eye and the vine
likee patterns that stretch out over the
left side of his face so the reason that
Gabby can actually achieve the state and
not just Bloom into a bunch of flowers
like everyone else who's been stung is
for a very specific reason pretty much
if only a little bit of tan makes it
into the body it has the possibility to
balance out making someone the same as
tenson Gabby Maru who had overheard this
explanation got everyone to accomp him
to mud's pile of bloomed flowers he then
retrieved one of the flower stingers and
plan to receive the same power as chobe
by overcoming the Arif fication but at
that time May objected to doing so just
due to how dangerous the risks are
however Gabby Maru reveals that he was
already aware of how choby managed to
accomplish this fate and is willing to
take these risks what separates chobe
from everyone else is that he has
something to fight for besides himself
so when he's down on his luck he finds
this strength to defy death no matter
what because he's got to get back to his
brother
back with the girls now sigari becomes
shocked after only just learning about
part two of Gab maru's plan but knows
that he is willing to do anything in the
hopes of returning back to his wife over
in the battle Gibby Maru Dodges out of
the way of a few thundering punches and
kicks focusing himself Gabby knows that
he needs to take out ran before the
flowers take over his body even still he
notices that Ran's attacks are starting
to become slower as he consumes more
doubt throughout the battle usara who's
still recovering from the previous
battle tells Gabby that he ain't normal
no matter what happens even if he does
die he doesn't stop pushing forward all
for the hopes of seeing someone that
might not even exist turning and looking
at her Gabby explains that yeah he he
might be crazy but there's only some
places idiots can truly reach someone
who keeps a CO head and thinks logically
just won't survive there's times we've
just got to let loose he compliments
usara as someone who pushes people away
on the off chance that they might make
her an idiot hearing this she becomes
encouraged by Gabby to step forth
despite her wounds and and fight with
your friend and a Dance of Death knowing
that his fire DA has no effect on Ran's
water Gabby Maru tells us Rea that they
need to rely on her Earth Affinity to
defeat him needing to make an opening
for her Gabby starts off by activating
his aesthetic form and using Nino
demonic fire above to throw a burst of
fire at ran the immortal easily
extinguishes the Flames but Gabby slides
in next to him and activates Nino
burning BR sending a fireball rocketing
towards Ran's face slashing his foot
back ran comfortably dissipates the
Flames from around him yet as he does so
yera makes her move and Lees on to him
with her mucus strings thinking that's
good enough to finish him off Gib heads
in and Dodges an attack ran makes to his
Tandon he then uses Nino atic blaze in
an attempt to Scorch the creature but as
he looks down at his work sees a hand
reach through and toss him towards usara
slightly impressed ran says that even
with this shame of theirs it's only a
futile struggle that's prolonging the
inevitable and yet it's beautiful to
behold hearing Gabby talks from smack
Randy prepares himself for the final
belt and tells them to show him
everything they have okay so like I I
hate to do this but I'm not going to hit
you with a 30 seconds of just like
onepage techniques over and over and
over again I just it's fire what's going
on right here right now boys okay but
reigniting the battle the two Shinobi
then unleash their various andu
techniques in combination with each
other ran somehow manages to block every
single ability and pushes them off but
suddenly notices that his body has begun
to crack with the immortal randomly
confused with what's just happened Gabby
Mar reveals that his earlier attack was
meant to over stimulate ran in order to
make him lose his sense of judgment and
timing throughout the fight they were
able to store for enough time with ran
like not knowing what's going on to have
the Kikai State use up all of its D
suddenly R's Kikai form explodes
revealing his weakened and reforming
States giving Gabby Maru and yaria a
perfect opening to attack as the two
rush in yaria starts to feel pain coming
from a wound but tries to Ure it until
they can defeat ran Rising back up in
front of them Gabby Maru sees that ran
had managed to cancel out his form
before complet complet running out of Da
while changing genders ran swipes at
Gabby making it obvious to the ninja
that he's trying to recover his lost da
by cycling between yin and yang he
screams out to use ARA to use her
ability before he recovers and hearing
this ran reaches out clutching down on
gab's shoulder telling him that it's
impossible he knows that the wound she
received earlier is extremely deep and
she she continue with her plan she will
die stopping in her tracks usera agrees
with Ran's statement and throws her
kunai away suddenly spinning around
though the queen cat her weapon and
Sparks up her Dow as it's time to follow
through with what she came here to do
slapping his hands together the immortal
goes on the defense by forming a field
of massive spikes in an attempt to take
usera down before she reaches him
putting out his hand Gabby helps uzia
avoid the spikes by flicking her up into
the air she then jumps down off the
ceiling and as she perceives the
remaining Dow inside Ran's Tandon
annihilates it with the Earth Affinity
infused kunai with the first battle here
coming to an end the immortal being then
starts to crumble away calling out for
his brother during his pitiful demise
what a battle as well that was gangster
and that's only the beginning of like
this entire Arc oh you not you're not
ready this whole Arc is just that after
that after like story after IR OD just
oh my God so good after watching ran
fully turn into a bunch of foliage now
us Rea warns Gabby Maru about the
ocation process eventually taking over
his body still in his eyes he knows that
he had no other options if he wanted to
see his wife again he then suggests that
they C up to sigari and may but Yara
needing to rest tells him to leave
without her before leaving yimo tells
Yara that he'll be waiting for her at
the boat and also once again thanks her
for saving his life when they first
encountered each other on the island but
man this moment always gets my my
freaking tear Ducks rolling after being
alone usara unbuttons her dress and
removes the mucus protecting the wound
she received earlier thinking to herself
she finds it sad that she never showed
her heart to anyone till the end she
remained the same always going at it
alone whether that be life or death nine
that her life was at risk us her
apologized to her deceased sister sa she
really really tried to live for both of
them but this here this here is the end
of the road remembering what she said to
centa when he passed she tells herself
those same words when it hurts go ahead
and think about whatever you want a pet
cat maybe a lover you left behind your
family pass on with that Bey beautiful
Vision usara then faints with a smile on
her face after thinking about sa as her
final thoughts damn and that hurts I'm
sorry I had to blow some stuff there
throughout like that battle and
everything as well yeah you Yuki just
had to calm down I don't know we had to
take a top off and everything but yeah
that obviously that just hurts my soul
and it was some brilliant writing on
Yuki's behalf but I I can't wait to you
know even get further into the story
right here everything ties up and
finishes so well nearby while gabimaru
runs he remembers the plan that then
needed at least five people of their
group to help sail one of the
underground ships and goes to push forth
to the team pool however he stopped
still dropping to the ground as the
effects of the vines spread through his
body beginning to crawl now he remembers
USA's words on how the more he
regenerates the quicker The Vines will
take hold thinking of this and the look
she'd have on her face if she saw him
now he fully collapses before losing
Consciousness moments earlier though
over in the uh you know the cheeky B
Jutsu chamber if you know what I mean
the sanctum now G tiu side and fuchi
majes and toor encounter J far daar and
the Bandit himself chobe seeing his
brother choe puts out his hand and
informs TOA that Lord tenson has agreed
to make them Immortal all he has to do
now is join them hearing this you know
big Gant tells TOA to leave and rejoin
his brother as he doesn't think that
them gaining one more wimp is going to
even out the odds I love how I love how
confident gantai is after saying goodbye
Toma walks up the stairs to finally see
his brother for the first time in days
instantly as the boys see each other
they break out in a gleeful smile and
slash at the two Immortals standing next
to them the creatures try to retaliate
but the boys are able to overcome the
monsters and send them tumbling down the
stairs proudly standing there try tells
his bro that he was slow on the uptake
but can already sense that he's coming
to his own the reason that Tomy knew
what was going on is because they have
their hair done in a specific way with
one you know like side being tied I just
thought that was a cool like aspect down
into the story that you can kind of see
when they're line between each other one
of those is done up but yeah continuing
on with a fat smile on his face he
thanks both gusai and fi for keeping his
brother safe and shows his gratitude by
having them take on dalar while they
take on the other Immortal themselves
genu and fuchi then watching shock as
dalar regenerates from the previous
attack and expresses her disappointment
and troe's betrayal getting the Babe's
attention genit points his blade towards
her and asks if he wanted him to take
away the pain over the other side of the
room the Bros then prepare to fight you
far who after recovering becomes enraged
at the fact that these people attacked
down far so let the rematch begin from I
guess you know beforehand obviously just
like last time jar believes that nothing
is going to change no matter how much
they try desan the brothers lay down a
plethora of strikes that the immortal
manages to fend off dropping down onto
the floor TOA jumps off tr's back and
manages to land an attack on jar however
he actually uses this to catch TOA off
guard and almost hits him with a volley
of energy balls having been pulled to
the side and timed by his brother though
the to them re-engage in a close combat
Jewel slashing at the immortal and
slowly beginning to push him back unable
to stop the force of the brothers from
pushing him back to darts en close and
manages to deal a significant strike to
the monster's face making it realize
that this battle is the complete
opposite to last time just like in the
battle with ran he then angrily decides
to ignore the ritual and take out the
two brothers meanwhile on the floor down
below kite explodes after seeing just
how beautiful daar truly is after taking
a compliment from fui she dashes at Kut
and attacks him with a strong punch
before following up and kicking him in
the head sending him crashing towards a
pillar she jokes that hearing some old
creep gawk over here makes the skin on
her body crawl even though like she's
literally a thousand years old anyway
calling fuchi cute though she offers to
partake in a round of you know B jutu
with without Boy Hey My My Brother fui
however fui cuts her off literally and
declines stating that he's only
interested in examining the constructs
of your biology picking himself back up
as well Big G becomes excited with the
idea of spending some quality time with
Dela wanting to get down to business and
continue with the right of just
consumption Dela then bulks up the boys
D in and slashed her but the immortal
easily takes control over the battle
comfortably dodging all of their strikes
jumping up daar lets loose a wave of Dow
that pushes out from all around her
flinging our guys across the entire room
seeing that they like can't defeat her
by normal means fuchi suggests that they
formulate a strategy to fight against
her ability to use Dow however cantia
screams frustrated with the notion of
Dow as you know like having heard the
word a million times isn't going to
change anything in his eyes plus he
can't even remember half of stuff that
goes into actually using this technique
instead he just wants to have fun in
this battle he runs at the immortal
trying his best to take her out while
she simultaneously mocks him for not
being able to use Dow bro the amount of
times I've SE down this video someone
needs to count it up cuz it's got to be
in the hundreds for sure floating up D
far LS a simple tap on gide's face but
the resulting blast was like it sent
forth a flurry of Dow kicks and punches
that left him on the ground immobilized
dancing around him relentlessly mocking
him she tells G to give up however Big G
just refuses in comments on how she must
have had fun to with humans for the past
1,000 years after hearing the statement
daar loses her smile and expresses that
all of this time they've trained to
achieve immortality they low humans over
and over and over for a thousand years
yes yet still somehow even now they
haven't been able to achieve the perfect
Immortal bodies they've all realized it
it's just that if she stops smiling now
she completely loses your mind or maybe
you know maybe she already has she then
attacks the two with another blast of Da
and disagrees with gantai statement
saying that the whole process isn't fun
at all having properly experienced da
for the first time fie picks himself up
and imagines the breakthroughs he can
make to Medical Science with this
knowledge also feeling a little
different he int stands up excited to
continue the battle initially confused
Dela is astonished by the enemy's
Ambitions that causes them to continue
fighting and senses their toil surging
around them sprinting The Immortal now
daar launches an invisible projectile
towards gensu however he briefly senses
her attack and Dodges shocking The
Immortal who receives a fatal Blow from
him back before they all left the palace
Shion explained to nugi fuchi and gantai
that they were unable to sense da
because they depend too much on their
eyes and battle to use da one must
detach themselves from reality and all
the body to embrace the sensation laying
there at the time and not participating
in learning G explains that he only
believes in things that he can cut for
fi explains that he can only accept
things he can touch and the present day
after managing to land his first attack
on D far G figures that he can use this
weird technique only for the tenson to
instantly retaliate sending him shooting
into a pillar while saying that it was
probably just luck on their behalf fuchi
comes in from behind and manages to push
her away from gen toai as he recovers
however she suddenly appears right in
front of him again and hits him with a
point blank attack before grabbing him
by the neck and Blasting him with
another flurry of energy balls da far
then drops fuchi while she comments on
How Sweet the links he was willing to go
to in order to help his friends were bed
and bruised fuchi says that g side
wasn't his friend yet in that moment he
falls into a memory where he told Big G
they weren't friends but they also
weren't so different from each other
this didn't apply to like just him as
well all of the executioners at the end
of the day are just human and if they
make connections with someone it leads
to genuine feelings just like anyone
else in the short time that they've
spent together he was able able to
observe that the samurai were no
different from the conix everyone is
made of skin and bone with an innate
desire to live from the bottom of his
little heart fi wished that Gite along
with everyone else would return home
safely even if they never spoke again
after that day watching the little man
in front of him just standing there G
senses that he's in massive danger and
like the Mad lad he is ripped out his
own freaking eye back just before when
he dodged that blast he knew that he was
relying on sensation and not sight now
though man's on a completely different
level and can perceive everything around
him through the use of Dow he quickly
grabs fui and Dives out of the way
before another volley of energy balls
could take them out stepping back into
The Fray ganta screams that every attack
she hits him with only increases his
strength and now he's eager to let loose
flashing back into the Past after our
big man gantai was defeated by his
former Master turns out our beg man's
name's actually originally tisun no and
while he was sitting there he wondered
how his master was was able to defeat
him despite being an old knowing
that his pupil wants to learn more his
master explains that the young man has
become greedy with wanting to become
strong and tells him that he must let go
of his strength then let go of it some
more and he'll finally find everything
he wants now thinking on that statement
some more Cana reiterates that he didn't
have a clue what his master meant back
then yes and after a life of mistakes he
finally gets it the more you gain the
harder it is to take a good look at
yourself and the Genai like the G
manages to dodge Del's projectiles and
continuously strikes away at her not
giving her a chance to regenerate
however his attacks are unable to stop
her from Reviving as sadly Gage side
doesn't have the right attribute to
properly take her down not wanting the
battle to like turn into one of
attrition fui knows that only his middle
Dow will be able to stop Dal far from
regenerating and jumps in to graur so
that it subsequently weakens The
Immortal allowing gar to cut the Tandon
with time beginning to slow as Big G
swings his blade towards the foe he asks
himself if he should just trust this New
Sensation remembering his master's words
again to St good and hard at what's left
as in there he'll find everything gantai
closes his eyes and uses a dow andus
strike to precisely cut the immortal
Tandon without harming fui who continued
holding her from
behind meanwhile over with uh the Bandit
himself chob in his own battle prepares
to unleash his transformation on du far
to increase his ability but is stopped
by Toma who believes that they can
defeat him together hearing this The
Immortal F tells them that they are
foolish for thinking they stand a chance
against him and his sister to which chob
explains that no matter where what or
who they are he always crushes his
opponents with his broke covering the
sides becoming enraged at the pathetic
Liv stop just won't end this futile
battle the tenson tells them that the
only thing they have in common is the
fact that they fight bitter and peers
reaching out his right hand another
suddenly reaches through the opening in
the curtain next to him down below it's
shown that the body of daa had begun to
bloom into a treelike state with fruit
growing on each of its Lim likee
branches apologizing to his girl juar
then begins fusing with the other tenson
while stating that together they will
obliterate them so as a child Jah and
daa were told that they were special and
that they were born as two parts of a
whole since then jfa developed the urge
to protect Al far and always came to May
for answers and one specific memory of
his May tells him that it was natural
for him to care for her since they were
Partners the fact that is able to
imagine the pain she feels is perfect
proof of that empathy is both a root of
uneasiness and compassion yet because of
what they are it's inherently harder for
them to understand or internalize these
thoughts sadly though a change soon
started showing itself in rean after he
introduces the five tenson to the hoko
he explained that they were allowed to
use them to replenish their Dow and
assign them their true training art in
an attempt to help them achieve
immortality both of them were in my eyes
disgustingly assigned with botu Jutsu
like like come on man they were pretty
much family at this point and it's kind
of hard to make them do that during one
of like I guess the you training
sessions Dela expresses her pity and
using hoko to replenish the Dow Dua
agrees with her which in turn causes daa
to feel happy that he understands
exactly how she feels after a few
centuries had passed jar becomes
frustrated that the hoko are on the
verge of extension due to the ARB
fication and how Ren and Juku are not
trying to fix the problem gfar which is
like one of the tents and I'm pretty
sure I hadn't mentioned before suggested
using the humans from the mainland as
another source which just like Mudan
says if they don't do exactly that then
it's likely they'll deplete their Dow
over time and also die after remembering
everything daa had gone through duar
becomes angry and slams the table
screaming that everything they've been
through has been for nothing looking up
he suddenly starts to watch as the
tenson faces turn into smiling pits of
Darkness fearing what they've become he
starts the question if they've all gone
mad did the endless training drive them
to Insanity feeling broken inside he
just Ponders the thought that maybe it's
him and daar that are The Crazy Ones
later he walks down to The Floodgate and
sees that Mudan and daar are preparing
to send out aried hoko to lur in humans
to the island Jer asks his girl if she
was okay with doing this as after all
she had in the past St that she didn't
like treating the hoko this way turning
around with a beautiful open smile on
her face she confirms answering with a
yes while asking if this was crazy of
her kneeling down next to her jar put
his arm around Dela and tells her that
she wasn't crazy the humans are like the
hoko lower than the livestock and fit
for their use wondering if he's indeed
crazy at this point he pushes it to the
side instead thinking that it's the
world around them that's gone mad sadly
back in the present where they two
finally becoming one and transforming
into the keshika state they look down
with their own crazy transformation
telling the pathetic humans that they're
nothing more than livestock damn and I
always I always feel so bad for juar
when I first like read through there he
he just wanted his girl to be happy so
he followed her till the end of the
Earth and absolute respect for that man
but you you probably shouldn't have done
that you ruined yourself having fused
together into the destructive embodiment
of love the je met an ear piercing
Screech causing chobe toite and fuchi to
immediately protect their ears chobby
throws his sword to attack but misses as
the monster flies up breaking through
the ceiling of the palace before
ominously floating above them in the
night sky confused fi begins to wonder
how the monster was able to fly with an
unnatural proportion however the way it
captivates thoughts makes him feel as
though it's the embodiment of Love
itself Geno mocks ch's earlier attack
causing our Bandit King to claim that
he'll fight Big G next after defeating
this monster Fuji tells G decide that
they need to administer first aid before
he could fight again however he refuses
and says that his only focus is on
defeating the Immortals looking at his
friend though Fuji watches as G starts
to uncontrollably laugh quickly
realizing what's causing it he says that
one of these spores the monster had
sneakily let Lo managed to sink into can
exercise neck having managed to like not
get hit himself he removes the Bob and
tells the others that they need to get
undercover choby knows that like he
needs to break the stalemate and
prepares to jump up and fight the
monster he transforms and sends forth a
couple vines that allow him to get a
hold of the immortal hanging there he
then morphs his hand into a mess of
battle ax and cuts daar's tandem with
his Vines making him realize that his
mental Affinity dominates one of the
Immortals wood Infinities randomly
splitting itself in half the immortal
then seems a lightning fast barrage
towards chob which connects and manages
to skewer him then picking it up a notch
the creature boosts itself forwards
before using that momentum to send chob
flying across the area and back through
a building having watched this G just
mocks chobe once again while next to him
Tom panics thinking that her brother is
in danger fui calms them down and says
that there is no way they could slash
the monster in one slice so in order to
defeat it they have to work together Big
G and the Bandit King exchanged some
half ass insult about working with each
other yet as soon as the creature tries
to attack them they turn their anger
towards it and deflect the attack don't
mean to like pop in on myself here but I
kind of just realized fui literally
replaced centa as a character with his
entirety except unlike centa he isn't
afraid to inflict injury on other people
oh well he reminds them all here that
the enemy is the Kikai amalgamation in
front of them and that they can focus on
fighting each other later if that's what
they want to do finally stepping forth
with everyone now planning to work
together CH TOA Gant and fuchi all fa to
win with all of the others behind him
chob transforms and blocks the monster's
Vine attack growing some more branches
The Immortal shoots some Stingers
towards the ground but the Bandit throws
himself in front of him to save his bro
from being hurt well stuck dazed
wondering if he can even handle this foe
chobby reviews The Elemental attribute
cycle and knows that because of the
secret technique he has in store he's
the only one who can actually finish the
Immortals youas sprout an extra Vine to
attack chob but suddenly it's sliced in
half by TOA he then grabs fuch's hand in
order to strengthen his metal D and
darts forth with him to slice ala's
Tandon getting in close Tom uses fuch's
momentum and flings him in close enough
so that he's able to land a slice on the
Tandon sensing an opportunity gide jumps
in to deliver his attack but
accidentally slips and falls into the
pool as the monster itself once again
flies up into the sky standing there
choby sees TOA arguing with gai and
remembers how like throughout their
entire life so far he's never seen the
side of him throughout their childhood
he was always someone who could only
ever follow in someone's footsteps but
now he's noticed that his has slowly
started to become his own person
realizing that you know like they Pro
they probably should be focused on the
battle here chy points everyone's
attention up to the newly evolved
monster still floating in the sky
knowing that they can't defeat the
monster without destroying both tendons
simultaneously choby assigns himself
with gai in order to kill du far with
the strategy he has planned while the
leftovers Toma and fui deal with d far
reverting back to his simpo mate he asks
his brother what you should do now chy
though simply punches him in the head
demanding that he make his own decisions
now since he has faith in his brother's
abilities ktia isn't exactly chill about
like teaming up with chob and is
initially reluctant to listen to his
orders but after the Bandit compliments
his strength man gets straight
manipulated into fighting with him
chobby looks over towards the monster
and notes that they are similar for the
fact that both Duos are willing to
protect their own in his eyes though toy
has grown to the point where he no
longer needs protection and because of
that states that he will rip them both
apart so that they can pass on together
super super nice of you CH to let them
die and go to the afterlife together and
all anyway skipping Back to Before the
battle began we see that re while
sitting up the ritual of right
consumption told chobe that his brother
bear an ill Omen back in the present
time chobe TOA Gite and fuchi all
charged towards the Kikai monster while
constantly feeding off a barrage of
vines turning to the small man gai tells
him to give him some cover as he dies
forth in an attempt to cut it down
seeing him get hit directly though by
modal Vines it causes fi to think that
the The Swordsman has almost reached his
limit the monster launches the spores
towards fuchi but having seen their
attack in time it's protected by TOA who
throws his own body in front of it
needing to step out of like the days
that he caught himself in Thomas shakes
him around and explains that his Dow is
vital in their plan of winning jumping
up into the sky Troy notices that
everyone is on their last legs but this
is it they won't have another chance to
win claiming that he's ready now the big
man himself manages to sneak under the
monster through the water before popping
up and sending a massive slash directly
up through the immortal cutting it in
half and leaving the others with a
perfect opportunity to take it down fui
Toma and chob then coming from both
sides swinging their attacks towards the
Immortals jar and dala try to reconnect
the Kikai form but just before they were
able to do so our team successfully
destroys the Tandon of both Immortals
screaming for her partner Dela emerges
from the pool weakened but is quickly
stopped and held in the arms by fui who
tells her just to stop as these are her
final moments to far then also climbs
out of the water extremely weakened and
tries to attack chob since his da won't
be able to hinder them chob punches
himself in the gut and removes two
bottles of water da that he originally
planned to use against Gabby Maru he
then pours the liquid on du far which
almost acts like an acid to stop him
from regenerating basking in Victory
chobe just tells the creature that he
should never have picked a fight with
the other brothers randomly G just like
comes in and finishes the job causing
choby to think that the man was taking
pity on the creature when in all reality
man just wanted up the KD and now big
brut's head though his thoughts are
slightly different while remembering
daar's words from their last battle he
kneels down and places a page from
dala's body next to Jah thanking her for
the fun they had throughout this fight
as he slowly dies and tears appear in
his eyes Jer apologizes to his girl for
not being able to protect her now
appearing as children in a different
world which obviously like represents
the most sane and happiest time probably
in both of their lives I'd imagine
before all of the weirded these started
happening either way the two of them
then embrac each other in the afterlife
with da far saying that she was glad he
was her partner back in reality and with
the battle having been won virt wonders
how the others are currently fearing
then once again going back to a bit of
an earlier time sigar and may encounter
goof far who says that he won't attack
them if they don't move from where they
are but also add that he will absolutely
crush them if they even take one step
forward after arriving May pointed out
that this was the ran Temple yet ran
wasn't here here so she just casually
asked her fellow Immortal where they
could have gone gofar says that Ren had
left not too long ago and he was given
the task to guard the ritual Circle
goofa explains that the items in front
of him are meant to tell the fortune and
current status of the humans fighting
against the other tensin which is how he
knew that her and may were on the way
here sari then reaches for a sword
causing goofa to admit their doubt
towards sigari in a similar manner to
someone overwhelming a person with the
aura which causes Sig to collapse from
the pressure impressed with the fact
that she can still move though Goa tells
her that if she does continue to resist
he will crush her sigiri explains that
she does not wish to fight and instead
places her sword on the ground while
apologizing for invading their Island
along with their behavior since then
with that said though she finds a
pathetic how he tries to stop her when
all along they were purposely luring in
people to the island this conflict is
merely an extension of what they swed
and sadly with how things are now it's
only going to result in more losses in
an attempt to prevent this though Ziri
offers a declaration of peace between
both sides they will leave and the
Immortals will allow it to happen
without delay hearing this goofa drops
the holdy head over sigiri and allows
you to move once more however he warns
them that even if they returned back to
Wago it would be pointless want you to
know what they meant by this the imortal
explains to the tooth through an
illusion created by D that Ran's true
plan is to depart her ey on his ship and
release the paradise butterflies on the
mainland turning every human into what
on who flowers then once all of the
humans had turned they would form
together into one giant Banco called The
Divine Beast Banco from that Ren can
finally produce the much sought after
perfected tan hearing this shakes out
girls to her core as finally for the
first time in the series someone of
normal sanity found out the truth about
Ran's manal plan by the way Wago I
probably said that completely wrong is
the ancient Chinese name for Japan
pronounced wuko and Japanese funnily
enough the name actually came about in
the 3rd century and it literally meant
dwarf country later in the 7th Century
though and to amend their short shaming
the Japanese people changed the Kani up
to mean peace and Harmony saryi asks SCA
why why would they all go to these links
what could possibly be motivating them
he says that they as in him and the
other tenson feel nothing for humans and
that they are materials for them to use
in order to make an electure hearing
this change in your old friend May
objects to the statement saying that Jo
fuku original research was for the good
of mankind and using lives isn't yet and
goar's they've all changed ever since
one specific day in which they all
tested a specific method and managed to
lure in the first group of humans to the
island on that day they learned just how
beautiful and delicious humans truly are
it was more than they ever expected
humans outside of herai were weak frail
things yet they possessed far more
Exquisite material the reason for this
is because humans are beings full of
doubt and indecision they waver between
the extremes which itself is the essence
of Dow love and hate life and death due
to the tenson being born as higher
beings they simply cannot fether those
aspects of D so to gofar it's frankly
Unthinkable that they would look for a
more suitable form of immortality Elixir
at this point with the Elixir completed
by Ren gfar also says that to come to an
understanding would be meaningless and
all they can do now is try and steal
more lives from each other looking over
his shoulder the dude then points out
that as they speak shon's Talisman is
beginning to burn up symbolizing that in
his battle he's nearing the end of his
road over in his fight with zujin SH
manages to cut the immortal's body 215
times looking at the thing in front of
him he comes to a quick conclusion that
his plan is working the creature is
beginning to slow its regeneration speed
walking up to it once more Shon
absolutely exhausted continues to attack
slicing the thing in half again then
after getting right above the creature
zujan quickly Springs back and manages
to get some distance between them and an
attempt to regenerate naruga goes to
attack herself but Shon holds her back
while explaining that the monster itself
is also just as
terrified and unable to take them out Z
Jin just asks what in the world Shon is
as he definitely isn't normal
remembering the the moment where
everything first changed for Shion he
grits his teeth and tells the F that
those who steal the lies of others
willingly could never understand while
those who have been stolen from will
never forget looking like an actual
80-year-old bag of bones now Zu Jin
defends themselves by attacking the je
with the remains of all of the other
bodies that had been generated
throughout the battle however Shion sees
through his opponent's Ro and slices the
down infused bodies to bits he then
jumps forth using the infamous IU hares
but fails to land a hit on the fleeing
Immortal sujun initially thinks Shion
misjudged the distance between them but
the reality of his attack was revealed
when the Blind King acting like he has
perfect 2020 Vision fakes a trip and
grabs the tip of his sword from the
ground and throws it towards Zan's
Tandon getting up from his injury zujan
sees that Shon himself is just as
exhausted from using too much of his Dow
and in that moment takes the opportunity
to attack nugo runs towards Shon to
system but as per usual she is told to
stay back as he doesn't want to put her
in danger sadly zujin uses this moment
to her advantage and seemingly crushes
Shon with the Dow bodies laughing out
loud thinking that she'd managed to take
down one of her opponents zujin is
promptly Gob smacked as they watch Shon
slice his way out of the body coffin and
utter shock at shon's determination
zujan asks why why would he shave away
at his own life force and go so far to
avent's Fallen comrade standing there
utterly broken over everything that has
happened on this island Shon explains
that he hasn't had a single chance to
feel grief or mourn at times he even
finds it difficult to rage still no
matter what he states that until he
managed to rid the Earth of these
pathetic creatures the grief despair
nothing will return to him he wonders
how many more hundreds of cuts it'll
take until he can finally put his
student and best friend to rest
literally just in fear for their life at
this point the creature makes a lastage
effort to heal itself by slipping
backwards into the water coming back up
it's Shan that somehow in just a matter
of moment Zen was able to heal
themselves by taking a leaf out of gfa's
book so unlike all of the others or like
the other tens and hoop and botu Jutsu
gar doesn't he finds it disgusting
instead he maintains a middle ground
between both yin and yang Zu Jin then
tries something new on the side of the
tenson and begins to partially transform
their body into the kesai form standing
there and looking just super freaking
clean now like like the foot actually
goes way too hard on the immortal right
here she taunts Shion asking if it was
still possible for him to land all of
those carts just like with tinza zujin
states that it is accustomed to their
tricks and it's fairly evident as the
three began their fight once more that
Shon and aruga are only barely able to
hold on against the partial kesai form
tricks though this statement said by
zujan it's probably one of the saddest
notes within one of our favorite
characters as it's literally who Shion
is a trickster he couldn't care what
this pathetic amalgamation of leaves
thought his mother was the one who gave
him these scars he was always born blind
but because he was also born as a
traveling performer it was a necess to
trick people into giving them some
measly donations to live over time he
came to be known as the Divine boy who
could see through anyone's swordsmanship
without even seeing moving forth
throughout his life Sharon remembers how
one day it led him to the tooa which is
actually like a real life Guild for
blind men to join and the King yo was
the highest ranking member of their org
it lasted from The 14th Century all the
way through to 1871 and there was also a
female section called the Goa the
highest ranking member which was the
Grand kyogo was said to have the
authority equal to a Dio once that Sig
Keo and hell's Paradise heard of shion's
abilities it was through him that he
managed to end up as a student of the
umada clan to not Su his mother's honor
Shion went along with the false
backstory that he was the illegitimate
child of a famous swordsman and kept his
real past life a secret from the Yamada
Clan even still this fact shames him to
his core after becoming a fully growing
adult and hearing tends to speak his
mind to shugan about how he should see
him for what he is now along with
watching him gradually gain acceptance
the spider's past Shan becom was
inspired to be like a student just like
how he grew into the man he was back in
the present Shon blocks one of Zan's
attacks and states that no matter what
if it's just this one it will die by his
hand he will gladly give his life for
that cause quickly leaning back he
Dodges Zan's lightning Dow attack and he
them gloating about how he does not send
a chance against their power Shon
angrily silences zujan before they could
finish their sentence and declares that
he will defeat them that form is merely
a cheap trick that prioritizes
performance over dealing destructive
blows he tells naruga to stay back as he
will end this himself before rushing in
and detaching Zan's left hand then in
the same moment plunges his snapped
Katana deep into her Tandon remembering
the Survivor strategy meeting about how
they need to Target Lord Ton's plant
like ovales to deal the finishing blow
Shon disembodies Zen with his blade then
sing above presses his sword down on the
tentant ovil to end the battle while
doing so Shion is suddenly assaulted by
the remains of zujan sending a bunch of
the vines shooting into his body they
explains that they need to pull the
blade out otherwise the AIA will
continue attack the one who holds the
blade down however Shi continues to
press down on her sword knowing that if
they both die then he will still be
victorious in the end nugo worries that
if Shon continues with holding down the
sword then he will die however Shon
tells you to stay back he expresses the
pain he found as he left T behind to
fight for their lives and pleads to nuga
to leave him behind as he takes
responsibility for his past actions he
finds it horrid that he made the correct
choice to flee in the past and now all
he can do is this his eyes don't sh
tears so he's unable bble to show how
much he truly cared nugo tries to
intervene and talk to him but sheon just
demands that she flees causing her to
turn and run away as tears begin to fall
from her face she knows exactly what her
Sensei is going through now as she's
been in the exact same shoes she could
never forgive herself instead she
thought that she was the reason everyone
in her life died yet after meeting tenza
seeing his actions and hearing him say
that he was unable to accept her reason
for wanting to die it causes her to stop
and look at the blade in front of her
beginning to walk now she then sees a
vision of tenza bending down in front of
her before standing up and gifting nuga
back her blade nuga tries to explain her
situation but before she can even
verbalize what's going on tend to hold
out her Blade with one hand and says
that if that's the case then there's
only one thing to do encouraged by her
man nuga grabs the blade and boosts it
back towards the palace inside of the
building Shon is fully covered with a
Vines and sadly starting to feel his
life being eaten away this alone to him
confirms that just like him the mortal
is also slowly beginning to fade away
however nuga suddenly flies through
tackling Shion and freeing him from the
death drip that he was in after tearing
away the remaining Vine nugo be hugs her
sensei in an attempt to restore his Dow
sitting there absolutely exhausted now
nugo points out that the immortal is
slowly regenerating but at this speed it
will most likely take a whole day to
recover Shon believes that they should
take it out now since it's nice and easy
but nuga objects and tells him that
that's exactly why they've got to leave
if anyone even Tri to get close to the
creature when it's in that state then
the vines will immediately skew anyone
so instead they should leave and get to
the others Shion he he just can't seem
to bring himself to this thow he finds
it impossible to leave but that specific
creature still sucks in ear finally nugo
tells him that that isn't it he's wrong
T never died with pain or regret she saw
it with her own eyes he was smiling
because he knew that the people he loved
were able to escape it was the smile of
someone who was proud in their final
moment but also an air of sadness she
doesn't think that he regretted a thing
about his final moments walking up to
him nuga hugs Shon and asks that instead
of holding revenge in his heart he tell
her all about the man that he used to be
after Shon looks towards the blade EMB
bedded in Zin he notices the reflection
of tza beside him and nugi finally
feeling somewhat at peace now Shion
thanks nugi for reasoning with him and
agrees to leave back over at the ritual
Circle two bottles suddenly shatter one
in another slowly begins to crack this
here obviously indicates that instead of
the criminals or executioners the
members of the Lord tenson have been
defeated pretty much simultaneously
noticing that the talismans remained
intact after the battle concluded saryi
believes that Gabby Maru and the others
are still alive with the ritual pretty
much over goof far gets up and prepares
to report to rein confused scary
questions goof far why they weren't
willing to avenge their comrades pretty
much this is just due to like the fact
that these tenson supposedly carry no
emotion or bonds with one another
instead their passings were merely a
larger part of their training in the way
of Yin and Yang goofa even reminds May
that the same wi for her the ttin and
are being that only seek the way no
bonds or emotion what they've seen from
her is only an Act created by a Lost
Child confused as to why she would even
reveal herself after leaving goar
inquires as to why she came back
although may still hardly able to
verbalize herself just answers that she
finally understands what life means
turning back guar just sadly responds
that he does indeed Envy her honestly
goofa along with I think it was daa were
really the only other two tenson to see
kind of how messed up their ways had
become maybe too far A little bit there
obviously May understands as well hence
like why she left I just think the
reason the other two didn't is because
they do truly have emotions and never
wanted to break away from what they come
to know either way everyone is suddenly
taken off guard as the palace then
begins to violently shake with goofa
saying that the situation has taken a
turn for the worst outside to reveal
that the maniacal Maniac the order 66
Merchant rank two Yamada aimon Shan
riding the top his Mion smashes through
the wall that made up her eyes
surroundings back over with the larger
Squad and after having given gantetsu an
eye patch to help protect his left eye
fui TOA and Big G have a comedic
discussion about its positioning chob
hilariously interrupts the conversation
calling them utter fools for weing away
time and quickly brings their focus back
to the main issue at hand he reveals to
them all Ran's plan of turning every
human in Japan into t synchronizing them
all with the monster called Bano he also
remembers how ran told him that he was
confident that the other tenson wouldn't
die but also stated that if they did
happen to die then it would not matter
to him try listens to gant's complaints
about how he finds the situation far too
complicated and also agrees with fuchi
suggestion on his eye patch much to the
assignment's happiness TOA getting a
little curious as to what his brother's
cutting up to with ATT tension inquires
but is utterly shocked after chobi
reveals that he engaged in botu Jutsu
and was constantly experienced on on
knowing that they must stop R and
retrieve his ship from The Floodgate to
escape themselves fuchi asks chobe if he
is willing to LA with them before he
could give them an answer though the
four suddenly feel the room begin to
tremble meanwhile Nuka helped sh up so
that the two can walk together while
he's still injured Shon ensures naruga
that even if things don't go as they
planned and they end up in the worst
possible scenario then he will ensure
her that she's still able to survive and
return home Ido though would not be
their destination instead they will roam
the country together in the current time
period there are still a fear few
Mountain Clans that remain hidden maybe
living life that way will suit them both
he gets down on his knees and promises
that so long as life Burns in his eyes
he'll be her protector until that day
comes the two then you know get into a
good old comedic discussion about
another one of shon's blind metaphors
there when they both suddenly feel the
palace begin to start shaking after the
Tremor settled down Shion is unable to
detect what caused it all around them
though appearing from the darkness e
ninja masks break through from the
Shadows with one in front of the duo
telling them that they have been ordered
by shugan to eliminate all convicts and
any assignment who have sided with them
at the same time gyai and the other
three there along with the currently
unconscious Gabby Maru are surrounded by
various ninja instantly the ninja around
Gabby lash out in an attempt to take him
out however gabimaru wakes up and in one
perfect motion takes out all four
enemies after looking and realizing that
it was Ean ninjas he's just merked G
produced that the next Gabby Maru is
here and what does uh what does Gabby
mean by that I'd love to know you guys
in inial thoughts down in the comment
section below so and a flashback during
the first night they camped out on the
island at shown that sigari was
constantly told by Gabby Maro that she
was feeling sleepy even though she
denied it she recommends though that he
sleeps after the battles his forward but
is quickly told that people like him and
iwa able to go for at least 10 days
without sleep with this in mind she
asked as to why Gabby Maru was even
worried about people coming after him
Gabby Maru tells sigiri that he has no
doubt that they'll track him down and
find him hearing him sigiri becomes
confused by the as to like why would
they go out of their way for just one
stray ninja so this is like as Gabby M
reveals here for one simple fact The
conation Gabby Maru the hollow is a code
name meant to carry and pass down
through I gur's strongest Shinobi saying
Gabby Maru like 12 times in one sentence
here it's going to make a brain explode
but uh either way well when the chief
found Gabby with his merched parents
turns out that the dude they next to him
was the previous Gabby Maru he wasn't
telling Al Gabby to necessarily behold
weakness but instead the current Gabby
marrow of that time who I'm guessing was
the one who probably merked gab's
parents otherwise how did the dude like
gain that position unless gab's parents
were just like random ninja and trying
to leave the village and it's just me
who's read way too much into the scene
here but moving forward either way back
when Santa was alive and during the time
USA and him ran off to evade the Flames
she actually explains this possibility
to the weeb king she went over the
horrific tale of Gabby Maru the hollow
and how the name alone was the only
thing she knew was real she's almost
certain she heard tales about how even
if Gabby Mara was slain he still somehow
shows back up and WS Havoc even more
than before decades pass but this name
never ages or dies it's as if it's a
living breathing representation of
Terror seemingly falling into a
flashback of gab's own memories it shows
the EV C Chief telling the potential
young Gabby candidates on how we will
pick from one of them to become the next
inheritor during the training the chief
sets his sights high on the young Gabby
Maru like the one that we know for his
impressive skills and lack of emotions
so Gabby uh you would be kind of
different I guess you could say this
dumb kid once threw a rock at his head
and um well yeah you can you guys can
see what happened here Gabby didn't have
a gabby doesn't know what the middle
ground is after finding out what
happened the chief asks the previous
Gabby Maro on the one who possibly
committed this act and it's assumed that
Al Gabby kind of you know kind of popped
off here as the early days brutalization
continued throughout the clan the chief
takes note on how each of the victim
separated the young gabim Maru from the
weak so that now only those who are
like-minded equals remain later on one
of these Shinobi comes up to Gabby Maru
after becoming impressed that he carried
out A Dangerous Mission with admires and
PE at envy him along with having true
Talent the chief decides that Gabby Maru
will be the next Shinobi to inherit the
Alias the chief tells Gabby Maru that he
has chosen him as a next successor and
must complete a ceremony where he has to
take out the current Gabby Maru and a
fight to the death I'm assuming this is
with absolute ease that our boy WS here
as we don't even see what happens the
previous Gabby Mar just got completely
offscreen by our boy in a matter of
moments over the enjoyed with just like
how broken Gabby Maru is the chief
screams into life he will become
History's Strongest Gabby Maru the
hollow back in the present now Chan
orders the ninja to execute any life
form they come across except the other
surviving Yamada then just as abruptly
leaves with asuzu and Karu while nearby
J decides to guard the Ria when in all
actuality man's just trying to do the
least work possible looking up to the
ninja next to him ja says that he knows
this whole obey the shogunate concept is
just a front used to hide their own
agenda on the mission thinking back the
specific ninja remembers the chief's
orders to kill Gabby Maru in order to
become the next Gabby Maru the hollow
themselves standing up she tells J that
they share the same goal since at the
end of the day their objective is to
kill everyone else on the island however
the N tells themselves that the only
thing that was more important than
actually taking out Gabby was to bring
him back looking up with a maniacal
expression on the face the ninja just
remembers that after all she was the one
who slaughtered everyone in his way and
took out those who were in VI of his
success after confronting her the ninja
admits to this she explains that they've
been supporting him all along from the
shadows and confess their feelings to
him that they love him that they'll be
happy to die by his hands or kill him
Yuki just came out the bag with like a
maxed out clingy ex-girlfriend right
here holy that's like the
personification of actual crazy crazy
also on another note those um masks and
ninja wear resemble the ones used in no
theater no drama is the oldest surviving
form of Japanese theater it combines
music dance and acting to communicate
Buddhist themes the tradition began
throughout like the morari period with
around 60 masks that originally had like
religious connotations funnily enough
and you all probably saw this coming
Gabby's crazy girl we just met was the
mask that represents a jealous female
demon back in the depths of her ey
inside of the floodgates ran senses the
Tremors coming from outside and is also
reported to by goof far that the other
remaining tenson have been killed the r
of just conception has failed and
extremely skilled human reinforcements
have arrived with no other choice R
stages a Counterattack by sending the
Doshi out for battle while keeping a
minimum number with him as protection as
they Rush towards the battlefield ran
reiterates that This Is War the losses
and outcome of this battle matter not
before long everything should return to
how it once was above ground now we see
everyone including the DOI riding their
STS beginning to throw hands seen as how
they can't manage to defeat every single
fod opponent gai fui to and chbe decide
to instead make a run for it over in
another battle Shon procures himself a
sword from one of the ninja and is told
by nuga to follow her to safety while
sprinting away themselves gde lets them
all know that he knows a thing or two
about experiencing War these fights
they're currently in go Way Beyond just
putting strength against strength and
War living and dying is complete luck
there's no fun about the battles and no
Pride at all to be won It's Only Hell on
Earth and the people who survive are
only those that run those who have Pawn
to do their bidding and the complete mad
men with God on their side over with one
of these Mad Men as the Doshi Army
charged towards him shugan remembers
Isen and is driven to cut down the
entire freaking Army and only a few
deadly swings after seeing Shan's battle
skills Karu asked him if he had some
experience with war however he's quickly
told by him that this battle is in war
it's an execution to purge the scum who
dared to defy The shogun's Honorable
blade testers he then commands his two
underlings to cut off the enemy's Escape
Route and slaughter them all at The
Floodgate R encounters the so so called
wannabe Gabby Maru and it's surprised
that he couldn't detect their prisons at
all gab's stalker here says that they
have no desire to fight with ran and is
sure that if they just waited here Gabby
Maru himself might come to the
floodgates getting curious to himself
and while asking if this person happens
to be from the mainland ran also
commands the Doshi to take them out
however they seeking gby Mar here just
like Gabby did with sigiri asks if
they'd like to see some Ninjutsu before
suddenly using NPO athetic Blaze to
incinerate the Doshi with the area
around them beginning to catch fire the
ninja orders its clansmen to burn all of
the ships except for one while they
themselves take on Rein back inside of
the um good old Ron sanctum sigari and
may are confronted by the Doshi and EA
ninja sigari sees the ninja charging
towards her and instantly defends
herself by sensing the da to track the
flow of their movements while fighting
off everyone she notices that the DOI
don't track May while the Shinobi do not
attack her because of her position in
the clan believing that it's most likely
due to the specific orders each side was
given she comes to the conclusion that
the key to winning lies in exploiting
this weird te the two Doshi then come
charging into attack however hey it's
time they are randomly pulled away from
the tube by a random sticky string of
course it's no one other than this
sneaky Kuni herself use a Rea seeing
that uh seeing that her friend is still
somehow alive after her previous Bel she
runs in and gives her a hug pretty much
like we all got hard baited on thinking
that uh our girl passed away there when
in all reality she just actually had to
kind of take a nap but if you kind of
think about it in the perspective that
when you usually get injured and need to
go to sleep you usually think your
body's shutting down and dying so it
makes sense that she probably thought it
was the end of the road for her but
turning out that after a nap she's back
then noticing one random small ninja yua
finishes off a small group of them and
explains to saryi that before messing up
with them she checked out the
surrounding area the situation is
probably the worst they could be in
right now as they are seemingly cornered
by all four battles that are happening
around them since the Shinobi were hired
by the Shogun zi thinks that they could
persuade them to fight like together
with them however usera tells her that
it just wasn't possible since they are
out to kill all of the criminals and
reminds sary that their task in coming
here has not changed scary knows this
and points out that the electure is most
likely at The Floodgate as well see to
Gary for the first time since arriving
on the island asuzu becomes relieved but
is shocked to see her standing next to
the criminal USA of kesu scir tries to
explain to her that like she and the
other executioners had no other choice
but to team up with the criminals given
this situation she tells her that many
lives were stolen by this woman's hand
so think of her victims do not dishonor
them as usera is truly a Villain at the
same time Karu confronts Shion and nuga
will J confronts chob and TOA asuzu
explains in combination with the others
that each criminal and Immortal creature
are the enemies and anyone who's willing
to help them even the assignment are
also seen as an enemy now with that said
asuzu asked sigari to move away from
Yara and come join your side meanwhile
kite and fuchi who had like temporarily
separated themselves from the other
Brothers run off in an attempt to find
an Escape Route catching their attention
though and slowly appearing through the
Shadows behind them it turns out to be
no one other than shugan looking rised
out of his freaking mind like like the f
is actually Darth mpck anyway standing
there in front of them G notices just
how menacing this dud is realizing that
fui is untied his criminals hands jukan
then angrily demands that he give him a
proper reason as to why wondering what's
up with this like uptight weirdo Gant
tiu side tries doing a similar thing
like he did with Gabby Maru back in uh
one of the earlier ARS to F out how his
opponent might fight however Shan sees
through intentions and silences him
telling inide that he only wishes to
speak with fui G just stands there
dumbfounded as to like who shugan is
since unlike the other opponents he has
faced he is unable to get an exact read
on what he's packing shugan who's still
not over the first question he asked
yells out to Fuji to explain the reason
why his criminals hands are un tied like
we all know from everything that's
happened so far in the island fui tries
telling him that they had no other
choice but to Ally themselves with the
criminals due to their extreme
circumstances Jan hears this reason but
like as he's here now tells him that he
no longer has to be by GES side and can
be HD him instead he pleads with fuchi
to not throw away all of the memories
they have together all of the times they
spoke about anatomy and the paths that
he has chosen in life sadden with the
reality of the situation fui says that
he also cherishes the times he spent
together learning about life through his
experimentations but also says that
before coming to the island he didn't
understand the value of life no not
until the death of his close friend he
instead draws his sword and apologizes
for disappointing him but what they need
to do now is focus on escaping they can
worry about everything else later after
drawing out a sword suan is shocked he
said that fuchi use the subba as GED to
eye patch to him and most other Samurai
like we've been over before as well the
blade is a Warrior's Soul the Yamada
Soul Furious he screams that if he's
misplaced his soul then he'll be forced
to but before can even finish his
sentence man is cut off by the Big G who
himself became dissatisfied at the fact
that Shan just assumed he could murk him
with ease instantly the two Clash swords
and while stuck in a blade tussle toay
knows that he's fine and should be able
to throw him around with the size
Advantage when the tussle like he
thought gai manages to knock shugan off
his feet however as he thinks he can
take advantage of the scenario notices
that the samurai had legitimately
transformed into someone else having
gained some distance Big G instantly
closes his in and goes to strike down on
him but Shan easily blocks G his next
attack and takes the time to tell him
about the fond memories he had helping y
Simon Genji with his calligraphy as he
starts to describe Genji Shan's strength
increases and causes gyde to see him as
an image of Genji now shugan now with
his massive strength buff deflects G his
attack and challenges him with all of
the fallen and even like some of the
like alive y beginning to appear as
Spirits behind suan Stakes that will not
be him who delivers the final blow but
the blades of all Yamada as Simon as the
belt begins shugan uses Genji's hel
splitter technique to completely off
balance gusai who was unable to counter
before the samurai disarms him having
lost his sword and with no other option
left G side throws at punch but shugan
once again avoids the attack by
imitating K's ability with the big guy
beginning to fall over shugan explains
the kind of man that Kesha was though we
RAR asserted himself into conversation
he was a genius when it came to for
scene and Warden off attacks Shon
suddenly uses a combination of both K's
Harvest shower and Genji's dest in an
attempt to mortally wound the criminal
dropping to his knees G say that he wish
he got to play some more but now he
slowly starting to fade not taking them
entirely seriously Shon screams that
Mercy isn't meant for the likes of
criminals no this this is an execution
having swung the blade down at top Big G
shugan is left mortified to find that no
one other than fui had somehow managed
to block the strike Fuji tries
explaining that crime and evil are the
same G is undoubtedly a criminal but by
no means is he evil he tells him that
he's just over this whole thing he
doesn't want anyone else to pass on even
if it means turning his back on the laws
of this era having heard these words
Shan says that fui hasn't changed since
the first time they met and yeah I I'd
love to go over what they did here just
you know best of buds you know back in
these old days doing like little little
experimentations on people and stuff but
you know YouTube these days anyways as
we bang it back to reality Shan suddenly
slashes fi before he even the chance to
react with tears beginning to fall from
his face shugan just remarks that he was
a ablim man till the end someone who
only ever put those in front of himself
elsewhere inside of the ran Temple asuzu
explains to Zira that she has faith in
shugan because he upholds order he
protects those who abide by the law and
punishes those who go against them the
level of crime does not matter in his
eyes it's the standard itself itself
that needs to be upheld at the same time
chobe and TOA surrender Shon lays down
his weapon and Gabby Maru is approached
by two ninja with faces resembling I
gur's Chief and his wife back with the
Fallen fuchi though G thinks that it's
mental shugan would ever go that far for
the sake of order absolutely raging out
at this point shugan screams that no
this isn't crazy what he witnessed was
pure determination from which there is
no return and for that reason he
condemns toaya a villain before
seemingly finishing it all so elswhere
at the floodgates and manipulating the
Flames themselves ran controls the
second gab maru's fight and Jitsu and
uses it against the surrounding ninja
taking out a bunch of them before they
even got a chance to react dodging out
of the blast to herself the female Gabby
throws a kunite ran which connects
directly with the immortal's face but
after it recovers immediately ceas and
not only can the B use sorcery but also
regenerate thinking back to what Gabby
Maru said to her earlier in life about
her no matter what the situation an
enemy is to a physical being if it has a
conscious mind then a strategy can be
formed with that in mind the seeking gab
Maru places out her hands onto the
shoulder of some and commands them to
use the last of their lives to set the
ships Ablaze not wanting the ships to
burn up otherwise all the butterflies
and the whole plan Goes Up in Flames R
tries to manipulate Dow in an attempt to
crush the ninjas bought in the ship
unable to stop everyone and see just how
tense ran had become the hi gab marrow
calls out that she had found her love to
her it's obvious that she'd been holding
back as to not damage the surroundings
but in reality it's only when the ships
get damaged that cause ran true pain
pondering if it's a possible love the
ninja states that at times it can be a
Troublesome thing and at others a
strength but in this fight here it is
indeed The Immortals weakness all of the
surrounding ninja which seemingly like
keep appearing from cracks send aora of
shuriken towards the creature ran then
easily blocks off the basic attack but
is shocked to see that the elixir of
life has been taken from her by the
second gabimaru who without a second
thought then tosses it to another ninja
and commands them to get it outside as
rean tries to stop them the second
gabimaru activates Nino pyro bridge to
launch a torrent of fire that completely
engulfs the immortal R doesn't drop the
concentration over which Ninja has the
Elixir though and destroys them with a
shot of D however it soon comes to their
attention that one of the items they
were carrying was the squad Leader's
mask and the other with the Elixir had
managed to escape the female giby knows
that she stands no chance of winning
when it comes to strength but this is
war when someone is in an unfavorable
condition they must exploit the enemy's
point of view to create chaos that way
any outcome is possible as in war it
isn't the strong who Prevail it's the
wicked and twisted after bringing the
Elixir outside the shobi calls out a
massive seashell and signals the team
that it has been acquired Isuzu hears
the signal indicating to her that the
mission is now complete USA who's like
on the ground in front of her unable to
deal massive damage due to like still
needing to heal attempts to fight asuzu
without her full power seeing the
sliming string coming towards her Isuzu
easily counters by kicking Rubble up
from the ground below scary quickly DTS
in and gets rehar out of the way while
asking her fellow executioner to calm
down asua is not a villain asly enraged
by the fact that a just won't listen
Isuzu responds by telling her that even
though they capture the electure she
will not stand to see any of the
criminals alive before they leave going
into a small flashback it shows that
even though Isuzu didn't exactly have a
bond with everyone inside of the dojo
she felt a connection with sigari the
first time they met since they were
females in the Yamada Clan so now to see
her teamed up with an enemy on the
island it makes her enraged meanwhile
Gabby Maro watches as the toobi kokubo
and kokubo use transformation Jutsu to
reform their faces into the W's Chief
and his wife speaking as the chief he
tells gaburo that he's been expelled
from the clan No Grave shall bear his
name as to leave the village means that
you no longer exist in reality speaking
of reality same goes for his wife
apparently she is only an illusion
created as a shame to help imprison his
heart inside of the clan however it's
sadly backfired in this case Finly
enough Gabby Maru compliments the two
Ninja on their Adept use of like
transformation juu and hearing him do so
makes the big guy shutle with joy over
the fact that Gabby Maru would say so so
hearing the two talk to him about the
next Gabby maro's instructions our boy
easily figures that the next Gabby Maru
must be sha which the two confirmed
along with this they also updated the
previous Commander that kumuk along with
the others had perished on The Voyage to
the island they also insisted on telling
Gabby Maru that shija was obviously the
person who merked all of the other
candidates and that in their eyes they
still view him as the true Gabby Maru
finally I can let my brain rest now and
just refer to the female Gabby as Shi
now holy like the idea that her name
wasn't mentioned after this point just
blew my mind when I first went through
and ReRe this Arc anyway after they also
hear the massive trumpet go off the guys
that K know that it informs him that
they've actually acquire the elixe of
life then moving on to like the issue at
hand kokubo humbly asks gabaro to end
his life as this way the chief will
remove the kill order on him and if he
wants he can make it Painless by liing
in Ninja's toxic saliva garu obviously
found this method of their to be
completely utterly gross but as big by
kbo to reconsider since in their hearts
they're all allies pointing out to them
that they hadn't entered his throne
hands range Gabby Praises them for
following the basic ninja principles
despite this Gabby Mar flexes his blood
lust and causes them to stumble
backwards somewhat annoyed kukuo asked
if he was still willing to defy the
chief and hearing that Gabby Maru plan
to escape this place kokubo tells him
that even if he does make it back to
Japan yui does not exist obviously our
boys heard this bot ass take how many
times now man just can't fathom the idea
that she isn't alive especially since he
knows the people from EA specially in
psychological warfare so in his eyes he
has to see it to believe it although
they were unable to reason with him and
much to like the annoyance of Gabi Maru
kbo says that he and the others are all
delighted that he refused since this
gives him a chance to fight to the death
with the current Gabby Maru of IA gur
everyone inside of like the clan
obviously looks up to him especially the
young Lings the idea that they all get
to fight him in Mortal Kombat is a dream
funly enough some of the higher rankings
even dropped down to get the opportunity
to become fod on this mission just so
they had the chance to throw hands with
Gabby bowing their heads in honor of
what's about to come the plethora of
ginon rushed towards Gabby Maru however
using Dow sensation and looking like he
perceives absolutely everything in
reality right now it's like some Gojo
spe gabimaru quickly deals with a ninja
dodging in and out of all of their
attacks and using their own weapons
against them what the f losers dealt
with Gabby tells them all that itage
tactics such as psychological warfare
and numbers will not work on him kbo
notices that like our boy has become a
lot stronger but is corrected by the
ninja saying that no he finally learned
to become weak he then states that he
doesn't care who he has to fight whether
it's the Lord tenson or every iuri even
these new Yamada they stand in his way
and try to hinder him from Escape he
will obliterate everyone and
everything dude I laugh so hard at this
part when I like first read through it
and everything you'll see you'll see in
a moment what I mean but we'll just skip
around here quickly so you get the idea
well as Gabby Maru quickly begins taking
down all of the guinon who are like
overly satisfied they all introduce
themselves before instantly being merked
by our man who all the while lets them
know what they did wrong with their
techniques training them in their final
moments like a true king and in the beat
down though Gabby Maru takes out the
final attacking ninja with a fat Kick
completely cracking the floor they're
standing on going byaku gun mode all of
a sudden Gabby activates his Dow and
takes the opportunity to sense the
palace's layout to revealing the
skirmishes taking place between enemies
and allies quickly dodging a random f a
ninja that tried attack him from behind
he also senses that sha is located at
the flood gate in a boat sigar safe for
the time being but he is shocked to see
that fuchi had fallen keeping the
mission as his main Priority First Gabby
ignores assisting the others to rush
towards the Ron Temple to meet up with
sigari steal the elixir of life from the
ninja Squad and leave through the
floodgates to reunite with his wife
meanwhile Zan's plants like remains
suddenly reawaken then slowly moving it
leaves the tyu temple and takes the
underground water system to eventually
reach the Divine Beast Bano remembering
like Ran's past explanation about how
the B required more high quality Dow to
stay alive and that consuming it would
be dangerous zujin in their half-baked
State throws the warnings aside and
makes its way into the amalgamation of
vines to become one with the Divine
Beast erupting from the top of the
palace wood and other remnants of it go
flying everywhere as Zin emerges
completely fused with a Divine Bano and
draws everyone's attention at a similar
time it's revealed that chobe allowed
himself and Toma to be captured by the
enemy as he believed that it's better to
bite his time rather than fight while
outnumbered however try bazali starts to
feel a pain coming from his arm which as
JC starts to ask him what's up flowers
began uncontrollably sprouting from his
body while this like occurrence is
happening a captured Doshi walks out in
front of J and starts to transform Blake
back into a human with the dude
sentience returning he just wonders as
to like where he is and the whereabouts
of his allies and like how he even
arrived here to begin with at the same
time Gabby maru's flower da also starts
to react and his body begins sprouting
flowers across it looking into the
distance and seeing the massive flower
monster he assumes that it's it's most
likely got something to do with that
thing at The Floodgate Ran's body also
reacts and while sensing what caused
this change finds it Zen had merged with
a Divine Banco the Zen fused Banco then
releases a plethora of roots which begin
to track any large source of Dow
transforming them into trees in the
process over in the Ron Temple scary
notices that May's body is starting to
react to the Barco causing Isuzu to rush
outside and find out what exactly has
happened only making it to the doorway
though she then becomes horrified as she
looks outside witnessing multiple
sunflower like human trees mix with t
monin and soan stuck in the zaz in pose
walking through them towards the center
of her ey meanwhile suar notices that
Gite and fi had managed to disappear and
instead only finds a flower beard in
front of him while this has been going
on ran thinks back to an old
conversation he had with ran in it he
was saddened about how the Divine Banco
wited but refused any thought of ever
turning it ENT 10 as it was just too
strong to control even for them the
tense and with throw off the delicate
balance of Da that gives them form in
reality and sadly because of what zujan
has done everything will have to start a
new endlessly they shall return to the
outset just like before their hopes are
dashed a feeling one only gets when
traveling between jigo kuraku itself
having heard ran State this once again
ran asks why he would go so far what is
he truly trying to achieve here shugan
who's still looking at the flowers in
front of him realizes that both fuchi
and genar hadn't left but were covered
by them and wonders what could have
possibly caused it he has been found by
iur Shinobi who have come to confirm
that shija was taken out while fighting
Ren but managed to stall them
momentarily and now the Tinton is about
to leave on his ship after getting the
elixir of life from them suan orders the
ninja to uncover gantu toight and fo his
bodies from the flowers and confirm
their status once shugan had left though
and made his way to the floodgates and
iur Shinobi reforms their face and
reveals themselves to be sha in Disguise
stating that they had substituted
themselves with another EV allowing them
to escape they then for good measure
throw to kunai at the flower bear to
make sure that gantai and fui don't
survive sha then jumps up onto a roof
and once she sees just how messed up the
area has become states that it's almost
as if they on the other side seeing the
massive bco monster in front of her she
realizes that M Mortals are no match for
such a thing laughing now she leaps from
the building and some hectic looking
JoJo's pose ready for her otherworldly
death match against Gabby Maru shortly
after fui still somehow alive wakes up
and comes to the conclusion that shugan
must have held back as he definitely
could have ended him there looking over
to his man he sees that gde is in a
terrible condition and decides that
instead of treating himself he needs to
help him with his hands trembling Fuji
tries focusing on treating his wounds
until he sees an apparation of himself
telling him that he should give up since
this new outlook of his own life will
not do him much good in this era this is
an era in which men happily surrender
their lives of a superior commands it
one in which a son takes pride in
serving as as a Kaku shugan is a perfect
representation of this and that's why he
acts this way he knows that the yada
Clan is already treated like a band of
ronin and this could cause them to be
disowned by the Shogun fi's apparation
pleads with him to know his place as if
he emerges from this it'll ruin
everything with fuchi slowly beginning
to fade he tells himself that the clan
does matter a lot to him and he doesn't
want it to be disbanded still he
believes that what he has learned on
this island matters and now he's
beginning to lose his mind over these
competing emotions he knows that he
truly does want to support G suai and
even though Shu tried to end his life he
doesn't blame him in the end he just
wonders if this is what it means to be
human opening his eyes to the sound of
someone mumbling GTI toite instantly
Rises to his knees and panics seeing fui
lying down dead in front of him
realizing that he had given everything
just to heal him screaming at him he
asks if the Yamada of Simon fui really
just went and saved his life unable to
open his eyes or even respond fui who's
still somehow alive just Bec SES
delighted to hear that gide called him
by his name for the first time and his
last thoughts Fuji warns shugan that the
survivors are not to be underestimated
since he has observed their will to
continue fighting no matter what
everything and everyone on the island is
a walking Paradox fui then happily waves
goodbye as he accepts his fate and tells
us all that he hopes everyone's dreams
become realized enemies and allies alike
and my throat like has a medeor sized
Rock in it right now that H harder than
sensor's death in my book I don't know
if it's cuz I love these two guys the
most and their interactions with both
Yara and G but seeing him happy for
everyone here in the end figuring out
how we truly felt towards people and how
we came to see that everyone was similar
as just a great way to end a character
that like I initially thought was a
simple replacement for the weeb king
plus to those saying like in my last
video that this was just hand like yeah
a lot of it is but it's also just
jam-packed with proper character
development on each side and enough
World building so that we don't feel
like we're missing out on some like
massive piece of info might sound crazy
but for like how concise and quickly
like the story is moving it's still
smashing everything I wanted to know and
more plus the art that Yuki is just been
showing recently is God here in this Arc
also I just you know I probably should
mention this but big Gary Maru just
ripped off the flowers that were around
his body several minutes before
everything went down goofa entered the
main Temple Annex to protect the Basin
as ordered by Ren while looking through
the flame thingy he's holding gofar
becomes confused if this was indeed
Ran's true plan all along and the
present shugan is told by the ewi K
Shinobi to not engage the giant monsters
since their touch will cause them to be
engulfed by flowers not bothered by this
Shar makes quick work of the monsters
using ca's fighting style and cries upon
thinking about his passing pushing forth
he notices that the Bano isn't paying
attention to him and makes he run for it
to enter the main Temple before the
vines could block his path meanwhile
sigari yua and Isuzu defend themselves
against the monsters next to them and
see us how like the Dow round is being
disrupted ma slowly begins to start
blooming in herself seeing her they all
realize that they must do something
quickly before it's too late for May Yia
swings up to get a good look at zujin
and after seeing that it's blocking the
entrance to the floodgates with vines
and monsters notes that it seems as if
they're back at square one she then sees
that Zari is trying to convince Isuzu
into cooperating with the convicts but
to no avail wanting to help her mate she
drops in and tries her hand in
persuading her however gusai also
arrives carrying fuch's body while
boldly stating that they do not need to
join forces with her as after all it was
shugan who took down fui after the group
buries fui in flowers Gena directs his
anger towards Isuzu and once again says
that they do not need her help agreeing
with him though asuzu says that they do
not need to cooperate as shugan is still
here members of this Mission weren't
chosen because of their innate ability
rather the three of them were ideal
disposable porn set up for the amusement
of the Shogun if it were a priority of
them to end this Mission they would have
selected shun to begin with as his power
is incomparable usara who like knows
that they need help becomes annoyed with
isuzu's stubbornness after she
continuously refuses and calls her a
gorilla only for Isuzu to get hit with a
fat dose of their childhood pdsd and
reply that gorillas embodi the very
concept of Bushido getting down on her
knees Isuzu then intends to commit
seppuku to take responsibility for the
death of her comrades and hopes that her
death will appease the Shogun as
everyone continues to bicker amongst
each other ja arrives with Toma chobe
Karu Shon nugi and the E shobi J tells
Isuzu that if he doesn't return home
then the responsibility will line shugan
to commit comicide however he does also
say that he just came up with a great
plan that will be able to defeat zujin
and might have a way for the criminals
to earn their freedom but needs
assistance from Gabby Maru in order to
do so remember how I brought up that the
like Divine Bano was literally the god
of creation and creation myth earlier in
the video well now we've seen everything
what do you all think about that being
like the reality of it in the series it
just kind of needed I guess one of these
tenson to control it to become like a
living being being on this planet like a
like a Titan in some kind of aspect
anyway moving forth chob while suffering
from Zan's effects on his body explains
to everyone that according to May the
Divine Banco has spread all over the
palace and that the fragments in the air
are T particles from the flowers which
will cause anyone to undergo
artification if inhaled may also warns
them that they will have until morning
to destroy it or everyone's D will be
disrupted and cause them to turn into
flowers knowing that they have to stop
it to destroy the Tandon chubby lets
them all know that he senses the banko
has five tendons of each of the five
elements scattered around the grounds of
her ey after remembering how he like won
their fight with jua and dala Gant side
predicts that they'll probably have to
destroy all of the Banos Tandon
simultaneously looking around at the
state of everyone here sh becomes
concerned with the condition since the
battle with the tension has left them in
a bad shape to continue fighting as a
few larger monsters roll up behind their
group everyone easily takes care of them
destroying them in an instant after
hearing sigari and nuga make excellent
points about needing enough Dow to
destroy the Bano and stop the monsters
from ping them jica while lazily big
chilling on the floor tells them all
that they need Gabby Maru to handle this
problem which you know like I went over
just before except this is much more
expanded on then out of freaking nowhere
saryi Ducks after sensing A Fire torrent
coming from behind her which incinerates
all of the monsters and reveals that the
one and only Gabby Maru has arrived
however due to him being inflicted by
the Banos effects he collapses to the
ground after finally reuniting with
everyone with Gabby Maru in a bad State
jiga sees that he has to change his
plans and turns as a attention to the
ewi Shinobi beside him obviously Gabby
Maru was super glad to see that sigari
is okay since he reminds her that he
needs her in order to return and receive
the pardon despite everyone feeling
exhausted choby says that they have to
fight back no matter what happens he
then walks up to Gabby Maru and
compliments him on the first battle
before stating that given what he's seen
it's fairly evident that he's also got
something to lose to which Al bettered
and bruised Gabby confidently says that
he does and that nothing else matter to
him chob becomes satisfied after hearing
this from him and Shon who's like close
by then looks at nugi and sees that he
also has something to lose chica then
walks up to Isuzu who wonders of Gabby
Maru has Charmed secary after seeing her
wanting to help him she knows that she
swore not to defile her brother's Legacy
by working with these criminals so
instead she decides to defer and catch
up with shugan when she can with
everyone on board now chica prepares a
disgust a plan but wishes for Shion to
explain it and tear much to his
annoyance while Gabby Maru is Sly
distracted the ewor of K shobi really
themselves while remembering a specific
Shinobi principle when going for the
kill keep your presence suppressed no
movements let it all come as naturally
is breathing then as if nothing is out
of the ordinary they all take the
opportunity to attack him with throwing
kunai any moments before they strike
from the Shadows Shon explained to the
like unaware group that a Tandon can
only be destroyed by a user with a
correct Dow attribute and DOW
restoration will increase the attack
potency May then confirms like the Dow
attributes of everyone who's like in the
group and because we know everyone I'll
just go over the ones that we don't know
jaica is Earth Here Karu with metal and
Uzu who has a water D wondering if this
scruffy dude is anyone like you can
count on USA questions sigiri about his
skill to which she also becomes insure
due to the bad rumors about him these
bad rumors by the way are that like he
pawned his blade away so that the one he
has now is trash and often gets on the
booze with the boys not completing his
assignments while they're distracted the
E would kakur Shinobi throw the kunite
Gabby Maru in an attempt to finish their
mission randomly though J notices their
attack and turns asking if they really
want to go through with this so you see
even sigari has been confused for a
while as to why Jer is ranked three and
even asked Shion back in the day Shion
states that taking his personality into
account he's the lowest of lows it was
confirmed that he even sold a sword for
some cash and now only carries around a
simple bamboo takamitsu which is a sign
of disrespect to the Shogun however he's
never once been accused of it du to how
his blade Cuts Like steel Shon explains
that one time while they were on the
booze he told him that he could perceive
the truth in all things and through that
manipulate someone's momentum by
applying force in certain spots he
claimed that it was something that went
beyond just the waves that Shon was able
to perceive and in reality it's fairly
evident that men aligned himself with
some Yin or Yang as he was able to
easily reflect all of the kunai back
into the ninja also takamitsu by the way
refers to like a bamboo sword carved in
the shape of a like wooden Katana it's
not the shenai which is made up of
bundled sleds or a ban which is usually
made of heavier wood and sometimes
referred to as like a bakuto the W Taki
mitu can also be used as a pajor for a
cheap dagged blade so pretty much
everyone thinks he has an ass blade but
turns out man's cracked with everyone
stunned at just what happened nuga
becomes confused because she thought the
Shinobi were on their side but it's told
by J that he knew that Shinobi were only
pretending to be allies to complete
their main objective of taking Gabby out
J like confesses that he didn't know
whether to side with the iur or Gabby
Maru but after seeing Gabby decided to
stick with him thinking that they were
somewhat alike although Gabby Maru
disagrees so you see jica he got a few
ladies and that's why he thinks him and
Gabby are quite a similar usera becomes
convinced of J's abilities but still
finds herself unable to get a good read
on him as the group then decides to take
possession of the Shinobi's equipment
Ziri finds herself conflicted thinking
that they have to start all over with
this insane situation and knowing that
even if they succeed they're all doomed
to slaughter each other at the end Gabby
Maru though disagrees as he believes
there are a few differences compared to
how they started and more looking at
just how much everyone has changed use
rear agrees with this a logical thinking
of his as that's when he tends to be
right and damn like everyone looks so
damn fire with these new fits on
especially chobe Dude Looks Like so
demonic with that mask it's actually so
clean so anyway back to the story
everyone's parents have pretty much
stayed the same except this time instead
of being with like yera Gabby is with
sigiri since who would D will help up
his fire and Yara stays with May to
figure out the exact locations of each
Tandon and finally Big G will team up
with J to help boost his Earth down then
with everyone well equipped and paired
up the group set off to destroy each of
the tendons falling into a memory about
the tenson though zuen remembers re's
explanation on the right of just
consumption and giggles at his poor
drawings Dua notices this smoke and rip
reminds him to which the young lean
apologizes but remarks that he can't
stand the way Dua picks on them the
tinon knows that this is all for daa's
sake but finds it annoying that he's
always on the edge trying to protect
them thinking on each tense and more Zen
goes over all of the good and bad
qualities of them and at heart they're
truly nice people then remembering how
they must work hard so they don't fail
like last time large white orbs begin
appearing in front of her making her
think that she needs to collect them all
to complete the ride of just consumption
back in reality though the amalgamation
of Zan's Banco begins grabbing at the
surroundings doing its best to gather as
many different types of Dow having made
their way to the shuu temple Kio and
Isuzu comfortably destroy a bunch of
random creatures protecting the entrance
Isuzu starts to notice that she is
getting exhausted from staying too long
in the area and finally realizes that
this is why they had to Ally with the
criminals hearing her statement and
while taking out a few insects Karu
tells Uzu to not doubt Shan's orders as
he was the only one who ever believed in
them shugan never judged them from
coming from an offshoot Dojo or because
they were young he trained everyone the
same no matter what after remembering
the respect suan showed towards him
kirar reminds her of how he s up for her
in the past and was even the person who
got her a teaching role Isuzu thanks
kumaru for reminding her about her
loyalty towards shugan and remembers the
time shugan pointed out the Beauty and
the color of her skin having cut their
way through the overgrowth now outside
of the palace Isuzu breaks the door open
rushes in and tells your that shugan is
in the right standing there inside of
the shuu temple the Joo finally confront
one of Zan's Tandon after arriving at
the Banko's Earth Tandon Shion tells
nuga to stay back as he defends against
the monsters approaching them but
quickly realizes that he's nearing his
limits they then hear the sound of the
Conch from Yara signaling that everyone
has reached their respective tons and
can begin to destroy them him see as how
the tannan is too high up for his sword
to reach shus naruga sword with his
strength and DOW and throws it towards
the Tannon but unfortunately it only
leaves a shallow cut in her own Dark
World zujan feels something to take her
hand but can't seem to figure out what
it is reaching forth trying to grab a
ball of Dow it's Shan that in reality
she's controlling monsters which are
about to grab the duo Shon yells out to
nugo to stay behind him until the next
sound of the horn since her inability to
use Dow puts her in danger once he the
speak up nugo remembers all of the times
Shion told her to stay back as he fought
alone and now he requin his status as
the yada in front of Karu in order to
become a guardian he himself knows that
it's due to the era that he's currently
in and has no hopes of changing any of
the laws around her fate however a man
can change himself and that's why he
decided to leave the yada Clan because
like the legend he is he couldn't
condone the execution of an innocent
person nugo asks Shon if he meant what
he said during that time to which he
answers yes after saying that she was
happy to hear him stay that nugo rushes
in to attack the monster herself she
already knows that it's dangerous and
remembers the reasons as to why she
cannot perceive D so you see in her clan
they don't believe things that cannot be
touched or seen however after thinking
about what can't be seen and remembering
the feelings she had towards tza manages
to awaken this ability and breaks forth
into the reality of gods having cut down
a bunch of fod creatures with his new
technique she tells Shon that she needs
to use her own strength to survive and
asks that he become her partner instead
of a guardian with a smile on his face
Shion states that his eyes have clearly
deceived him and because his body can't
take too much more asks that she take
the lead until the next s of the horn
rings out agreeing nugo rushes forth and
takes the lead still unable to see
themselves zujin becomes furious at the
random damage she keeps taking and makes
the Earth Tandon Sprout multiple bodies
of Mudan much to Shion and nuga Shar
while at the wood Tandon chob and TOA
find themselves confronted by clones of
dala that have emerged from the Tandon
leading them to believe that the same is
happening at every other tanon that
corresponds with the Dow attributes of
that specific tenson the brothers then
begin to ponder on whether they should
make the choice of escaping with the
other survivors or act on J's secret
plan of eliminating Shun in order for
him to make a false report to the Shogun
that they had died so I've actually held
off from saying this a little bit
earlier on cuz I wanted to but you see
our friendly neighborhood J right here
is actually what I consider to be a
first generation Yakuza we know for a
fact that Samurai over time didn't he
take the role throughout this period of
Japan as with no war they took different
routes of occup
why he wants everyone gone also is for
the fact that man wants to be the next
leader of the clan and doing that would
be perfect for him he wants to put this
world behind him for one of luxury
instead plus he also drops a bomb that
if Shon and sigiri end up Surviving the
bandits can take them down if they
please but that's you know that's just a
maybe as well after the Clones partially
transform into the Kikai State CH
prepares to fight back but feels his
body suffering from the bankers effects
on his Dow he also senses that Toma is
gradually suffering from the Dow
particles in the air and tries to to
think of a logical plan going forward he
knows that it's pretty much impossible
to take on both the daa Army and destroy
the Tandon plus they've got no time to
do the restore glitch effect telling
himself to break apart once more he
knows that he's he's just got to do it
originally it was his plan to slam back
the elixa with his brother but now he's
leaving everything up to him without a
single worry at all as he knows he'll
win watching his brother run ahead of
him choby pushes himself forth and
forces Vines out of his back and all
sides that destroy everything around him
meanwhile Gabby Maru and are approached
by shija who has comfortably taken out
all of the goofa Clones flashing back to
the moment where Gabby Maru and sigari
are confronted by the goofa Clones
themselves themselves shiji comes in and
quickly disposes of them all as the dust
begins to fade it's obvious that she's
extremely denied to reunite with Gabby
Maru Gabby then takes a time to talk to
sha due to knowing that the Shinobi is
unpredictable however after hearing the
sound of the Conch sigari reminds him
that they are running out of time and
must either have shija cooperate with
them or take them on as an enemy
gabimaru tells sigiri that he can't
afford to fight sha with the current
state is in prompting sigiri to try and
perform D restoration on him seeing this
and while calling her a winch sha DTS in
behind the two and prepares to take out
sigiri only to Cease the assault in an
instant after being ordered by Gabby
Maru to wait hearing him out Gabby Maru
just asks her to help as he's in great
need of her strength with sha having
like multiple personalities it's hard to
know which way she'll react here turns
out though that she's been waiting
months to hear those words a battle in
her mind between helping the chief or
following her heart
happily she agrees to help Gabby Maru
but only in order to truly resurrect his
true self in a sense she will dedicate
her existence to the Soul Revival of
History strongest Gabby Maru the Holo as
Sha rushes into attack and despite his
previous injuries Gabby Maru tells AI to
take down the regenerated goof clones
behind them while he handles fighting
against Sha Sha first starts off your
attack by using NPO here forg to throw
multiple kunai at gabimaru while dodging
them chija then uses the opening to use
NPO flash hand to push him backwards
Gabby Maro dashes out of the way of a
kunai and fights during close quars
combat where the two using a multitude
of technical techniques to try and get
the upper hand on one another
simultaneously both of them end their
initial Clash by using Nino fire monk to
create a massive explosion knowing that
sha knows more like Ninjutsu thanam
Gabby Maru speculates that continuing to
fight with tautu is more effective
however cha literally word for word
quotes what Gabby Maru was thinking and
tells him that they are aware of every
move he makes as they after all spent so
much time observing him despite this and
as the two begin fighting once more
gabur tells sha that they are also able
to read their actions with the help of D
he then purposefully takes a kick to the
naval in an attempt to send himself
towards the boncos Tandon and destroy it
but ends up only destroying the statue
beneath it sha somehow sees through him
and could tell from the very start of
the fight that he has been protecting
sigiri who they refer to as the hag they
then start to wonder if Gabby Mo's
current state is because of like the
hag's presence and as she manages to get
the upper hand slamming Gabby Maru into
the ground becomes saddened after seeing
just how much his body is suffering from
the weakened D regeneration picking up
his face and staring into his eyes she
finds it truly heartbreaking to see that
her love lost his deadly ferocity and
instead chose to protect others she then
realizes in Anger that sigari is with
Gabby Maru to perform D restoration and
jumps towards her Direction and disgust
Gabby Maru yells out to sigari to run
however sigari refuses stating that
she's head enough she won't stand being
caught a ha anymore and prepares to face
shija alone knowing that the ninja isn't
an immortal Zar uses her Dow to
anticipate sh's attack but is unable to
react in time as in an instant she
appears before her and slams her into
the ground having picked up a special
bag earlier sary pulls it out causing
the female ninja to quickly D back and
ask why she is Ed with Gabby Maru
despite her job saryi explains that yes
once upon a time she lived to a strict
code but this this is no longer their
case as an era begins to shift it's
almost possible to sympathize with
anyone not just Gabby Maru but the
tenson and even iar ninja after hearing
this statement CH uses Hood Ino knotted
locks to seem to hear through the ground
before it Springs up restraining sigiri
pinning her down thinking that sigiri
wants to share a similar experience to
herself she makes her inhale the powder
she tossed earlier so you see this
powder is one that manipulates one's
sensation and makes them experience an
overwhelming sensation of pain as often
used in the training of young ninja
which like just like it shows with sha
usually results in only a few family
memb surviving this toxin is known as
nerve powder and all an evil gur undergo
intensive training with it for 3 days
and three nights until they acclimate to
the pain as they prepar to gives sigari
another drug which is called NE Blas she
explains that it connects with the
pleasure section of the brain she tells
her that all in Ur are made to be numb
stripped of their senses so that the
only feeling they have left is one of
death fear and despair and the face of
death are the only distinct sensation
those inside the clan feel Gabby Mara
first granted her that feeling and
through her encounter with him she
eventually became aware of her own
mortality yes and if there is death
which embodies life itself death which
comes for all true fleeting life can
only be found in that moment of parting
you Yuki back had it with their poetry
again and I had to change things up
slightly for the super morbid side of
this like text right here cuz of YouTube
but I recommend everyone go and read
like this passage of text themselves cuz
you could kind of just pops off with how
how beautifully he constructs a vivid
image with his words inside someone's
mind with his body beginning to suffer
and his Dow depleted as well as sigari
being unable to combat against sha Gabby
Maro SE that their chances of Victory
are slowly fading away the sicking Gabby
asks Gabby mo why he is desperately
clinging to life to which he answers
that he desires to live a normal life
with his wife she tells Gabby that his
wish cannot come to pass since e will
remain in puru of him forever and his
wife does not exist gab Maru denies the
thought though as he knows is the
typical psychological warfare and tries
to buy enough time to recover his doubt
and presents an opening for sciri sha
like she's done through the majority of
this belt sees through Hashim and pleads
to G to come to his senses as they try
to explain that his wife and the life he
shared with her is false pure make
believe gtis also focuses on preparing
himself to cut down the giant flower in
front of him beside him J who really
ain't Keen to do that much right now
decides to lay down and put his faith in
gusai gantai who like interprets his
unfaced behavior as a test of Courage
sits down next to him wishing to follow
along as well which J just found
extremely random he then hears the
signal to take action but is told by J
that the roots will tell them when they
t have been destroyed and when it's the
correct time to take out the main Plant
Big G questions how he knows this and J
explains that he's been able to
understand how things move ever since he
was young like how to inflict a cut or
exactly where a pet would fall his motto
is one of waiting as good things are
bound to come to those who wait gde
though then senses that he is up to
something but can't really seem to get a
read on what his intentions are over
with the Grazy over with the Grazy
stalker girlfriend sh explains to Gabby
Maru that like Judah e gur's influence
no matter how hard someone craves a
normal life and simply unattainable the
chief's daughter is no exception at all
she possesses no emotions and has been
merely set up to fake a relationship
with him as a way to hide the atrocities
he commits her smile tastes all is a
deception crafted to imprison his mind
cutting off the the mental stuff going
on right now though I need to point out
how cracked Yuki is again for like the
20th time this hero is a representation
of ban Raku Theater which is super dope
like you're the old like Puppet Theater
except these bodies are like the size of
a humans and the bodies are usually
controlled by out to like three
different people it's just perfect
imagery to show how manipulated and
controlled gab's life has being with his
wife with this in mind though she begs
for Gabby to revert back to his former
self and throw away any idea of a normal
life after hearing she are out saryi
awkwardly Smiles as she looks up at
Gabby Maro standing back up like like
saryi suspected all our boy needed was a
confirmation that she does indeed exist
she you kind of miss you kind of messed
up there we know for a fact that his Dow
explodes whenever his wife is mentioned
and for him these feelings are tied to
strength and weakness due to that and
because of how and how's Paradise the
Dual forces of Yin and Yang can affect
someone's body and minorik his body is
then shown recovering after his D
becomes stabilized from the confirmation
he received of his wife truly existing
standing there Gabby Maru remembers the
words you imparted to him that this is
the battle we call life and it's
important to preserve a little normaly
at times confidently he tells sha that
he always knew his dream would come at a
price but now he's ready to search for a
new normal life with her with you with
his wife by his side with his body back
to normal gabimaru boldly States the Sha
that they will not have an advantage
over him and will not allow him to get
away with this no matter what this
causes sha to remember their past
confrontation with him when they were
children where he stated the exact same
thing get in my way and I'll take you
out sha let the mental Cas sheers then
becomes Overjoyed with Gabby maru's
Newfound attitude screaming that this
this is indeed perfect and in past
memory yui explains to Gabby Mo how to
properly prepare chestnuts after Gabby
questions the like the point behind at
all yui tells him that she doesn't quite
understand herself she just wanted to
try the normal way since growing up in
EA wasn't normal at all they two then
sit down to eat Chestnut rice which you
say she found to be very delicious and
sweet Gabby though staring at his plate
just wonders if it really was since he
wouldn't know J sense of taste as D you
who's actually sadly in the same
situation then tells him that by saying
it out loud they can at least pretend to
be
normal back in the present now and
during the current battle gab Maru says
that he has not lost his battle
instincts it's just that the battlefield
in general for him has changed referring
to his memories of how like he could not
understand his wife struggle before at
first he never understood why she would
do something so Random it just seemed
like meaningless drudgery to him what
was the point of food the normaly he
could never even figure it out looking
up into his eyes shei figures out that
gabim maru's love has no clear signs of
weakness and a lasch effort attacks with
everything that was taught to them by
Gabby darting Adam she tries to strike
his vitals but to know aail throwing a
kick Gabby effortlessly leans back out
of the way before blocking a follow-up
strike thrown by her jumping back she
remembers the time Gabby told her she'
never be able to master acidic Blaze
before pulling her hand up to her face
and releasing a huge torrent of flames
after using her own acidic Blaze sha
boosts forth pushing the Flames aside
and somehow managing to stab gabim
maru's heart nonchalantly though looking
down at his injury gabar applauds his
sha for a dep use of the ability
explaining that if he was still human
that might have just killed him now
though and because he's making it home
no matter what he grabs your hand pulls
your in close and activates Nino atic
Blaze full fire completely sitting the
duo Al lights after being engulfed by
Gabby maru's fine and Jitsu sha thinks
back over a sad existence she remembers
how everyone had admiration for Gabby
but hers was different something more
she wonders what it was what she found
she thinks about the time she fled from
Gabby Mara when there were children and
questions if the reason was because she
feared that she might have died as time
slowly moved forth she's a caught wind
of Gabby Maru being married to you and
tries to mirror her appearance by
burning the right side of her face in
reality though and she's known herself
for a while that the pounding of her
heart wasn't born from admiration nor
from dread but sadly the time for
thinking of that had indeed passed
having collapsed to the ground with a
smile on her face sha with her last bit
of strength creates a whistle from the
hair and signals all of the
eobi asking what the signal was for it's
revealed that it was in fact a cleansing
ritual one to clearly path forth for
Gabby and the last nimpo she'll ever use
they also tell him that you was indeed
alive and awaiting his return apparently
the chief like hadn't actually planned
to do anything until after all of the
Shinobi returned confirming Gabby's
death then he was going to deal with his
daughter with the final breath Shea asks
Gabby that if she's ever reborn in
sickness and in health until death
through them in part would he face them
once more to which he answers yes with a
smile on his face Cher happily thanks
Gabby Maru for his answer and wishes
them luck and his future battles I'd
love to know your thoughts on Sha down
in the comment section below damn like I
thought she was too crazy when she first
showed up but like over the short amount
of time that she was in the story I
guess right here who Dynamic is really
damn cool and the idea that she was the
next Gabby kind of like resonated with
me that she she had to kill Gabby there
if she wanted to take that position
moving forth now sahiri rolls over to
Gabby and is told by him that they need
to refocus their attention back on a
destroying the tandem while it's still
regenera with everyone around being in
the prime position usera sounds off the
next signal and all four teams
simultaneously prepare to destroy the
Tandon over with the big chillers though
J begins getting back up on his feet
after sensing that the timing is right
for him and gy decide to destroy the bco
yet as Big G himself begins to stand up
he States this thing might be uh might
be slightly difficult revealing the
titanized barod that had begin taking on
a completely completely new
transformation in preparation to take on
the new transform monster and I
absolutely love this part of the story
man J begins tossing off all his
clothing as a way to maintain his
spiritual focus and asks gusai at the
same time for a sword gusai finds it odd
that he doesn't have a strong enough
weapon to cut down the zujin fused Banco
but after looking at his surroundings
and witnessing bodies of zuu Jin
sprouting out of vines gai chooses to
follow wi's plan and gives him his sword
as I said this part is mental right here
boys this like this dude he he is him
using his own special intuition chica
senses all of the fatally wrong moves
that he could make as he walks forth to
take out the monster eventually after
casually strolling past countless spots
where he die in an instant jaica comes
to a good position with the right
factors like wind in presence around him
to cut down the monster finding that it
is all in syn now chica swings giz sword
and successfully cuts down the head of
the zji infused bco from a distance just
like he did in the past with the ocean
monster having watched his unfathomable
fate anti side becomes astonished and
remembers the time that he believed
defeating monsters would lead him down
the path of Legends standing in front of
him now is exactly the sort of man to go
down a history as a god Slayer thinking
on lately past more he also remembers
when fui fre to dohi and refused to
explain why as a baby clone of zujan
approaches him now G state that he
started to understand where Fuji was
coming from and that fighting monsters
in order to give him a thrill in his old
age doesn't affect him anymore in front
of him and having walked across a field
of flowers chica steps up to the Tandon
and prepares to destroy it Gena tries
warning him that if he should proceed
then it might also have an effect on
kimaru and chob since their Dow is
connected with the monster despite being
told this though chica ignores the risks
and utterly destroys the tandem with his
zoen fused Bano destroyed all traces of
its remnants slowly start to welt away
however J and gai soon realized that the
giant creature is still somehow alive
this is J who had already been mourning
as warned before by May and now because
of that they must take on the task of
destroying the tendon simultaneously
again Toby Sayes that the wood tendon is
beginning to slowly regenerate from the
Sun and finds himself too low on stamina
to make another attempt at destroying it
Tommy yells out suggesting the toay and
leaving the monster behind and trying to
find a way off the island together
instead in his eyes there's no reason to
dying here as that would make him no
different to their father despite his
brother's plea choba activates his
breakdown State one last time and uses
his Vines to dig into the wood Tandon he
knows he doesn't have the right
attribute but skewering the roots with
his Vines will allow him to cut off the
Regeneration of the main body with only
one job left he chooses to do that exact
method with each and every location as
he can fully destroy the immortal
through that method his plan ends up
becoming a success as everyone around
watches Cho's Vines burst through all of
the tendons in each location one last
time our demon Bandit says break down
and come the hell apart but not on
himself instead on the immortal Bano
which as a result starts to finally
wither away having used up his strength
chy falls to the ground and hears his
brother crying out to him falling into a
flashback of his own he remembers all of
the times he held to is a baby and how
he felt like he could break apart at any
second but still grabbed on to him for
dear life once realizing that he must
protect the little one as his older
brother chobe with tears in his eyes
says that he protected him because
that's what big brothers do and the
afterlife chin kneels down before his
parents and apologizes for the sins he
had committed in his life but was happy
to say that it was at least a good
brother a young chobe then runs to his
parents with open arms as his life
finally comes to an end randomly though
and breaking through the light he
notices a hand reach out to him after
the passing of his older brother Toma
kneels down in total grief for holding
on to what seems like a plant-like OV
meanwhile man USA run out of the temple
while complaining but the foul OD in the
air and encounter goof far as a child
who's holding on to this random Bas and
ear looking thing kicking things back
off as all of the flowers around begin
disintegrating May and usera confront
gfar who's holding on to that weird pot
looking thing remember like that was
where we ended right at the end of The
Last Arc which was just a battlefest
gofa lets them all know that duud to ja
cutting down the Divine Bano he can
sense that not only is the Banos Dow
destroyed but the islands as well Hing
that the land will soon meet its end the
reasoning for what zuim did as well was
explain to the humans who wouldn't have
had a clue about who want to be praised
by all of her fellow tenson us read her
comments on how she felt that GAR didn't
seem bothered At All by the fact that
the tenson are all dying but it's told
by him that death is not the end for
them every being passes from life but
their Dow will still remain even though
reversing their process is insanely hard
pretty much impossible under normal
circumstances the Little Man reveals
they have a chance of being revived
through the Basin pot ear looking thing
that he's holding inside of the Basin it
holds all of the Fall intense ules which
after a thousand years had passed will
allow them to fully revive USA who like
doesn't care about what happens a
thousand years from now decides that it
was time for her and may to enter The
Floodgate but it's warned by gfar that
yes she might not care about the future
but she B A Freak about what's going to
happen in the coming hours from now as
ran cannot be stopped meanwhile over at
those sneaky old floodgates shugan
bursts his way through the overgrowth
and grabs onto the Anchor's line in an
attempt to hold the ship's departure to
Japan I don't know like what man was
thinking and as we probably all saw
coming the line snaps allowing rean
their safe departure however turns out
shugan actually tore the rope in half
himself to use the anchor as a grappling
Hawk to fling himself all the way up
onto the boat standing there in front of
the final boss shugan states that he
doesn't care what cargo he intends to
move but he will never reach the
mainland looking back at him ran tells
him the same and that not a single soul
will leave this island alive darting at
the immortal she manages to easily
defend herself against shugan but also
tries to hold back is to not damage the
ship's interior shugan screams at
himself to not falter and slashes re
across his chest but this has no effect
due to his water down not being the
right match to hinder the creatures wood
Dow pointing her finger forth he then
shoots a blast of Dow which connects
directly with the spot on sugan's chest
where his heart would be sliding back or
gritting his teeth the Yamada states
that they will not fall to these dark
arts of these fiends revealing that
somehow rein's Blast Of Da actually hurt
tin's headband which he placed under his
robe thinking about how tza saved him
once more suan notes that that r assault
will only serve him poorly instead to
when he must call forth the true essence
of what it means to be a Yamada a Simon
choosing to replicate the abilities of
the other Yamada to fight shugan bursts
forth and uses a plethora of his
friend's abilities to slash at the
creature R senses something strange with
Shan's D and upon receiving another cut
toward his Tandon from a replicated
attack used by Shion she starts to
actually cff up blood jumping back in
fear ran is just confused as she was
sure the dude's da wasn't meant to
affect him yet after looking closer
realizes that shugan has the ability to
change the attribute of his Dow which
they always assumed was impossible
saying that they have to take him
seriously now R drops the control that
head over the Flames around them to give
her full attention to her enemy during
the battle suan who ain't really
concerned with these Flames tries to
attack yet R Who would have loved to
study this man on any the other day
takes things up a notch and sers Shan's
right arm with a feathered fan she then
states that time for tankering is over
and changes to their true form as Yin
allows for a far greater Focus back over
with the children siiz tenson may ask
scua as to what exactly Ran's true goal
was flashing into a dark room and using
their Dow illusion ability gofar shows
May and newa what they saw earlier in
Ran's laboratory so remember in their
last AR where gofar got surprised at a
revelation that wasn't really expanded
on well here it's shown that not only
did he find the OBS of all of the other
tenson but also an extensive amount of
research on restoring the body of
someone not the soul then beyond that he
noticed a war that wasn't in place
behind that unfamiliar the door hidden
by an illusion was even more research
and notes that alluded to the true goal
of Rin we will think that it's to M
every single person inside of Japan and
yes that is true but just as everyone
reacts to these clones looking after a
mysterious crippled figure in beard May
lets them all know that that person is
the Grand Master a sudden noise then
breaks them out of the illusion as goofa
explains that the noise came from ran
who had managed to finally set sail on
the open ocean after having dealt with
shugan despite the circumstances May
asks gar to continue with the
explanation on Jo fuku plan gar tells
May that they are making an incorrect
assumption Joe fuku had indeed died long
ago and has already been turned into a
gold statue so that his body can be
preserved undergoing
ocation back in the past when they were
first not permitted to meet with their
Master it wasn't because he was busy
more that he had actually aried and
passed from the Mortal realm for the
last 700 years ran has worked non-stop
for this day the way of Da explains that
the soul and and body are one and
through this it lead her to believe that
they would have been able to revive the
soul just like any other part of the
body goofa then tells May and USA that
Ran's true goal is to revive Joe fuku
using the Dow of all of these citizens
inside of Japan not use it to make a
perfect elixa for themselves like we
originally thought knowing that Juku was
already dead and while speaking in their
native Chinese tongue may ask scua who
was the Hoku that they found earlier on
when getting the Basin then and in a
crazy Revelation the little man revealed
that the person was the real body of ran
who' begun arbu fying in that room the
person that they are familiar with is
merely a puppet crafted out of Dow that
she controls the puppet insane quality
is due to the level of D manipulation
that surpasses what every other tenson
is capable of all of it points to one
solid conclusion in his eyes R is not
even a tenson but in fact a human and
the wife of Joe fuku when Jo fuku
actually left ancient China with his
3,000 voyages one of them was indeed Ren
the tenson all originally thought and
were taught that they were an
amalgamation of Mystic da and flower da
yet this was false first ran created
another version of herself and from that
the other tenson were all born back when
a change first started to sh ran it
wasn't because she was mad but because
her body had started to undergo ocation
limiting her time and only allowing her
to control the Clone version of herself
remotely gofar who doesn't fully
understand the matters Beyond his
comprehension just calls ran foolish and
starts to criticize the notion of love
that humans have and his eyes it makes
them pretty and cruel full of arrogance
lacking in style suspicious and paranoid
and even still it drives them to
sacrifice absolutely everything that
they have after over a thousand years of
building everything somehow ran is
willing to throw away everything if it
just means that they get a chance of
holding their love once more then with a
final statement he tells them that
within 2 hours ran will 100% reach Japan
to initiate their plan taking this all
in Yara panics wanting some form of
break after everything that they've been
through she even questions if this is
just another trap that t in trying to
sit up for them but gofar explains that
he's stuck in a paradox of his own he
wants Ron to leave but also wants to
save her unable to understand these
feelings he currently has he asks May
for her opinion on the matter but before
she could even give her answer usia hits
her over the head and tells her that
they should hurry to where the others
are as a Parting Gift kufar warns her
that according to the eye Ching they
found in 's room which for those who
like forgot iing allows the tenson to
tell the fortune of specific people
through this he was able to determine
that 100% only two men and one woman
will survive Goofer himself relies on
this chunked forcy fate and those names
who are unknown cannot be included in it
but ran themselves may even be among
those ceded one thing is for sure though
the art of iang does not lie having left
gfar Yara and may then arrive at the
entrance to the blood gates with
everyone else gathered obviously with
the exception of G tode who's already
gone here to try and stop Ren from
departing as well as the absence of the
other brothers who have yet to return
and like they just don't actually
realize that chob has passed on yet
after discussing how they need to find a
specific ship with a like Light low to
catch the main vessel the group into the
floodgates only to be left disappointed
that all of the ships have been burned
looking out through the wreckages nuga
spots one unharmed ship but is told by
Shon that they will not be able to use
it since the wreckages of all of the
other vessels as blocking the water from
flowing and allowing them to move out
with everyone left absolutely hopeless
Gabby Maru sees another vision of his
wife in front of him and dives into the
water to try and remove the deis himself
J tries reasoning with him but our boy
screams back they rethinking is
impossible he only has one goal and
refuses to give up wanting to help and
seeing the pain in his eyes both sigiri
and naruga dive in to help him despite
it being an impossible task standing
behind them our little girl may thinks
back to what goofa had just previously
asked her pointing her little hands
forth and closing her eyes USA then sees
May about to unleash her power which she
instantly objects to doing so since she
knows that her body will be at risk she
pleads with her asking if she wanted to
talk with ran and Juku once more but
with a smile on her face May explodes
and transforms into her kakai State
commanding everyone to get on the ship
while she handles the task of making a
path which is like damn May why did you
have to go and do that I know there's
this pot thing but still may like why so
skipping back and back in the early days
while looking after the first humans who
came to the island with them may asks
Joe fuku why he decided to bring people
to the island since the emperor only
seeks the electure Juku explains to her
that because Dow goes far beyond just
typical human understanding she
shouldn't concern herself with these
difficult matters pretty much saying
that it's above the level of humanlike
capacity in another memory and after ran
finished a session of like dank bju with
Joe fuku May is told by her to not feel
ashamed by the practice as even and the
young ones will perform this training
someday so she mustn't continue to Har a
doubts then as the children Grew Older
she recalls her punishment for defying
ran and how she felt powerless to do
anything about it she was fed up with it
all so she fled and told herself that
she was unable to make a change but
after recalling goar's past question as
to why she returned to harai May
remembers that it was once again because
she was fed up with it all and the
present May explodes into a Kikai State
and continues to say that she was up
with having fled over and over not
anymore though now she flaps all five of
her massive wings and blows away the
wreckage giving everyone a clear enough
path to get on board the ship saryi
prepares herself to yell out to mate and
concern but is interrupted by Gabby Maro
who begins yelling at himself telling
her that she is at risk of dying if she
continues to stay in a Kikai form and
her original goal of being able to live
a normal life will fade away May then
returns to normal dropping out of her
fighting form and hugs both sigiri and
Gabby Maru and she thans thanks both of
them for everything that they have done
for her but this this is how she takes
responsibility for everything in her
life she tells the confused Gabby and
sigiri that watching them has a way of
filling her with courage and finally
thank sigiri for combing her here in the
past before slapping her Palms together
revealing that they were actually in an
illusion and may had indeed transported
everyone to the ship safely as May uses
one last gust of wangs she pushes the
ship forth allowing them to rush after
the final boss in her last moments and
as she begins to fade away May
apologizes to everyone for not being
there to sail off with them to her
father hoko to her family and to rean
for not realizing their feelings after
they banished her and how she would have
been able to stop them
originally elsewhere and aboard the ship
alga blade Dragon toaya gusa walks his
way through the Flames of Hell over the
other side of that like burning ship ran
reclaims the elixe of life after finding
it lying next to the defeated shun she
then wonders as to why he had it on him
but quickly dismisses the question after
having it back in her hands with the uh
with the elixa returned ran sees that
all that is left to do is put her faith
in the paradise butterflies and becomes
happy to know that her dream will soon
come true as things were going well in
her favor the puppet randomly starts to
feel its body suffering due to Ran's Dow
control starting to listen with time
running short in her eyes ran hopes that
she reaches Japan soon meanwhile and
over the other side of the Flaming deck
gai finds shugan unconscious and starts
to wonder as to why his seet arm wasn't
bleeding shugan then wakes up badly
injured and sees G hedar standing right
in front of him without fi by his side
but soon remembers as to why this was
not the case Gant side tells shugan that
he was glad that he managed to wake up
since it wouldn't have felt right to cut
him while he was still down somehow
though shugan manages to block the first
attack on him but falls down after being
knocked off balance losing his sword in
the process Genai tells shugan that it
is useless for him to fight back now
that he has lost his right arm but it's
told by the injured asimon that is a
samurai he cannot give up just straight
up annoyed G just like kicks Shan in the
face and screams that all of them are a
band of fools all of this damn honor and
dignity forced him to cut down one of
his own friends he punches him in the
face and kicks him in the stomach while
telling him that his ways of living are
utterly corrupt suan makes in an attempt
to defend himself by swinging his sword
but fails after losing his balance once
again gusai then turns his back on
shugan calls him out to be a purely
pathetic Samurai and tells him that he
doesn't care if he decides to burn to
death now as he watches the blade of his
sword burnning the fire in front of him
shugan grabs it and quickly cauterizes
the stump of his right arm after
remembering fuch's advice about
disinfecting a wound he practices
getting used to swinging his sword with
his left arm in front of againi and
recalls the time fi discussed with him
that the human body is a toall and that
by searching its construction and limits
one can manipulate it as they see Fed G
then becomes shocked is that shugan in a
matter of moments managed to adapt using
his left arm to wield his sword the
screams to gy that fuchi was caught up
in a sentimentality but says that a
samurai Spirit lives on within him now
falling into another memory of the past
he recalls the time where he pointed out
how we the yada Clan was fui though said
that even though they got rocks thrown
at them for being that like weird group
of people the clan allowed them to
partake in his offbeat proces and for
that reason it's always going to be
extremely deare to him shugan then
proceeds to tell gantai that someone
like him can never understand a samurai
sensor duty to protect all of those that
they hold dear to them and that he has
long since abandoned his own
sentimentality after he finishes his
statement Shan's eyes then mysteriously
begin to invert and change color not
noticing this though Big G points out
the fact that he sheds tears quite a lot
for someone without sentimentality and
prepares to fight him but senses
something different so back over with
the other group and earlier on before
arriving at the floodgates suan senses a
strange energy emitting for the god
containing the elixir of life and
becomes suspicious of its content PRP
prompting him to straight up open the
bottle and taste test it for any
underlying poisons much of the shock of
the shobi accompanying him he splits out
its remains and then declares it to be
safe for consumption by the time he
faces gedi though it's obvious that the
full effects of the elixe is shown to
have run its course as Shan's eyes start
to change in a rapid moment he then
darts at the elderly G and tries to
strike him down comparing him to last
time gantai notices that suan is somehow
able to fight properly as if nothing was
even wrong and that the way he moves his
body is similar to Fu cheese to him it's
as if he's fighting against his own
friend which complicated things for him
even more and meant that he didn't even
defend as the fake fui sliced at his
chest after his robe is cut open Gant
sees the bandages that F used to heal
him with before his own passing and
decides to stop fighting for that reason
looking at him shugan questions if he
was ready to surrender yeah in a
freaking million years though like like
I I think you need to understand that
big G Genai is built completely
differently he tells shugan that he was
just remembering the reasons as to why
he boarded the ship in the first place
and how he never even intended to fight
him slowly standing up now ganta
explains that in the past he T the
provinces fighting anyone of strength
but at some point they never even
scratched the edch he sought to find his
nickname blade Dragon came about after
he took down his very first Monster a
Rio catsu known to as feeble English
readers as a ship's kale with that said
g Smiles as he brings his sword down and
slashes the ship in two causing a
massive explosion as the energy blast
connects with the ocean below falling
back with his wounds reopened he laughs
as he was unable to completely cut the
ship in half but figures that one more
attempt would be able to do the job
absolutely like enraged with what's just
happened Ren floating there in the sky
starts to ask what in the world he's
just done gide then Nots that like
obviously the ship couldn't even be
sliced into completely since it's
actually made out of D and then as she
slowly begins to stroll towards Theo now
says that he didn't manage to cleave the
ship in two but did indeed manag to slow
her down enough for the next crew to
make it on board guessing that his work
here is finally done he reades himself
to get off the ship instead of
continuing to fight stating that his
life was indeed a gift given to him and
that now he will not throw it away
however he does tell both ran and shugan
that someone else stronger than him will
arrive shortly and that he hopes that
they're ready to face him then looking
over the boat and Through the flames he
becomes happy to see that Gabby Maro and
the squad had finally pulled up Gabby
Maru flings himself up on board the ship
compliments Gant to for the work he has
done so far and tells him that he will
handle the task of taking down the ship
as he faces both ran and shugan
alone so it's the final showdown now
boys but right back before boarding the
ships themselves gabaro pointed out that
the Flames were probably too strong for
everyone but him to jump on board so
alone now and walking through the Flames
like a yamabushi monk gabimaru
approaches ran and shugan Shan then
standing there himself takes note of the
sitting in front of him and Compares it
to the portrait he and Eisen looked at
to piic in Hell which in my eyes just
goes back to how like the series is
called jigo kuraku and how that word
when broke down means one heaven and two
Hells I like actually wonder if that
also refers to the amount of survivors
that this mission is going to end up
with two men and one woman could have
also been in front of our eyes from the
very GetGo I just I love that like
Paradox as well everything about these
like the end of The Last Arc and this
Arc here has kind of just been paradoxes
throwing up people anyway anyway let's
push forth and discover how Yuki ends
this amazing series nevertheless shugan
then announces that he will for the sake
of the world and the clan punish even
the Devil Himself hearing his war cry
gabimaru commented that he's already
used to this hellish domain well ran on
the other hand just found her situation
with them to be extremely irritating in
an instant all of them then Clash blades
hands and feet in a three-way freefor
all continuing all of them then wave
through each other's strikes ran blocks
G Mar's attack and tells them that she
will not allow him to damage the ship
any further and will use everything they
have to kill him will stomp in foot onto
the ninja R sees that shugan was about
to attack her from behind and uses who
fan to counter him taking things up a
level shugan manages to anticipate her
attack and uses the Dow sensory ability
and comes in to strike using shion's
wood Affinity however Rion who's just
like in another class when it comes to
the level of skill stands on the top of
shugan Sword then sitting down she tells
him that as a shinen the highest class
of hermit a human such as himself would
not be able to harm her before raising
her hand and firing a point blank
invisible Dow attack watching this from
the side Mario SE that ran as a lot
stronger than zujin and ran but
remembers from his conversation with ja
earlier that as long as Ran's priority
is keeping the ship intact he should be
able to hold his own and the battle ran
suddenly becomes shocked as see that
tendon got slightly cut and sees that it
was done by no other then our Queen
saryi who boarded the ship after
remembering that Gabby Mara will need
her help since her wood down will
actually harm ran and you know like his
loone won't actually be able to take her
down after nuga who's like sell on the
other boat with everyone else makes a
point that their best chance said
survival is fighting together the other
survivors with the exception of jica cuz
just man's always on the sneak and can't
be doing anything all decide to board
Ran's ship to take her down together ran
states that a gathering of humans will
do nothing to stop her however Gabby
silences her nonsense he already knows
that they're just a bunch of randoms who
came together to fight but they will do
anything to survive and make it home
together knowing that range D is too
powerful us was a rehart and Gabby Maru
decided that the best cause of action is
to try and have it deete all of energy
here similar to like how they managed to
defeat Ry and then with like everyone
else acting as distractions around them
so that they can keep out the battle
sprinting forth usara makes the first
attack by using her nimpo concealed
armor ability in combination with her
nimpo puppet slime to create her Supreme
move NPO Crimson confection guard she
knows that only two dudes in one cheick
will survive but pushes forth either way
and puts your faith in sigiri and Shon
knowing that both of them can make the
final cut together ran with like
complete ease destroys yara's armored
soldiers but it struck in the head after
failing to notice the sneaky kunoichi
charging towards her even still R
manages to Simply send her back with a
down fuse blast however in that moment
she's caught off guard by naruga who
while sliding behind them remembers
shon's teachings and the use of Da and
cuts rian's left arm using tensas Itor
Ryu ultimate pounding torrent technique
with her body beginning to fall a bit
Oran quickly reconnects it and uses the
partially CED Branch arm to grab a hold
of nugi but luckily for our Mountain
Warrior heesu Lim once again cut off by
the blade Dragon who came SW pooping in
Gabby Maru who like comes down from
above notices a perfect opportunity and
in combination with gise merciless eye
killer move Sky Peak splitter uses his
secret art Shandi Gus to simultaneously
light on fire and cut the Immortals
Tandon with ran lift wide open gabimaru
calls out to sigari and Shion to perform
the combined attack to destroy Ren's
tanding stepping forth then and a
perfect motion both of the yada use the
ultimate techniques hid and blade Jewel
wheel motion to buy sex the immortal's
Top PA sending it flying into the air
and bringing the intense battle to an
end and retaliation the tent and simply
claps their hands together revealing
that she's perfectly fine and the events
that had transpired was simply an
illusion of Doubt all created by her
which is actually just freaking mental
looking to her left saryi watches Shon
fall down in front of her with the South
still stand ran walks forth revealing
that everyone except for shugan Isuzu
Karu and Gabby has already fallen
irritated with the pathetic foolishness
of these humans she explains to sakiri
that Hermits are those who touch upon
the truths of this Divine plane the only
thing that has ever remained beyond
their reach is the world of gods
themselves still in her eyes she will
soon reach even that state revealing the
bike Kika state that she wields All That
Remains now in Ran's eyes is the
complete destruction of Wago after
seeing ran enter a kesai form gabimaru
prepares to use his technique against
her yet ran instantly blasts him in the
face with a d lightning bolt before he
is given a chance to attack scary comes
in and actually manages to stab R's
tending from behind but it's told by the
tenton that her Dow is far too weak to
harm her body seeing that sigari was
about to be crushed shugan jumps in to
save her from re's Dow manipulation and
orders both Isuzu and Karu to have the
criminals return to the ship explaining
that they could not allow a monster to
steal the Amada Clan's duty to executed
him which is absolutely crazy that he's
still got like that in the back of his
mind with everything going on right here
any hearing that some of them were going
to like try and Escape ring dismantles
the entirety of the ship's exterior sing
pieces of wood flying everywhere while
keeping the room which your fuku is
placed intact elwe and like while sigiri
holds on to Kiam maru's hand she becomes
extremely shocked to see that the young
asimon has already been crushed by a
piece of debris that was previously seen
flying poor dude rest in peace Kio
that's that's one down seen her comrade
Isuzu becomes shocked and rushes towards
their Direction however Ren senses her
exact location and literally takes
control of isuzu's body before
ultimately crushing her in front of
shugan much to his horror screaming for
both of his friends deaths shugan jumps
up to the immortalist and tries to
attack Ren in a blind fit of rage
sneaking up from behind as well as this
happened gabimaru grabs onto Ren and
sets himself a blaze with an intense
amount of flames which in turn allows a
megalomaniac suan a chance to cut off
one of Ran's arms but also as a side
effect he is caught in those Flames as
well while trying to completely
incinerate her G Maru has a sudden
memory of you face and ends up seizing
his attack realizing that he'll perish
if he continues in his battle looking at
his own hand he notices that his doubt
is starting to resonate with ran and
because of that he falls into a similar
Dark World to that of zuin before
suddenly bursting into a bundle of
flowers and falling to the ground
aried so back before the um Board of the
ship jaica did his you know like his
thing and made a bunch of predictions as
to how the survivors should go about
fighting but believes that there's
absolutely no solution here knowing that
that J himself as I've said decided to
stay on the ship as you know they've got
to have someone Garden it in the present
though J watches the outcome on the ship
and sees that he was right on the
survivors not being able to stop Ren he
then brings out a drinking barrel and
decides to toast the end of Humanity on
board of the skeleton vessel and we're
watching Gabby Maro start to arbery Ren
says that she knows not of his Ambitions
but hopes that he has pleasant dreams
and as she then goes to Landy finishing
blow believes that all those who are
still alive currently will die on this
fire or will lose the well to fight as
soon as they reach Japan sitting there
herself sari feels that she's outly
powerless and reflects on all of the
times that she failed to do anything
against any of the enemies she then
looks at Gabby Maru and begins to say
that she gives up but stops in the
tracks after seeing just how bad his
ocation truly is rising to his feet
himself Shan badly burned from G maru's
Flames orders sary to return to the
other ship so she cannot fight in the
state she is in he looks at the
reflection in his blade and to him it's
obvious that our girl has lost her
resolve after witnessing too many of her
close friends passed away so and since
she is like literally the only he Li of
the clan apart from Jacob his big CH on
the boat he orders her to board the
other vessel as he cannot afford to lose
her having survived being fatally
wounded himself shugan boldly states
that he will make Isuzu and kumaru proud
by eternally carrying out the Clan's
juicy without any doubt within himself
as she senses Shan's Dow surgey sigara
remembers the time shuken congratulated
her for earning a rank and how she would
bring about a change as a woman to the
Clan's male dominant trade speaking up
scary questioned suan if it's even
possible for people to live on without
doubt and if they do does it even
translate to strength over the entire
time of this Mission She's Come face to
face with doubt over and over again her
doubt as well as the doubt of the
criminals executionist and even the
tenson everyone struggles in life and
doubts themselves only to struggle some
more of a abandoning doubt is truly The
Way of the Samurai then like Shon she
rebukes the role and states that she
isn't one in that case with all of the
Fallen Yamada placing a hand on her back
she screams that she refuses to leave
these feelings behind and instead while
picking up her sword exclaims that to
The Bitter End she remain full of doubt
and confusion as for that as who she is
and I'm like hell yeah that's G me the
biggest Spirit of encouragement of
actually ever had while writing this
script and this is for you guys as well
reading this video everyone's way too
hard on each other these days and I'm
way tooo har on myself with like my
pronunciation on words or the way I say
things but this is how I grew up this is
the country I'm in it's the way I speak
get used to it I can't do anything about
it it's like if I was Indian or
something you know like in another part
of the world it's just there's only 4
million of us in New Zealand so it's a
very unique accent and like sigi here
I'm thanking shugan for these words as
we are truly grateful for him looking at
her shugan feels this random ass
sensation emitting from sigiri it's
neither Tranquility or intensity but
something else completely different G
herself then looks back at Gabby Maru
and asks him in her mind if it was okay
for her to have faith skipping back any
a time once passed we see Gabby Maru
being introduced to the eighth daughter
of the chief of iur yui initially she
becomes spooked after gby Maru raises
his hand towards her and Pats her head
as if she's like some sort of pit yui
questions his action to which Gabby Maru
answers that like ever since that day
he'd wanted to become more open with her
revealing that now this is kind of like
a dream state that they're in in on past
memories but in that time it just didn't
feel right he had stolen lives so he
thought he'd never qualify for a normal
life yui says that she doesn't really
like understand where he was coming from
and tells gab Maru that he is still
eligible to have a normal life despite
his past sins she notes that he seemed
to be suffering some kind of pain but
the acts of regret and reflection are
all part of those of atonement she asked
if it was enough that just a single
person accepted him for who he was
causing Gabby to question what she me
meant thinking on this Gabby believes
that it was enough and that he should
accept himself for who he is so that he
can finally be free of his burdens and
move
on in the present now scary raises a
sword above gabim maru's aried body and
tells him that he must accept his
burdens while continuing to live on she
then brings her sword down and executes
the role she was initially charged with
momentarily Gabby regains Consciousness
with his body back to normal and finds
his own flower alight head in front of
him noticing that his sense of self had
finally returned scary explains that she
had to amputate the parts of his body
that were deeply rooted with vines and
used the most outlandish method of D
restoration by pressing his Tandon next
to hers while he stands there impressed
with her approach saryi states that she
canot see a way to defeat the enemy but
it's told by Gabby Maru that they need
to keep fighting as long as they alive
much to her satisfaction Gabby Maru also
thanks aary for leading her back towards
doubt to increase the speed of his
healing she did this SP like guarding
the thoughts in his head bringing up his
wife like Etc when she went to drop the
sword down before after scary jokes
about actually following through with
like her original task I mentioned
before gambing Maru says that they
cannot rely on fate du to the risk of
failure that it's given them and also
readies himself to fight alongside
sigiri together over with the others sh
and aruga fall into the ocean more
carrying Big G who remains unconscious J
then tries to bring them on board the
ship as requested by Shon but falls into
the ocean as well due to being overly
intoxicated after his few sips on the
drink back there before after everyone
including usera is brought back to the
ship J lets them know that it would not
matter if they had saved him since he
believes that ran is utterly Unstoppable
while on the other ship R senses Dow
growing from where giby Maru and sigari
are and looks in their Direction jumping
towards her Rend off a plethora of
attacks by them and uses a bolt of
lightning as an attack on them but Mrs
saryi after Gabby Maru pulls her out of
the way over with the others they all
watch as Gabby Maru and saryi fight in
perfect synchronization but nugo also
point points out that there needs some
sort of strategy in this fight stting
fourth Gabby is handed to Gary sword and
goes in to strike re's Tandon however J
notes that this strategy will not work
since the hinding attribute will lose
the necessary power needed using another
strategy Gabby Maru attempts to use the
Gary as a human sword by holding her
legs and quickly flinging her around but
dismisses the idea after it doesn't work
in the light of the ridiculous tactics R
sees that she cannot afford to waste any
more time fighting them and must take
down seira using her bulked up arms now
over on the other side of the boat
shugan looks at sigiri and remembers the
time he felt worried that she was
selected for the shogun's mission he
assumed that her kindness would be a
hindrance but now in the light of things
starts to see that it doesn't SAR
remembers how Gabby Maru pointed out to
her that she lost her sha due to giving
into anger instead of focusing on the
middle path that gives da its power and
in that moment excepts both strength and
weakness and doubt is that makes her who
she truly is after her doubt is
strengthened sigari attacks ran with a
clear mindset of knowing that she is the
Spear and the lunch pin that will take
ran down while our sneaky while our
sneaky sneaker Gabby Maro is the spy
from within the shadows as after all
being a snitty Shinobi is what he does
best bro that was so sus familiar
moments before sigar made a charge and
remembering that R's true goal is to
revive chuku gabo tells her to remember
what happens when those extreme emotions
take over it weakens the Dow Dows held
together by a clean Discord between both
yin and yang too much sway to either
side and the power Fades so her heart is
filled with rage and indecision then
maybe they have a chance to win in
reality and as sigari is plating the big
boss Gabby Maru lands in the same room
as the guilded statue of Jo fuku causing
the B wannabe to start falling directly
into their trap as he charges towards
Juku curse with his Nino athetic Blaze
activated G knows that when your da was
disrupted sigari will slash your Tandon
the timing has to be perfect but as he
goes to slash down on the floor of the
boat notices that there is a post
wedding BRAC here a flower crown and a
pair of traditional wedding Gars laid
out in front of the statue stunned G
Maru thinks back to when Yara said Ran's
true goal was to revive her master yet
after seeing what's in front of him gab
Mo for the first time realizes that ran
and Joe fuku are indeed a married couple
beginning to falter he tries to push
himself forth as he knows that he needs
to be in perfect scn with sigiri as this
is truly the last moment messing it
means death seeing his wife with a smile
on her face appearing in front of him
now and knowing the pain that it to
cause someone to lose their beloved he
drops to the floor unable to follow
through with his plan unexpectedly
though the merchent of death so order 66
himself shugan the G jumps out from
behind Gabby Maro and screams that to be
a samurai means being prepared to give
up your life at any moment for duty is
the pride of a samurai and the pride of
the clan raising up his sword he
envisions eyes and doing the same free
of thought till death was single
devotion towards the Embrace of death's
warm grasp he brings down his Blade with
a vision of demonic eyes and behind him
allowing him to deal a powerful downbut
slash that not only slices Joe fuku
guilded statue into but the entirety of
his ship itself having witnessed the
confirmed passing of her loved one ran
screams in horror as your late husband's
body is destroyed giving secur the
perfect opportunity to bisect the tenson
and Destroy her plant of Y so with
everything lining up for our girl she
swings her own blade fourth and manages
to slice The Immortal Kikar in two with
the battle finally over Ziri Gabby Maru
and shugan are seen exhausted while the
upper half of the puppet starts to
disintegrate as it falls into the ocean
below having defeated the immortal the
ship starts to fall apart since like the
only thing keeping it together keeping
it held together was ran Dow after
retrieving the electure of Life gabimaru
yells out to saryi to grab his hand
while they make their way back to the
other ship saryi wants to look out for
sh Jan once she turns around and sees
that he had passed away due to
overexerting too much of his doubt on
the previous attack continues forth
randomly Gabby Maru watches as s
suddenly receives a massive
life-threatening gaping wound in her
chest as she was caught off guard and
hit by some sort of Dow infused attack
with Gabby Maru leting out of shock he
turns to see that the culprit is ran who
stands before them with her body being
partially covered in flowers her only
desire was to ever be with her husband
and now because of that she states that
this is the end of everything she
furiously vows to gabimaru that she will
take away everything from him and the
other humans suddenly Gabby maru's left
hand is then crushed by Ran's power
causing him to drop to the ground
himself laying there herself and after
remembering a past lesson from Isen but
how aaku is needed when performing soku
scary comes up with the idea of using
hemostasis on herself like gofar but
quickly concludes that that idea will
not work and help her recover she then
remembers goar's past words to her on
how the only thing each side can do now
is to steal more lives from each other
and Ponders if that was truly the only
recourse they could do after seeing
Gabby Maru punched by Ran's branches
nuga prepares to jump on the boat and
assist him however ji grabs her and
explains that her power would never be
able to stop ran back over with he dying
Immortal and while having gabimaru
suffer for his crimes ran remembers how
he hesitated to destroy Joe fugu's body
and asks him as to why he did so giving
R answers that in the moment he was
about to strike an image of his wife
appeared in his mind which caused him to
end up faltering as ran thinks about her
lost love gab Maru tries to reason with
her saying that maybe because the both
of them had loved ones they could
somwhat relate having heard these words
Ren looked back on her loving memories
with ch fuku how he ended up slowly
starting to grow old and Arbor fire
while she till the very end stayed by
his side remembering the love that she
once felt and beginning to cry herself
she brings her hands together and in one
final act decides to heal Gabby Maru and
secu's wounds with everyone around
watching this bizarre change and like
the battle like they just I guarantee
you no one saw this one coming ran
starts to finally disintegrate turning
her body into a bunch of beautiful
flower Pit and the afterlife had said
that ran who was finally at peace
managed to have her soul reunite with
her
husband over on the other boat though
job while like mad intoxicated becomes
happy with the outcome of the battle and
tells Gabby Mar and sigiri that he had
faith in them all along much to there as
well as like Shion rugi and gze
annoyance on the other hand though user
Rea suggests and forgiving him since
like he is the one in charge of staring
the ship back to the mainland as they
all slowly make their way towards Ido
now which is around about an hour away
according to Shon he informs everyone
that he and the rug guy will not be
returning and will instead go their
separate ways on a small boat he also
reminds them about their situation of
who will get the pardon Upon returning
and that's that's right guys only one
person is getting this pardon two men
one woman it's fate you can't break fate
I tell you now but right now like before
we get to the end of the video I'd love
to actually know who you personally
think the survivors are this to me is
just like an amazing part of the story
and it wraps up everything so
beautifully it's like form to Alchemist
where you just the last like few
episodes of that it's just I love it so
much and I can't wait to see what the
anime does with it anyway after seeing
saryi depressed about everything like
that is about to happen with all of her
friends departing and stuff Yia tells
her that a happy ending was never going
to be possible for them and asks if an
executioner like her started to become
fond of criminals Siri wipes away the
tears and happily answers yes as after a
while she came to see them as people
deare to her heart and asks if it was
wrong of her to not know what to do in
this situation us reard says no and
points out that everyone else beside
herself was actually a villain which
leads to everyone having this like
helious conversation about just how
villainous each person is after everyone
ends up pointing Gabby Mar and his wife
out as evil Gabby shocks everyone after
he laughs at the ridiculous notion of
yui being a villain having become
interested and wanting to know more
about his wife the group then sits down
and asks Gabby Maro to tell them more
about her to he agrees and after the
conversation is finally finished Yara
Gabby Maru gasai and sigiri all stand up
together to try and figure out who will
return with the elure of life my voice
is actually giving up I don't know if
you guys can hear it it's like croaky at
some point shortly after the then
becomes informed that his ship had
returned from the island Voyage with
only two men and one woman boarding it
drum roll
[Music]
please at the magistrate's office sigari
and Ja present themselves to the Shogun
as the only two surviving aimons to make
it out alive and are ordered by Aoki to
make the report scarying remembers back
to how JC said he will take the
initiative on make you in report but
wonders as to how he will do so and
Chica looks completely different now
he's like mixed up a sty almost looks
like a chick in some kind of way like
his goody too's ch right here chica
first bows his head in complete
gratitude for being assigned with the
mission and tells them that since shukan
has lost his life during the mission he
will be the one to make the report chica
then presents the Deliverance of the
elixir of life and presents that the
only surviving criminal was Gant tetai
the blade dragon with this Tamaya Gant
tetai is then pardoned by the Shogun and
I never not for a second doubted Big G I
knew this is I knew my man was going to
take it home like the blade
Dragon no way was he going to die on
that island everyone knows that he has
to has to die in infamy you know what I
mean like that's the only way I wanted
to see is to I go out anyway before
allowing Aoki to end all matters J asks
him about the arrangements that were
made concerning the I Chief sneakily
auki confirmed sikia that the iur chief
was dealt with after the letter
testified that the leader had his own
Ambitions drain the mission which was
viewed as treason against the Shogun so
because of that he was taken out much to
like yeah know see G Shock as they show
him like they're taking out evidence and
stuff I can't really
show also reports that the body of the
chief has been transformed into a tree
after they forc him to test the effects
of the elure before beheading him as per
jica suggestion after he probably got
back on imagine anyway ok then questions
if the state of the chief could be
viewed as immortality but it's convinced
by chica that the Shogun could possibly
live for I as a Divine tree to watch
over his family in exchange for his
Humanity which I think is just hilarious
like imagine being stuck as a tree for
human like I would hate it like the
dread after the business with the shoken
was finally over J absolutely naked
falls down and becomes pleased that
things went according to his plan
earlier on the ship J saw that Gabby
Maru and yuzar had pet game toite as the
one to receive the pardon due to was
high reputation and sugess that they
themselves actually abandoned their own
names in former life upon separating on
boat as obviously usera is just like a
random ninja that had like a few things
known about her and Gabby Maru himself
is just a name passed down throughout
iok kakur so his face specifically isn't
actually know anyway as they prepare to
depart scar receives a goodbye hug from
nugi and yells out her farewells to
usera who happily waves back already
having started to leave on her own
vessel looking over she then sees that
Gabby Maru as the last to depart the two
then meet each other's gazes and as
Gabby Mara walks by happily says their
goodbyes without even having to say a
damn word to each other and damn I love
this panel just the smiles on their
faces as like Gabby walks past there
brings a tear to my eye like when I
first read it it truly did like all of
this part here my throat when I was
writing this script was so like sore cuz
I was just I was wanting to B my eyes
out it's just so beautiful anyway in the
present J sees sigari thinking about
like all of the others and tries to
cheer her up stating that it was fate
that brought everyone together and now
all they can do is hope that whatever
path they're on in life it will make
them happy after hearing these words
saryi looks up happy for everyone with a
smile as she begins to cry meanwhile
Toma is also revealed to have somehow
found a boat and departed Kotaku alive
but also not by himself dude is
mysteriously accompanied by an unknown
person skipping away for him from now
though after the arrangements were made
by J with the chief being taken out it
meant that yui would obviously be all
right as well and Gabby Mara would be
able to go back to the clan or like
leave with yui and they' be able to
travel off and live happily somewhere
else gab Mar who had finally managed to
make it home becomes shocked to see his
wife yui standing a top some stairs and
eagerly runs towards her after finally
being reunited the couple then sit out
on their own path in life so we finally
made it after 126 chapters we have made
it to our boy made and his wife again
she ain't fake she exist and didn't have
to MK Big G along the process it's pure
Bliss in my eyes right here skipping
forth in time over in a British Hong
Kong during the mid 1800s a young man
sitting in a chair notices that the men
looking down do not look like the local
to which he is informed by his brother
that these men are from England due to
the recent War causing chaos and Power
in the area yeah you know who it is you
you guys know who this is the banit
brothers Toma and chob big chilling and
back together chob like hearing this
becomes pleased since he he believes
that this is an opportunity for him to
take over the city and declares to the
Englishman that he now rules over the
underworld from here on out just dope
hair and I love the fact that so TOA
obviously never made it back to the
mainland of Japan and it said probably
like sailed off C ended up on or in
China and back like Hong Kong area which
is quite like a I I guess that's
probably where goofa went and like goofa
knows the language there and everything
as well so they wouldn't have been
completely confused I really really like
that ending for him and it doesn't like
conflict with everyone in the main land
as well back in the room though one of
the English men suddenly whoops out a
gun and calls chob a freaking baby which
to translates for his brother and after
learning that he was insulted chob
transforms into his breakdown State and
Mer the dude for just insulting him at
the same time in a tea house in Japan
her tooshi domain Shon gives his opinion
on nuka's new appearance saying that she
was too young to wear that but it's told
by her that she refers as new look and
the other girls around her all dress the
same rukai is then head on by two random
men which she found fluttering but Shon
obviously Wards them off as a threat
rugo becomes disappointed but is given a
lecture by her like pretty much Dad
figure about how all the men in this
world are either beasts or thieves
noticing some like dirt or food on her
face begins to clean it off the two then
decide to head off together to try and
find the r guys's people and having
watched this entire thing a random woman
wonders if they are father and daughter
despite not seeing any resemblance
meanwhile and over with sari and yera
while they're traveling they talk about
how Gant has actually opened up a dojo
dedicated towards medicine and
swordsmanship he ring fochi I love that
and a flash over there and after
finishing up a patient himself Gant
toite has issued a challenged by a man
at the door but yells at him to silence
himself I love it just a parallels to
like who he was in the past and I've got
the biggest smile on my face right now
sary then reveals that J has taken over
the Yamada Clan as the next head and is
now enjoying an easy life just like he
wanted which is dope for our man after
being tasked by usera as to like why she
chose to travel scary answers that it
was a good way to help her polish who
blade testing skills but also says that
she wanted to leave home for a little
while us figures that her current joury
is is most likely to visit Gabby Maro
but remembers her past statement on it
being a bad idea to do so sary replies
that she couldn't help the urge for a
little reunion so obviously pointing out
that she wanted to go and find Gabby
marrow then asks her mate why she also
decided to accompany her to what usia
answers it's because she wants to be her
bodyguard who secretly loves her looking
over at a random woman though us R her
then spots yoi outside her house and as
soon as aary sees her as well screams at
her name in Surprise standing outside
their house together the three girls all
introduce each other and began having a
chat about all of the things that have
happened with them once they walk inside
Yi offers to wake G Maru up to have him
see them which causes the CHS to be
surprised as Gabby Maru probably didn't
sleep at all throughout the entire time
on the island apart from like the
obvious Knockouts and he refused to
sleep when he was told to scary also
finds it hard to believe this but states
that he was no longer the same Gabby Mar
as before all of them then roll over to
check up on Gabby Maro and after seeing
just how out towe he is states that they
probably can't Rouse him as dude's G
from stray cat to literal house cat
letting him be then we skip away from
Gabby for the final time of the entire
series and leave the three women as well
to have a fat Yar with each other about
everything that has happened so far time
then slowly slips forward several
centuries to where we find gofar running
an online class while living in human
society finally like hell's Paradise
ended drain over so this whole online
class thing hits different when you
think that for the last 2 years this man
was writing the series he was probably
stuck indoors doing so but anyway man
enters the room to tell kufar that jar
and daar have sprouted which was a lot
earlier than anticipated then walking
off together goofa then says that he
hopes all of the others progress just as
well so have we made it did we make it
to the end of this what like 5 Hour 6
hour long video now with me discussing
the entirety of how's Paradise this here
honestly what is it like the actual
first series where I've been able to
probably discuss an entire series that
has probably ended I I don't think I've
been able to do that with anything else
so far cuz chainsawman has decided to
continue on I'm too lazy to you with
good old Tokyo Avengers because that
final Arc man oh my God I can't I can't
get over that final Arc but this final
Arc and this story here this is how you
end storying man this is how you're
meant to do it like Yuki Kaku actually
has an understanding of how you're
supposed to finish everything out you're
not meant to give too much you know like
that's what that's what I find with a
lot of stories these days is that they
give us too much with these endings they
go over the top you know and they give
us the story 10 years ahead or they give
us the story a few hundred years ahead
and Yuki Kaku might have done that but
he
gave us a little sprinkle there wasn't
much where he went a few hundred years
into the future and was like this is
what everyone's up to they're doing this
this this and that here's their family
we got a little taster of that with kind
of Gabby Maro but everyone else we kind
of flew around and just got an update on
what they're up to seeing you know Shon
and arug guy and they're part of the
world and they're just chilling together
trying to find their family members and
knowing that everyone's kind of happy
doing their own thing now really really
resonated with me and it was just it was
too dope seeing Big G Gant tetai
actually get his pardon and make it out
of there alive and then it was like the
parallel of him finally you know running
and starting his own Dojo like I assume
his sense probably had his own Dojo or
his master had his own dojo and then
that dude who runs in and is like yo big
G Fight me I want to take you on here
you're like a the blade Dragon Samurai
and it's just like the parallel from who
he was at the beginning of the story and
him screaming at this dude to shut up
and not fight him anymore it's too
amazing he's probably going to train
this dude to you know like just like he
trained him and all the stuff that you
get to think about that could possibly
happen but that isn't explained by the
manga themselves is what I love about a
great ending to the story it leaves us
pondering like what could happen but in
a in a happy State not in a not in a
state of like confusion where we don't
know what just happened we know what's
happened and we know everyone's actually
happy and we can just sit back and be
like that was a good series because Yuki
Kaku that was a brilliant series
honestly everyone go out and read like
hell's Paradise go Ahad and buy the uh
the story because I haven't let I
haven't put everything in here obviously
that does happen throughout the story
and there is so much that like I just I
just left out like the little details
the stuff that that means a lot that
maybe you didn't pick up on because it
wasn't in the video and that you need to
know and you're like maybe that's why
this thing happened because I couldn't
understand what he was talking about
here it'll be because I've you know left
out a tiny little bit Honestly though
I'd love to know your guys' thoughts on
what you thought about the series how
you possibly wanted to like to end did
you want R to come out on top and
absolutely wipe everyone roll up to
Japan and then just you know commit her
Divine Banco plan to bring back her
husband at the end of the day what did
you think about the meaning or like the
the message of the story that it was
trying to push to us on how to believe
in yourself and to not like think that
the indecision or the anxiety like we
have a lot in these days you know in
these day Society or the depression that
we get sometimes you get into these bad
states that you're not meant to be in
but sometimes if you just believe in
yourself you can push through you know I
have a a big confidence is issue I find
sometimes so that whole Last Arc there
was Gary and her just being like I can
do this really really resonated me with
me and that's why I kind of popped off
in the video there and was just like yes
because it it's you know it was too good
it was actually too good but either way
as I said I'd love to know what you guys
thoughts are on the series down below
what do you want me to cover next and if
you guys do want to get earlier access
to these videos you know like a few days
beforehand before I release them here on
YouTube same with these larger Arc ones
where at least them like a week or two
before I do on YouTube like the full
story ones then make sure you check out
my patreon which I will leave down in
the description below as honestly it
truly helps me out with like so much
being able to tral different editors and
all that kind of stuff to possibly you
know put out more content in the future
it's really hard with the level of
detail that I edit these videos to these
days to be able to put out a video say
every week or 2 weeks or even every 3
weeks sometimes depending on how long
the videos are so all the support that
does happen on patreon is truly like it
truly means a lot and means I can focus
more on making the content better and
looking for script writers who
understand the way that I talk and all
that kind of Ja
but either way if you are new around
here as well and just want to support me
in general then do hit that subscribe
button because you know what are we what
are we now 155k pushing into 200k 200k
before the end of the year surely with
the amount of content that I've got
planned like one punch man we've got
like steel poool run coming out soon
like can you guys believe that I've
actually started editing still will run
moving forward like I said just
subscribe if you guys are new around
here and want to watch a bunch of videos
like these and leave a like push this
video to 10K likes show me that you want
another full series explain video that's
like 7 hours long or whatever but for
now it's been your professional degener
at deolo and I will see you all and a b
bye